hey everyone in this week's episode
we'll talk about the most popular and
commonly used programming language
python so let's begin and learn about
the development of python and gain
insights about the current it Trends but
before that make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to get
notified every time we come up with new
content python is very famous for its
simple programming syntax core
readability and English like commands
that make coding a lot easier and
efficient due to this it is the most
popular and preferred language python
has interpreted high level general
purpose programming language developed
by Guido van rossim at National Research
Institute for mathematics and computer
science Netherlands in contrast to
popular belief that python was named
after the snake python was actually
named after the show Monty Python's
Flying Circus
Guido van Rossum formulated python in
the late 1980s as a successor to the ABC
language in 1994 python version 1.0 was
released with features like exception
handling Lambda map filter and reduce
python 2.0 released in 2000 introduced
features like list comprehensions and a
garbage collection system capable of
collecting reference Cycles python 3.0
was released on the 3rd of December
2008. undoubtedly Python 2.x and 3.x
have proven to be the most used versions
as of today python 3.7.4 is the latest
stable version released in the summer of
2019. python is popularly used for
development scripting and software
testing top ID companies like Google
Facebook Instagram Spotify and Netflix
among others use Python some major
applications of python can be seen in
the fields of machine learning
artificial intelligence data science and
iot python also offers many libraries
like numpy sci-fi Keras tensorflow
Django and flask pep 8 is the official
style guide that defines the styling
conventions for python code a few
popular open source python projects
include pep EnV statistics solving the
traveling salesman problem using
self-organizing maps and python to BPF
converter some of the trending python
repositories on GitHub today include NLP
ml from scratch pytorch Transformers 100
days of ml code among others popular
websites on the internet like Reddit and
quora are built using python
civilization 4 Battlefield 2 Sims 4 and
World of Tanks are some popular games
developed using python according to
indeed the average salary of a python
developer in India is about 5 lakhs per
annum and that in the US is around 124
000 US Dollars users and admirers of
python especially those considered
knowledgeable are referred to as
pythonous pythony stars and pythonians
since its Inception python has come a
long way to become the most popular
coding language and continues to
revolutionize the IT industry python is
a widely popular programming language
that is used for web development game
development data analysis as well as
data visualization
hi everyone
welcome to this python developer full
course by simply loan in this session we
will cover all the important python
Concepts techniques and projects that
will help you become a successful python
developer a highly experienced trainers
will take you through this live session
but before I begin make sure to
subscribe to the simply learn Channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update
so we will start by learning the history
of python and understand the top 10
reasons to Learn Python you will look at
the job role of a python developer the
skills they need to possess and how the
resume of a python developer should be
then
we'll see how to install Python and the
Anaconda distribution of python
then we will shift our Focus towards
learning the basics of python such as
data types variables operators lists
tuples and dictionaries next we will
understand about loops and conditional
statements after that we'll get an idea
about object oriented programming
Concepts and functions in Python we will
also cover some important Advanced
Python Programming Concepts such as
iterators modules generators as well as
packages finally we will see the
important python interview questions
that are often asked so let's get
started let's begin and learn about the
development of python and gain insights
about the current ID Trends python is
very famous for its simple programming
syntax core readability and English like
commands that make coding a lot easier
and efficient due to this it is the most
popular and preferred language python
has interpreted high level general
purpose programming language developed
by Widow van Rawson at National Research
Institute for mathematics and computer
science Netherlands in contrast to
popular belief that python was named
after this snake python was actually
named after the show Monty Python's
Flying Circus
Guido and Rossum formulated python in
the late 1980s as a successor to the ABC
language in 1994 python version 1.0 was
released with features like exception
handling Lambda map filter and reduce
python 2.0 released in 2000 introduced
features like list comprehensions and a
garbage collection system capable of
collecting reference Cycles python 3.0
was released on the 3rd of December
2008. undoubtedly Python 2.x and 3.8
have proven to be the most used versions
as of today python 3.7.4 is the latest
stable version released in the summer of
2019. python is popularly used for
development scripting and software
testing top ID companies like Google
Facebook Instagram Spotify and Netflix
among others use Python some major
applications of python can be seen in
the fields of machine learning
artificial intelligence data science and
iot python also offers many libraries
like numpy sci-fi Keras tensorflow
Django and flask pep 8 is the official
style guide that defines the styling
conventions for python code a few
popular open source python projects
include with EnV statistics solving the
traveling salesman problem using
self-organizing match and python to BPF
converter some of the trending python
repositories on GitHub today include NLP
ml from scratch pytotch Transformers 100
days of ml code among others popular
websites on the internet like Reddit and
quora are built using python
civilization 4 Battlefield 2 Sims 4 and
World of Tanks are some popular games
developed using python according to
indeed the average salary of a python
developer in India is about 5 lakhs per
annum and that in the US is around 124
000 US Dollars users and admirers of
python especially those considered
knowledgeable are referred to as
pythonous pythony stars and pythonians
since its Inception python has come a
long way to become the most popular
coding language and continues to
revolutionize the IT industry so what
really is Python programming language
python is an object oriented high-level
programming language that supports
built-in data structures and dynamic
semantics
it's supposed multiple programming
paradigms such as structured object
oriented and functional programming
python is often described as batteries
included language because it has a
comprehensive collection of standard
libraries
python supports different modules and
packages which allows program modularity
and code reuse
python was developed by Guido van Rossum
and its implementation started in
December 1989.
python 1.0 version was released in the
year 1994 python 2.0 came out in October
2000 while python 3.0 was released in
December 2008.
now that you have got an understanding
of the Python programming language let's
now look at the top 10 reasons why you
should learn python
so at number 10 we have ease of use
one of the most common reasons to like
python is that it is quite easy to learn
and code
it provides a simple syntax that
improves readability and makes it easier
to understand so developers can create
any desktop or machine based application
using this language
python is very versatile and is
instrumental in artificial intelligence
and machine learning
we will talk about this later in the
session compared to Java or CC plus plus
it has fewer lines of codes
in the example here we are printing a
hello world program in Java as you can
see
if you have to write a program in Java
you first have to declare the class name
along with its scope
next using curly braces you need to pass
the main method along with its arguments
and then using system.out.print element
method you can print hello world that's
quite a tedious task isn't it
the same task for printing hello world
can be done using just one line of code
in python as shown here you can write
the print function and pass whatever you
want to display inside the brackets and
that will print the output it is so
simple
that is why python is considered as a
high level language and its open source
you can just download it from the
website and start using it
at 9 we have active community
you need a community to learn new
technology and friends are your best
asset when it comes to learning a
programming language python has large
community support
it has an extensive and active Community
to assist Engineers developers analysts
and data scientists with expert support
in case of programming errors or issues
with the software
you can just go ahead and put your
queries in the community forum the
community members will address your
queries in real quick time
communities like stack Overflow also
brings many python experts together to
help learners
python enhancement proposals or pep is
where the proposals and the improvements
are announced
also there are a set of recommendations
or core values called the design of
python written by Tim petos that
represents the guiding principles for
python development
up next at 8 we have portable and
extensible
multiple cross-language operations can
be performed effectively because python
is portable and extensible in nature
for example if the users have a python
code written on Windows and they want to
execute on a Mac operating system or
Linux operating system or Solaris they
can easily do it without any Amendment
they can also run this code on any
platform flawlessly and without any
interrupt
due to its extensibility feature you can
integrate other programming languages
such as java.net C and C plus codes with
python
the components of other programming
languages can be used with python and
thus it can be used to make a
cross-platform suitable application too
so it is a really good feature that
python provides
the next Reason To Learn Python is
testing Frameworks
python supports several built-in
Flawless testing tools and Frameworks
that help in debugging and speeding up
workflows
some of the tools and Frameworks
supported by python are by test selenium
and Splinter this is the reason for
which every tester tries to use Python
based tools and Frameworks to test any
application or code or to validate it in
an easier manner pie test is the most
recommended testing framework for
functional integrational and unit
testing
you can run selenium test scripts using
Python programming language to automate
various tasks and Splinter is an open
source tool for testing web applications
using python
it lets you automate browser actions
such as visiting URLs and interacting
with their items
at number 6 we have libraries and
packages
another reason why python has become so
popular in the industry these days is
that it has a massive collection of
libraries and packages that make your
task simple and easy
it has a range of libraries packages
Frameworks and modules for data
manipulation statistical calculation web
development machine learning and data
science
python programmers have developed tons
of free and open source libraries that
you can use
you can find many of them via python
package index the repository of python
software python provides the default
package called pip Anaconda is a third
party python ecosystem other examples
include numpy scipy and xango
then we have scripting and automation
python is not just a programming
language it can also be used for writing
scripts for automating tasks and
workflows without human intervention
the code can be written in the form of
scripts and executed later further it is
interpreted by the machine and checked
for errors at runtime
the machine is used to read and
interpret the code
once the developer checks the code it
can further run or be used several times
without any interruption
this allows you to automate a set of
certain tasks within a program or the
same code can be used with other
applications as well
at number 4 we have web development
another reason to Learn Python is that
it makes the web development process so
much easier
it provides a wide collection of
Frameworks that make it easier for
developers to develop web applications
some of the examples are Django flask
pyramid turbo gears cherry pie Etc
these Frameworks are written in Python
which makes the code a lot faster and
stable
the task which used to take hours in PHP
can be finished in minutes using python
python is also used for web scraping
Django offers many elements of intricate
programs such as template design
management panel signing in signing up
signing out URL routing Etc
once the user establishes the framework
all these features become ready to use
flask
is a microwave framework written in
Python
of all the components that are part of
this module they are all ready to
execute in the server context
Pinterest and Linkedin use flask
pyramid offers more attributes than
flask it will assist users with URL
routing and authentication support
turbo gears is a highly recommended and
scalable framework that supports
features such as authentication caching
identification management of sessions
and pluggable applications
up next at number three
we have machine learning
the growth of machine learning has been
phenomenal in the last five years and
it's rapidly changing the world around
us
python is one of the most preferred
programming languages for machine
learning because of its simple syntax
and support for several machine learning
libraries
using different libraries and functions
in Python the system can learn and train
itself from past data
once the system is trained it can then
learn to adjust itself to new inputs
finally it can make predictions and
perform human-like tasks automatically
at number 2 we have data science
machine learning and data science go
hand in hand python is robust scalable
and provides extensible visualization
and Graphics options hence it is widely
used in data science
python has libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data pandas for
operations to manipulate data on
numerical tables and time series it also
provides simply for symbolic computation
and sci-fi for Technical and scientific
computations
it has another Library called Pi brain
which is sought for python-based
reinforcement learning artificial
intelligence and neural network library
scikit-learn is the machine learning
library for creating classification
regression and clustering algorithms and
finally it provides Pi torch and
tensorflow for deep learning
finally coming to the most important and
the top reason to Learn Python which is
career opportunities and salary
Python language provides a variety of
job opportunities and Promises a high
growth graph with huge salary prospects
it has been used by most of the tech
Giants
industry leaders using python are Amazon
Google Facebook IBM NASA Netflix and
YouTube
next you can see the Google Trends
but I have considered three programming
languages python Java and C plus I have
compared them for the past 12 months you
can see it clearly on your screens that
python has become a front runner in
terms of popularity and web search
volume
it means people are interested in Python
they want to learn it and use it in
their work
you can also check for the YouTube
search
there also you will find that Python
programming language is the most
searched language on YouTube
now on your screens
you can see the report of pypl which is
popularity of programming language index
it is created by analyzing how often
language tutorials are searched on
Google
it is a leading indicator the raw data
comes from Google Trends
the bar graph depicts that python is the
most popular and widely used programming
language across the globe followed by
Java then JavaScript and c-sharp
the popularity of programming language
index can help you decide which language
to study or which one to use in a new
software project
the next graph shows the popularity of
python and Java over the years starting
from 2004 till the current period which
is 2020 worldwide python is the most
popular language
python grew the most in the Last 5 Years
by 19.4 percent and Java lost the most
by minus 7.2 percent
now let's talk about the different
career opportunities and the job roles
that you can get into If You Learn
Python language
first
you can become a python developer
where you will be asked to write and
test codes debug programs and integrate
applications with third-party web
services
second
you can become a web developer here you
will be responsible for writing
server-side web application logic python
web developers usually develop back-end
components connect the application with
third-party services and support the
front-end developers by integrating
their work with the python application
you can also become a data analyst if
you know python as a data analyst you
have to gather data from multiple
sources using scripts analyze that data
develop and Implement databases and data
collection systems
you can become a data scientist
as a data scientist you need to
understand the challenges in business
and come up with the best Solutions
using modern tools and techniques to
analyze visualize and build prediction
models to make business decisions
lastly you can be a machine learning
engineer where you can develop
intelligent machines that can learn from
vast volumes of data and apply knowledge
without human intervention
so there's a lot of Scopes If You Learn
Python
now let's have a look at the salaries of
some of these job roles
so if you become a python developer you
can earn an average salary of 76 526
dollars per annum in the United States
while in India you can earn an average
of 4 lakhs 98 000 rupees per annum
also
If You Learn Python and become a data
scientist
you can expect an average salary of
hundred and thirty thousand dollars per
year in the United States while in India
you can earn an average of 10 lakhs 28
000 rupees per annum
let me now go ahead and call out the 10
reasons for learning python once again
at number 10 we had ease of use at
number nine we had active community at
eight we had the portable and extensible
feature of python at number seven we saw
the testing Frameworks
at six we had libraries and packages
then at five we saw scripting and
automation followed by web development
then we had machine learning and data
science at number three and number two
respectively
and finally at number one we had career
opportunities and salary
so who is a python developer let's
answer this so here are some of the
Technologies used by a python developer
pandas Anaconda tensorflow python Ides
Django web framework and patreon a
python developer is one Who develops
backend components of a web application
using python when working as a web
developer now the web Frameworks like
Django and flask are used for this
purpose
a python developer is also the one who
writes effective testable and scalable
python code he also performs data
analysis when working in the field of
data science so basically a python
developer develops deploys debugs and
maintains a project so let's go through
the skill set of a python developer now
the core python skills that a python
developer possesses are data structures
like arrays list stack queues trees and
graphs there's oop Concepts like
inheritance classes and objects and
abstraction thus packages and functions
that is importing external packages into
a python code database and its
connection that is connecting a python
backend to a database like MySQL when it
comes to data science skills there's
numpy that is a library for performing
mathematical calculations
let's pandas that is the library for
storing and manipulating data
efficiently this scipy and then there is
matplotlib which is a library for
plotting charts and graphs for a given
data and finally there are machine
learning algorithms which consists of
models like supervised learning
unsupervised Etc now coming to web
developer skills there are Frameworks
like Django and flask for back-end
development of web applications
and then there's web scraping which
includes taking data from websites and
converting that data into usable format
there's API handling which is basically
handling API requests for a web
application to perform server-side
operations and finally there is back-end
connection which basically involves the
back-end part of a web application
usually handled by python Frameworks
now moving on let's look at the python
developer job roles
first up this python web developer now a
python web developer usually writes
server-side code works on the web
Frameworks like Django and flask
collaborates with the data team together
end users requirements develops the
server-side platform deploys
applications performs tuning usability
Improvement and automation
moving on next job role is data analyst
now a data analyst generally works on
python libraries including matplotlip
numpy pandas Etc carry out data analysis
collect by using the scripting language
explore data sets gather requirements
tune in applications analyze problems
communicate findings with the team or
stakeholders
the next job role is automation test
engineer
now an automation test engineer usually
works on python test framework tools
including Pi test Pi unit perform
complex system tests troubleshoot code
issues create test scripts design the
automation framework perform a b testing
next up is machine learning engineer
now a machine learning engineer has the
following roles to perform statistical
analysis of data put machine learning
models into production research and
transform data science prototypes
research and Implement appropriate ml
algorithms and tools perform ml tests
and keep updated with the ml trends
the last job role is software engineer
now a software engineer is expected to
write server-side code collaborate with
the design team to gather end users
requirements develop the server-side
platform deploy applications perform
tuning usability Improvement and
automation
moving on to the next topic let's look
at the python developer salary trends
now software Engineers with python
skills are offered better salaries
across the globe
the average salary of a python developer
in India is around 7 lakhs 55 000 rupees
per annum the average salary of a python
developer in the US is about 79 000 US
dollars per annum
moving on to our last segment python
developer resume
so let's go ahead and understand what a
python developer resume should portray
just keep a few things in mind when
you're preparing your resume
your resume should be clear updated and
concise
you should prioritize the skills
according to the job role you're
applying for and do not write anything
extra that's a big no the recruiters are
smart enough to know that so do not lie
and do not write extra firstly let's
look at the fresher resuming so if
you're a fresher these are some of the
points that you need to know
first you have the resume header now the
summary is supposed to be clear and
concise just say what exactly you want
and some of your strengths next is the
profile links and your portfolio so you
can mention your LinkedIn profile link
and also your GitHub repository link if
you have next up is the projects now
clearly depict the goal of your project
so just in case you worked on like C5
projects make sure you keep it concise
and crisp next up is your education do
not lie here make sure you give a
relevant education with grades next you
have the certifications if you have any
certifications or achievements go ahead
and write them down next you have the
technical skills now again prioritize
according to the job role and lastly you
have your non-technical skills this
could be your communication analytical
skills problem solving skills Etc moving
on to an experienced developer so again
mention the resume header
then you have the summary again very
crisp and clear go ahead and mention
your portfolios and your links coming to
experience now here you'll have to
clearly depict your work you'll have to
make sure that you write down all your
responsibilities in that company do not
go overboard and write extra keep it
very concise
again relevant education and your grades
you have technical skills the same goes
for this as well prioritize according to
the job role and finally you have your
non-technical skills now let's go over
some of the features of python and these
features are actually why it's
considered that using python is
advantageous over using other languages
so let's start with some of these points
now as we mentioned python is very it's
a very readable program code readability
is very important it's one of the design
philosophies behind this when it was
being developed it's very easy to learn
which is why python is an entry point
for many people that are just beginning
to learn programming and as I mentioned
earlier it's a high level language in
Python we since python is open source as
as I had already mentioned so it gets it
benefits from all the the benefits you
get from any open source technology now
it's also portable so what this means is
that if we create a code in in Python
and we create in a particular system on
Windows we don't need to make any
changes if we wanted to use the same
script or that same piece of code on
some other system say on a Linux system
or a Mac system python itself comes with
a very large standard Library this this
facilitates us a lot because we don't
need to create our own libraries or
modules or have to download very
specific libraries most of the problems
that we do encounter quite commonly can
already be solved by the standard
libraries that have already been
provided by the developers of python
right right from the beginning now later
later on during the course we will
encounter what is the meaning of a data
structure a data structure is
essentially a manipulation of a if of an
object of an object of data and as as
you will see later python has one of the
most user-friendly data structures that
can be found in any language especially
compared to some of its contemporaries
now python is a dynamically programmed
language and this is very important and
what this means is that in most
compiler-based languages we there are
certain processes that can only happen
during the compilation stage so what a
dynamic programming language does is it
takes all those compilation specific
tasks and processes and it does it for
us as we actually type the code so we
don't need to waste time or spend extra
time to do something that would
otherwise be needed to be only done in
compilation we would have to set out
specific uh run time just for that so
this allows us to create our programs
and solutions much faster and allows us
to debug much easier and yeah so it's a
it's a very important feature about
python Now quickly I will just go over
some of the areas of python where like
areas of or different domains where
python is very heavily implemented and
the first one the first few ones that
come to reminder like web development
and Ai and machine learning so you have
Technologies like Django and Flash that
are built on top of python that I use
extensively for web development when it
comes to something like artificial
intelligence or machine learning you
have distributions such as Anaconda you
have pandas and many other libraries
like scipy and numpy that are used
extensively too so tackle problems in
this domain and similarly python finds
used in most of the scientific work that
goes on nowadays because of again some
of the libraries that I have already
mentioned such as sci-fi interestingly
if you are into game development or
gaming in general you would see that
python actually has certain libraries
and certain technologies that facilitate
game development very very well one very
popular game in fifth in case you are
into gaming is a world of tanks that is
built on python some of the other
applications are of course desktop be
creating desktop guise image processing
graphic design applications and
something that is very relevant to me
and of course you as well is a creation
of education programs and training
courses uh there are many Technologies
in the environment of python that were
almost designed for the specific purpose
of being able to present certain
Concepts or to be able to teach certain
classes and I can't think of too many
programs or too many environments
outside of python that are better to
solve these Education and Training
course related problems and situations
let's uh let's get to actually
installing python so now that so I will
show you how to install python on
Windows since I have a Windows system
however I will also point out the way
you you would have to install python on
a on Mac OS or Linux or even on mobile
so yeah let's get started so to install
python on your Windows computer it's as
simple as going to the website
python.org and selecting the download
section when you reduce click on
downloads you get redirected to this
website that this webpage that I'm on
out here it by default it will ask you
if you want to download python 3.9 which
is the latest version but of course if
you for whatever reason if you needed a
particular version of python you can
download that as well by just scrolling
down and choosing the option that you
want now it's important to note that
whatever option you choose of course I
would recommend the latest one but no
matter what option you choose I would
recommend you choose a version of python
three point something because previous
versions of python namely Python 2.7 and
uh and basically every version of python
two point something has it will not
receive any more maintenance and updates
because the developers have decided that
python will that trying to shift towards
the maintaining and updating python
three point whatever completely right
now so yeah let's not delay this uh any
further and let's download python 3.9 so
once you select the option out here uh
you'll be you'll get an installer all
you have to do is click on that and
it'll give you two options to customize
installation or install now I would of
course recommend this blue install now
since you're a beginner do not worry
about what a custom installation is if
you have multiple drives in your system
by default the python will be downloaded
into uh the drive where your windows is
actually installed your your main drive
so as you can see now that once my setup
is done it should give me a pop-up soon
so my setup is done for Python and this
is essentially how you would
um download python on your Windows
system but what if you had Mac OS or if
you were using Linux well for Mac it's a
it's actually almost as simple you just
go if you see our here below this
download button python option you get
the website asking you are you looking
for python on a different OS and it
gives you the options of Linux Mac and
even other os's but for Mac if you
wanted you would just open this tab and
just like the windows option you would
choose a version and you would choose an
installer for that version so if I
wanted say python the latest one I would
just download this installer and I would
install in my Mac system now when it
comes to Linux I cannot show you exactly
how you would install it there are
certain commands that you have to
execute but essentially again if you
would just choose the Linux option out
here it would take you to a page with a
different installers and essentially
packages for Linux systems in specific
what I would recommend to you if you are
a Linux user and you need python is to
go over to the realpython.com website
and they have a very good uh essentially
instructions on how to install Python
and since I don't have a Linux system
them I cannot directly show you how to
install python on Linux so yeah if you
do have Linux please head over to this
website and this should be of a lot of
help to you now as I had mentioned you
can actually install python on your
mobile devices as well so if you were
say an iOS user you would go to the iOS
App Store and download an app called the
python is the app for iOS it essentially
is like a full-fledged python
environment where you can develop in
Python on your iPhone or even iPad and
if you're an Android User you could you
would go and download an app called the
pi Droid 3. there's a free version and a
paid version for this app and of course
the difference between the free and paid
is that the paid supports uh code
analysis and code prediction these are
certain details you don't have to worry
about right now and honestly if I
wouldn't worry too much about installing
python on your mobile devices currently
since I am assuming most people would be
learning Pro programming and programming
in Python on their PCS or laptops what I
had actually shown you was installing
what is called an implementation of
python on your system and implementation
is essentially a program or a software
or an environment that allows you to
actually work in Python so what I showed
you was how to install the by default or
the most basic or reference
implementation that has been created by
the developers which is actually called
C python even though you were not you
would not have seen the word the letter
c or the prefix C but yeah that
implementation that I had I had
downloaded myself and I had shown you to
download is actually the C python
implementation which is python built on
top of C the the C language essentially
there are other implementations such as
iron python which uses the.net framework
and J python that uses Java virtual
machines that you could use if you were
interested but again these are things
that I would not worry about too much
right now so now that we have tackled on
how to install your implementation of
python I want to introduce what is
called a distribution to you this
distribution is called Anaconda Anaconda
is a very important distribution
especially if you are looking to use
python in data science and machine
learning and AI which I am assuming is
the motivation for many of the people
that are actually watching this video
that they actually want to move into
data science and they need to learn
python as a foundation towards moving
towards data science and if that is your
goal or in any case whatever your goal
may be I would recommend that you
install Anaconda distribution now do not
get confused between anaconda and python
their Anaconda is python with in the
form of a bundle and this bundle
contains not only the basic python
implementation that I had shown you to
download but it contains a lot of extra
libraries and Technologies and software
as well so of course this means that
what you need to download both of course
not if you download a python you do not
need Anaconda to work on Python and if
you have already downloaded Anaconda
which I will show you how to do it in
some time if you have already downloaded
Anaconda you don't need to download
python separately so I'll just speak
about Anaconda a little briefly so as I
said it's a distribution it it contains
a bundle which includes the basic python
implementation and a lot of Technologies
and softwares and applications that have
essentially help us to use python in in
in specifically managing Big Data
applications and data science related
projects so so now I will show you
actually how to install python I mean
anaconda on your system it's as simple
as it's actually as simple as
downloading just this thing so if I did
a quick quick Google Anaconda
so the website that I'm looking for is
anaconda.com and I'm looking at products
and I'm looking at individual Edition
there are other editions as well like
commercial Team edition these are for
companies usually or uh for more
professional sort of projects so of
course we are looking at the individual
Edition and if you selected this page
you would be taken to this particular
web page where It'll ask you if you want
to download and again there are options
depending on which machine you're using
if you're using a Linux you would choose
one of these two if you are using Mac OS
you would use one of these two and since
I am a Windows user and I have a 64-bit
system this is the option I would use so
again it will it will first download and
install it for you and as you can see my
installer has been downloaded so upon
opening it it will open up this
installation thing you can you can just
click next on most of these again if you
want to specify your destination folder
you can change it here mine will be with
a default folder in the C drive and you
can leave this unticked you can you can
change these options much later so this
is how you install an account on Windows
and it's pretty much the same on other
systems as well now once it's done I
will show you what exactly what are some
of the things that Anaconda contains
that are not there if you installed
python like the way I had shown you
earlier just the bare bones python
implementation so as you can see here my
installation is actually complete and
now I will open anaconda and I'll show
you what how you can actually use this
Anaconda so if I search for anaconda in
my system I would look for something
called Anaconda navigator to actually
get started with this and when I open
that it should open something like this
so this is what opens when you click on
the Anaconda Navigator and as you can
see there are a bunch of applications
you don't need to worry about what these
mean right now just understand that this
this is essentially a bundle of
different applications and technologies
that come along with just the normal
installation of python that you get when
you install Anaconda Navigator now now
that we have actually tackled where
we've seen how to install and I'm hoping
and I would recommend definitely that
everyone is watching this video installs
Anaconda not just the normal python
installation or implementation now that
we have gotten all the introductions in
the basics and the installations
regarding python aside let's get right
let's get down to actually creating our
first script so now the question is how
do we actually start doing this task of
creating our first python script how do
we how do we realize uh now that we've
installed uh python like uh now let's
how do we start doing something so the
answer to that question is that
typically when you're working on python
the one of the most basic thing that you
can do is create a python script and
execute a script script essentially a
sequence of commands and instructions
that you give for python to run and
execute to give you a certain result so
I will show you how you can create a
python script now there are multiple
ways of creating a python script you can
create it directly from command line
which is obviously something I would not
recommend because it is not convenient
and easy and it's not very useful for a
beginner another way is using a text
editor such as the one I have opened
right now which is the notepad plus plus
text editor now it's very important to
not get confused between notepad plus
plus and the standard notepad that comes
with your windows or wordpad for that
matter in fact text editors such as
notepad and wordpad that you are more
familiar with create text and files in a
form that is called Rich Text Now Rich
Text is something is text that contains
format setting and fonts which is
actually a hindrance when it comes to
creating actual code so what we need is
a text editor that creates or writes
text in what we call as plain text plain
text is obviously text which does not
contain these fonts and these
formattings and it only respects white
spaces and indentations those two being
actually useful towards creating code
unlike fonts and formatting which are
only a visual thing so notepad plus plus
is obviously a text editor that creates
a plain text documents that is very that
was actually created with programming in
mind obviously you can use a bunch of
other text editors such as vim and atom
and you can Google for these there are
plenty of them so without any further
Ado let's create our first python script
so one of the most common one of the
most famous examples of it a first
program in any program for that matter
not just python is creating a print
statement that gives us a statement
saying hello world so enter in Python
this is how you would go about oh this
is the syntax you would use to create
the statement all right now weight is
very important when you are saving your
Python program that you use the dot py
prefix so so if I were to save this I
can choose whatever folder I am going to
choose yeah this folder seems fine so
now I give the file name over here as
say I want to keep it as test I need to
prefix this Dot py and this tells any uh
sort of interpreter or anytime we need
to read the script to know that it's a
python script we need to add a DOT py
otherwise it will not be treated as a
python script will be treated as some
normal document sort of a thing so now
that I have stored it as dot py I have
created my first python script now
obviously the next question is I need to
see what happens when I execute this
line when I run this script essentially
so to see that there are multiple ways
the first way that I will show you is a
command line method which is obviously 3
again before we get into it it's not
something that I will be using to teach
you it's not something I would recommend
you to immediately start using
um but for the sake of showing I will
show you how to execute a script in
command line well to do this you go
since I have installed anaconda in my
system and I will be using Anaconda to
work in Python what I will look for is
something called the Anaconda prompt as
you can see this is the option that I
get Anaconda prompt this will
essentially open you a command line
under the environment of anaconda or
python so in this now I am already in
the folder I believe that had my script
so how do I call this script or how do I
run this script well the command is
python space the name of my file which
was test of course the prefix is very
important so I enter test.py if you if
this was in a different folder you would
have to change your folders in command
line which is again something that I
might show you later but since my file
is already in the folder that I am in in
my command line I would just have to
enter this Command right now so if I
execute this as you can see it's given
me an output of hello world which is
which is what I wanted I wanted it to
print this uh these two words and of
course the command line is now waiting
for the next command for me so this is
uh one of the most simple ways for the
most rudimentary ways of executing a
python script now another question would
be well this isn't the most visually
appealing or not the easy to read or
easy to use way of executing scripts and
I would agree and that's why I'm going
to introduce a another technology or a
software called the IDE so the IDE in
python or in any programming language
stands for integrated development
environment it's essentially a software
that not only allows us to run scripts
but it allows us to create the scripts
it allows us to debug it allows us to
see outputs it allows us to the
intermediary outputs it allows us to do
a wide variety of tools and tasks and it
comes with a bunch of robust features to
enhance our Python programming
experience so let's let's see so I will
show you a an IDE called spider which
comes bundled along with the Anaconda
distribution that I had mentioned
earlier so if I open the Anaconda
Navigator as you can see the Anaconda
Navigator shows me a bunch of
Technologies and options and I'm looking
for something called the spider IDE
which is over here as you see here it's
a Scientific Python development
environment this is exactly what I'm
looking for so I am looking to launch
this so now that I've launched it you
can see out here this is what an IDE
looks like now this looks very
sophisticated and it's a it's a one and
any almost any IDE is a wonderful
software that where you can create your
code you can debug your code you can
check the results you can make
adjustments changes and you can do a
wide variety of tasks and functions with
relation to your programming so this is
the spider ID in particular and this is
how it looks don't worry about the exact
details just know that on this left hand
pane is our current script that is open
out here and out here we will get the
results in this this is what we call a
common solar console essentially
so now that we have we have already
created our script in notepad plus plus
and I want to open that script and I
want to see uh how an i how it would the
result of that script would look in an
IDE so let's just open it so we can
browse for our file and as I had named
it test this is the file over here I
open this and as you can see out here in
the left hand pane my script has opened
and the commander had given or had
written is out over here now if I want
to run this application I press this
green button and as you can see the
result of my my execution essentially is
over here it's in slightly small font
but as you can see over here it says
hello world and its way and the next
line is essentially it's it's waiting
for me to do another execution of the
script and then it will give me new
results so let's actually give the
system new results so now that I have
printed something called hello world
let's let's change what's written over
here let's say I will perform
basic maths all right and let's actually
perform the basic maths again don't
worry about the details the syntax uh
what I'm exactly doing these things that
we will actually cover in the in
upcoming videos and modules so let's
create a variable called a let's store a
number three let's create a variable B
Story number five all right let's create
another variable C uh which will store
the result of what's in a and b in the
addition of A and B all right and let's
print the result or print what's in uh
this variable C or what's the result of
a plus b I will print a statement saying
the result of the addition of three and
five is all right and I will put my
result over here as you can see I should
get the result in this pane so let's
execute this and you can see uh my first
line is executed saying I will perform
basic maths and the next line says the
result of the addition of three and five
is eight so this in this script what
I've done is I have performed uh two
print statements and I performed a basic
expression some variable assignments all
of these things we will be doing later
this is what I what I'm essentially
trying to show you is that Ides are a
very convenient way of not only creating
the scripts but actually seeing the
results and then making adjustments as
well we can come we can create a
completely new script we don't need to
create a script from some special file
or text editor I can just create a new
file here and this is my new script
essentially so I can start working on
with this new script right over here
from the get go so Ides are very
powerful spider IDE comes bundled with
Anaconda there are other ideas such as
the idle IDE it stands for
indicated development and learning
environment so the idle IDE comes as
part of the basic python implementation
that I had shown you in the previous
video where you if you just installed a
basic uh python implementation it would
come along with a basic IDE known as
Idle or integrated development and
learning environment but of course since
we are using Python and this is what I
would recommend it comes with a more
robust IDE called spider which is
actually very very helpful for
scientific and numeric applications and
was designed specifically with that in
mind now this is not the only way we can
actually work with python there's
another very interesting and a very
educative method of it in Python let's
say python programs and it's something
that I will be using extensively
throughout this course to explain
different concepts so this technology is
called or the software is called uh
notebooks now before I get into the
details I will state I will just open
node a basic notebook so the notebook
that comes as part of anaconda is called
the Jupiter notebook and when I open
when I launch the Jupiter notebook this
is what I get now a very important
feature or a a feature of notebooks is
that notebooks are a web browser or a
web-based application so you it's not
something that you can use if you are
offline or disconnected basically if
you're disconnected from the internet it
is something where which for which you
would need an active internet connection
however it is way more robust and it has
very very good properties that allow it
to be used in education or for
presentation and such so as you can see
this is my Jupiter notebook these are a
bunch of folders don't need to worry
about what these are right now I will
show you how to create a fresh notebook
so if you go here now you go to new and
you select under notebook the Python 3
option it will open you your first
notebook as you can see this line is
essentially waiting for me to enter some
sort of a command or a statement that I
would give in a normal python thing now
if you would have noticed the diff in uh
until now everything that we were doing
involved us creating a script which was
the whole series of commands and
functions so if I go back to my spider
IDE as you can see like this is a whole
script and this script contains multiple
different tasks and functions that are
individually being performed so this is
a separate print function this is a
separate Edition another separated print
function and for longer programs or
larger program terms you like you'll
have multiple different tasks being done
and if you were using a script you can
only see the result of something like
this by executing the whole thing at
once you cannot see exactly like what is
the result of just this print statement
or just this uh it's not typically what
an IDE is used for and this is where
notebooks come in super handy if I had
to break down my previous script
essentially where I first did a print
statement where I said some random thing
say hello
yeah so if I execute this particular
line you can see it gives me the result
now I want to do what is 5 plus 3 it
should give me the result over here
eight now in the next another part of
your program might be storing five and
three into variables so I can do this
and I can do this so now this line will
store the variables now I want to do the
addition of what is five plus three but
I want to use the variables and I want
to see what's the result as you can see
a plus b means 5 plus 3 which is 8 and
I've essentially broken down various
different parts of my previous script
into into its individual tasks and I'm
able to see what each part of that
script does and this is very good when
it comes to making presentations or
trying to teach a class so I will
personally be using notebooks a lot to
explain different different concepts of
um different concepts when it comes to
Python and I would recommend that you
get used to notebooks in general because
it's an amazing way to Learn Python
Programming or programming in general in
fact and again as I had mentioned
earlier notebooks are something that
it's an online application it's a
web-based application so I will have to
need a active internet connection to be
able to work on a notebook which could
be a disadvantage if you do not have a
consistent internet connection and in
that case you would probably use your
Ides or text editor which you can be
used offline as well in this video we
will be introduced to the concept of
variables and expressions let's start
with Expressions well an expression in
Python is anything that results in a
value its difference although the
difference between an expression and a
standard statement in Python is that a
statement in Python is something that
results in an action or an execution of
a command there is no calculation per se
or any sort of manipulation or as I said
audio calculation resulting in between
two different say numbers or other
objects that results in a value and this
happens in the case of an expression so
for example if I were to add two numbers
say 5 plus 10 this is an expression
which should where two objects 5 and 10
are being added and a result has been
given to me which is 15. now let's see
an example of a statement well a
statement could be something like a
print statement so when I ask python to
print something for me it's not
calculating anything it's not evaluating
anything it's simply performing an
action that I have or a command that I
have given the system which is to print
whatever I have entered over here as you
can see so this is a statement similarly
there are another type of statement
known as assignment statements which we
will learn actually right in the next
section well let's move on to variables
right now now earlier you might have
learned about objects in Python so
objects are essentially data that we can
work with a manipulate in Python now
variables are a place to store these
different objects
usually it's much easier to store
objects in Python instead of using the
objects explicitly themselves because
objects may be very compute complicated
whereas variables are very simple to use
and very simply very named in a very
simple manner so that we can use them
quite often in our programs now it's
important to note that in Python we do
not have to explicitly declare or Define
a variable to create them in fact
variables are created in the same
statement where we assign some object to
the variable in Python the assignment of
variables happens using the assignment
operator which is the equals design so
if I were to if I wanted to assign a
number say 100 to a variable say B well
it would be as simple as doing this now
anytime I want to know what is stored in
B I just have to enter B and I will get
the value that is stored in it and we
can store different types of objects
inside any variable let's say I store I
want to store this particular word in
the form of a string now this is stored
in X and if I want to know what is an X
I can just see what is here and it's a
string hello which I had stored earlier
now it's very important that we follow
certain naming rules when it comes to
naming our variables in python or else
we may be thrown error so we might get
some problems in our program
so the first rule is that you cannot
start your variable name with a number
so if I were to give a variable name
like 4 num is equal to something say the
same string hello this would be an
illegal variable name and I would get an
error when I try this so if I were to
choose a num 4 is equal to hello this
would be perfectly fine I won't get an
error the second rule is we are not
allowed to use any
non-alphanumeric characters except the
underscore character while naming our
variable so for example if I were to
name my variable num underscore 4 and I
stay I said random some random string
this is perfectly fine however if I
change num underscore 4 to num hyphen 4
this will throw me an error as you can
see over here next the third rule is
that variable names are case sensitive
so if if I have a variable called num or
say n-u-m if this was one of my
variables and I stored say the value 50.
this is not the same as me writing num
all in capitals and say storing some
other value 60 these are two different
variables so it's very important that
when you name your variables you are
aware of what case you are writing them
in because python variables are case
sensitive now the final and probably one
of the most important rules in Python is
that you're not allowed to use what we
call Reserve words in Python now python
has a bunch of reserved words these
words essentially are performed or they
are used to perform certain special
functions and are user identifiers for
certain special functions in Python that
we that have a special purpose like that
particular word has a special purpose
within the Python programming language
and you cannot use them to name our
variables so a list of them as you can
see over here some of them are like
false def if Del Rays and there are like
are there are around 33 of them and
sometimes some of these words are taken
out sometimes there are more words added
as python gets updated now let's let's
move on to a concept uh where we try to
really understand what do we mean by
storing data inside a variable now when
I say that we are storing something
inside a variable you get an image or
you get an idea in your head that this
variable is like a container where we
store or we put a particular object
inside it so does this mean that
variables have a place in the memory are
they are also an object that is placed
in the memory where we can put other
objects inside of well I'll show you an
example where this idea is kind of
disproven or where I'll show you that
the idea of variable is kind of
different than what we understand by
storing something inside a variable now
let's say I'm storing the same object I
will take this object as some random
number let's say 100 and I'm going to
store it into two different variables so
I take X is equal to 100 over here and
in the next line I will store 100 in y
as well now if objects were I mean if
variables were objects that we placed in
our system then X and Y should have two
different IDs but let's see what happens
when I check the ID of X and the ID of Y
they should be different in case
variables were their own objects however
as you can see the ID of X and the ID of
Y are exactly the same so well obviously
we know that two different objects in
Python cannot have the same ID so does
this so what does this mean when it
comes to the nature of a variable well
the the fact is that variables are not
actually objects in Python in fact
variables are more like pointers or
references to the actual object so when
I said X is equal to 100 and Y is equal
to 100 what I am actually telling the
system is that there is this variable
name called X that I want to refer or
Point towards the actual object that is
in my memory called 100 and I do the
same thing with another variable y so I
am not exactly creating a different
space in my system for these variables
these variables are more like
placeholders or references that point to
a particular place in the memory where
this object is located and that is what
happens when I do ID of X and idea 5
it's not giving me the idea of something
called X or the ID of something called Y
is giving me the ID of 100 each time
because 100 is stored in X and Y so as
you can see this is something like a
visual representation of what I'm trying
to say and similarly if if I were to so
in this example on the left as you can
see I've used the value of 50 to explain
my point so as you can see initially X
and Y are pointing towards this value 50
because I have stored 50 and 50 in both
X and Y now what if I changed the object
that is stored in X well that means X is
now pointing towards this new object and
I have stored this new object called
hello the string called hello as you can
see here so now X is pointing to a new
object in the system and it's called
hello and I haven't changed anything
with respect to Y so y will Point
towards the same thing and I can also
make the pointer of Y different or what
I'm trying to say is I can store
something else and Y say I stored this
list in y 50 1600 when I do that now Y
is pointing towards a different object
in Python and X is also pointing towards
something else so what happens to this
object 50 well now that there's no
variable referring to this object 50 it
becomes what we call an orphaned object
and we can actually see that when we do
the ID of X now let's go back to my
example on the right where I stored X is
equal to 100 so as you can see it gives
me some ID represented by this number
now let's say I stored x i stored
something different say 200 now if I do
the ID of X it should give me a
different ID because as you can see the
values are different and this is because
this object 200 is what is stored in X
and when I do the ID of X I'm actually
getting the ID of this new object now
200 so as you can see Point as you can
see variables are they should be and
they are treated more like references or
pointers instead of containers for a
particular object in this video you will
be introduced to the concept of objects
in Python now what are objects in Python
well all the data that we manipulate or
use in our operations in our code are
represented as objects or relations
between objects so if you want an
example two numbers that you add in your
code well both of them are objects and
the usually numeric type objects
similarly if you want to store someone's
name or an address of your hometown in
your code you usually stored in a form
of text and that text is also an object
usually a string similarly you might
want to create a container of different
smaller objects inside them and that big
container is also a type of an object
and one of those containers are called
lists and similarly we have many
different types of objects which we will
be covering during the duration of this
course the following pictorial
representation gives us a broad
classification of different python data
types and objects as we can see there
are five broad classifications numeric
which contains integers complex numbers
and floats we have the dictionary data
type we have the Boolean which
essentially consists of objects that
have only two valid values true or false
then we have sets and we have sequence
data types such as strings lists and
tuples every object in Python has three
important properties that kind of Define
that particular object they are its
ident entity its type and its value the
identity of an object is it can be
considered as a place in the memory or
its address in the memory where an
object is stored an object's identity
does not change one at once it has been
created so for example if I took an
example of say a string called hello I
can use the ID function which is this is
how you use the ID function to find out
the ID of this object and it should be
the answer should be in the form of a
particular long integer so as you can
see the ID of hello is this integer two
three two six four seven six six two
three zero two four similarly all
objects in Python have an identity we
have another operation with regarding
the identity of an object it's the is
operator and the is operator compares
the identity of two objects so if two
objects have the same identity it should
give the answer true otherwise false now
the next property of objects is the type
type of an object is essentially what
defines what kind of values and
operations that that object can have so
for example a numeric data type in
Python such as an integer would allow us
to do arithmetic operations and
similarly string object type in Python
will allow us to do concatenation
operations much like its identity the
type of an object cannot be changed as
well now let's see what's the type of
that particular object that I had shown
you above as you can see it should be
string Str stands for string similarly
if I did a type for a number say 50 it
should give me int as you can see now
the third property of an object in
Python is its value now the value is the
actual data that is contained in the
object it's the thing that we use that
we display that we can manipulate and
that we can perform operations on so for
example if I were to talk about this
string this string is hello so the value
of the string is the word or the
sequence of letters that spell out hello
and similarly this particular object is
a numeric object with the value of 50.
let's see in this in this pictorial
representation I have shown you that you
can assume this dodge Blue Area as the
memory of the system within this memory
we have objects created called 50 and
hello and this list containing smaller
objects called cat pen and 40. now what
I'm trying to show you here is each of
these objects have a type an ID and a
value and let's see what they are if I
wanted to see as we had already seen the
type of 50 now let's find the ID of 50
as you can see we get this unique ID for
the object 50 which is obviously not the
same as the ID of the object hello above
and the value of this object is the
value of s50 itself so that was a brief
and introduction into objects in Python
in this video we will cover the topics
of numeric object types and type
conversions in Python now let's get
started numeric object types in Python
are a broad classification of objects
plenty of common real life applications
that we associate with numerals such as
arithmetic operations and calculus are
done in Python using numeric object data
types there are three main types of
numerals or numeric data types in Python
they are integers float and complex
integers as the name suggests represent
all integer values in Python these can
be such as 100 minus 3 to 305 and so on
floats are used to represent new builds
that contain decimal points such as
100.3 3.9 4.8 minus 6.8 and so on then
there is the complex object type which
is used to represent complex numbers in
Python and this is an example of a
complex number 3 plus 7j okay this is a
complex number three plus seven J where
the real component is 3 and the
imaginary component is 7. all complex
numbers have a real and imaginary
component and this is how we denote them
now it's important to note that this J
is a very common symbol in maths and
Engineering used to denote the imaginary
portion of a complex number and it's the
same in python as well so moving on
let's talk about type conversion in
Python type conversion refers to the
conversion of an object from one data
type to another for example from string
to an integer and there are different
types of conversions and let's go
through some of them first of all let's
consider the conversion of something to
an integer and more specifically let's
consider the example where we convert a
string to an integer so let's consider
my example string to be some something
called 145 and I'm sewing this within a
string for a reason because I want to
convert is string to an integer so as
you can see I have stored this one for 5
within my within a variable X and if I
were to confirm that is actually an
integer I can use the type function and
see that it is actually an integer Str
now let's convert this into an integer
using the int function so how would we
use it is simply passing the End by
passing the variable that we want to
convert into the int function and as you
can see this is what I've done over here
but before this I will also store it
into another variable all right now
let's see what's in y well y gives us 1
4 5 but are we sure that it's an end we
can just check it by using the type
function and as you can see the type
gives us the answer end that means that
we've converted the string to an end
interestingly we can convert something
and also specify what base we have to
treat the number as by default when we
pass something in the in function the
programmer python will treat whatever we
have passed within the string as
something in base sub decimal but what
if we were to pass something that is
well not in a decimal we could do it
like this now let's store Y and in y the
store let's do this and I will show you
what this means X and I will give a
comma and eight what this does python is
well I want to convert the string in X
into an integer but I want to treat
whatever is an X as a number of Base 8
so 145 is actually 145 in the base 8 now
when we see what's in y we get 101 which
is different to 145 because well 1 0 1
is actually the decimal equivalent of
145 in the base 8. similarly if we were
to give it in the base 2 we would just
replace 8 with 2 over here now next
let's talk about converting something to
a float now as we know float is just
simply something that has a decimal
point so let's convert an integer into a
float how would we do that simply by
using the float function so if I give
120 and I pass this integer through the
float function I should get 100 120.0
and these two are not the same though
they may mean the same things to us but
in for python 120 is an integer and
1.120.0 is a different object which is a
float and this is how we convert
something to a float now what if we
wanted to convert an integer to a string
well we can use the Str function we can
also use the hex and the OC function if
we want to convert a particular number
to a hexadecimal or an octal string
respectively let's look at all three
examples say I have a number 688 and I
want to convert this into a string I
just use the Str function around this so
as we know just to confirm let's see
what the type of 688 is this is this
should be an end as we can see but when
we pass when we let's say we convert it
into a string 688 and let's store it
into some variable let's call it a all
right now let's see what it's an a it
gives a 688 in the form of a string but
we can confirm by checking the type of a
it is an Str so it is a string similarly
we can use hex if we wanted to convert
an integer into its hexadecimal
equivalent in the in in as an output of
a string as you can see this comp this
uh this sort of complicated thing is
actually telling us that we have
converted 688 in terms of hexadecimals
now how do we read this output this zero
should not be treated as anything it's
more like a an identifier which says
that the letter after this first 0 is
the base of this whole number so it's
saying that x x stands for hexadecimal
so it's saying that 2 B 0 is to be
treated as a hexadecimal number and if
you did basic maths you would find that
the decimal equivalent of 2b0 is 688
similarly if I did opt if I use the oct
function for 688 it will give me the
result something like this so again how
to read this the first 0 is to be
treated as an identifier and not part of
the number what it's saying is the
letter after the first or after this 0
is the base of the number following
these two uh following these two
characters so as you can see as you can
see what's this saying is that this
whole number is an OCT represented by
this letter O and the number itself that
we are dealing with is one two six zero
and one two six zero in octave system is
the equivalent of 688 in the decimal
system so this is how we've converted a
an integer in an integer into a
hexadecimal or a an octal string now
what if we wanted to convert two numeric
objects into a complex data object well
for that we can use the complex function
as you can see here
if I passed complex 5 and say say
something like 3.1 let's see what this
gives us as you can see it gives us an
uh a complex object where our real part
is 5 and our imaginary part is 3.1 so
what this does is essentially uh you
pass two numbers the first one is the
real component and the second is the
imaginary component it combines to give
you a complex number as you can see here
now let's look at some other type
conversions the next type we will be
talking about is converting something to
a tuple or a set or a list so what if I
wanted to convert a string into a tuple
I will use the Tuple function and as you
can see over here so let's say I have a
string called random let's call it
random all right now if I want to
convert this to a tuple I will use the
Tuple function as you can see over here
the output will give me tuples where
each individual component end of this
Tuple are the individual components or
the individual characters of my string
random similarly if I wanted to convert
the string to a list I would use the
list function and this will give me a
list of the individual characters of the
word or the the string random and I
could do the same thing with the set
function to create a set of individual
characters of uh the string random as
you can see here so yeah these were some
of the basic python type conversions
that I have shown you as we learn about
more complex data types and different
object types in Python we will learn
different type conversions and functions
associated with them in this video you
will be introduced to the concept of
strings strings are an object type in
Python used to store textual data this
textual data could be something like for
example someone's name it could be an
address of a place or it could be
something like a word or a sentence now
strings in Python are an object type
that is actually a subtype of a broader
classification of objects called
sequences sequences are objects in
Python which contain components placed
one of the other where each component is
given what we call an index a numeric
Index this numeric index identifies the
component in the sequence and its
position within the sequence now since
python is a zero index based language
the first object of any sequence is
always index 0 the second is index 1 the
third is index 2 and so on now let's
move on to defining strings how do we
Define them well strings are defined
using what we call delimiters and
delimiters occur in pairs in opening and
a closing delimiter in Python these
derivators are pairs of single or double
quotes so for example if I were to use
single quotes to define a string I could
I would do it like this this is a string
as you can see this is a string is
printed over here this is delimited
using single quotes similarly if I were
to define a string using double quotes
it's as simple as doing this this is
also a
as you can see now a valid question
arises what if I wanted to include a
single code within my string well if I
try to let's see what happens if I try
to print a statement with a single quote
naturally inside it so say I'm saying
it's my birthday all right let's see
what happens if I try to print this
statement it says invalid syntax and
this is because as I had mentioned in
Python single quotes and double quotes
are delimiters so they have a special
function in Python and we cannot simply
just use them within a string because
python will treat them specially for a
special purpose so what python will do
is it will pair this and this delimiter
so single quotes and say okay this looks
like a string to me and it's not going
to understand the rest of this and then
it'll find a random single quote and it
won't find its pair and it will
basically throw us an error because of
this so one way or one word around to
introduce single quotes into a string is
simply to delimit our string itself
using the other type of delimiter or
double quotes So if I want to include a
single code I will close my string using
double quotes So if I did this instead
of what I had done earlier
this is a perfectly valid and legal way
of defining my string and I could I
would do the opposite if I had to
introduce a double quotes within my
string I would use single quotes to
close it so if I were to write a speech
statement she said
I am
hungry all right I have I want these two
double quotes to essentially show that
this is a speech and I'm gonna close the
string using single quotes and this is a
valid way of doing it as you can see my
string has this two double quotes now I
had mentioned that strings are sequences
well let's describe how array sequences
so first of all all sequences in Python
are a
um it's a essentially a sequence of
smaller objects that form the sequence
right so let's try to understand like
how do how are strings to be treated as
sequences some sequences that we will
learn later are like lists or tuples and
in all sequences we can retrieve any
particular object or component in that
sequence using its index and how do we
use indexes in Python well we enclose a
numeric index within square brackets now
let's see what I'm trying to talk about
by this example now say I'm storing a
particular string called say random
within now my variable name here is test
and I'm storing the string random within
it all right and this is the way of
retrieving a particular index from test
I write the variable name and then next
to it I put the square brackets now I'm
supposed to put a numeral within the
square brackets to tell python like what
a particular index I'm looking for so
let's try 0. now as I said python is
zero index based language so the zero
index essentially means the first part
of or the first component of a sequence
so let's see what happens when I ask
python to retrieve the first part of
what is stored in test it gives me the
string R in fact it's just one character
R and it's a string so as you can see it
has given me the first character of the
string random which is R so what this
shows is that this string random is
essentially a collection or a sequence
of one character strings so this is so
Random is essentially a collection of
the string R the string a the string n
and so on together combine to form the
whole string that we call random
similarly if I wanted the character at
the third position of this thing I would
use well since the third position and
since we're working in Python I would
use the index too and it should give me
the letter n as you can see it's giving
me the letter N so this is how we can
show that strings are also sequences in
Python well now let's move on to
um certain string operations and
functions that we can perform well as
you have seen already that we can
retrieve any particular character within
a
um within a string using numeric indexes
well what if we wanted to know what
index is a particular character at then
we can do it like this we use the index
function so let's say my test and I want
to know where where or what position the
character D is in my string random so
this is how I would use the index
function index and within the index say
I'm looking for the character D and now
I it should give me the answer 0 1 2 it
should give me the answer three so if I
execute this it gives me the index 3. so
this is uh the index function that we
could use for our strings now what if we
want to
um say slice a string into a into its uh
into a smaller part you want to slice it
and we want to retrieve only that
particular size well here is an example
say I'm gonna I'm gonna use the same
string called random and it's stored in
test right so let's so one way of so the
way of doing this is like this
now let's see what this let's just see
what this does first as you can see it's
given me a and d and if I went to my
string random A and D is this particular
slice now let's try to understand what I
have done by entering one colon for well
what this has done is it's retrieved a
slice from the first position uh the
first index which is the character a up
until the fourth position which is the
character o but it has not included o so
it's very important when I index like
this every every time I put something to
the right of this colon I am not
including this itself all right so it's
essentially one when I say one colon
four what I'm telling python is give me
the first the second and the third
character but not the fourth one so it's
given me a n and d and it's that's this
is how we do a slicing operation in
Python similarly if I were to say slice
from the first if I wanted only first
and the second character I would do this
is what I would do if I wanted the first
and the second character I would do one
two three so this way it says python
that I want the first I want the second
but not the third off so as you can see
I get a and N now so this is a basic
slicing what if I wanted the portion of
a string from a particular Point all the
way to the right or all the way to the
left well let's consider the example of
where I want the portion of the string
random from the say fourth character
until the left well the way I would do
this is test now since I want it all the
way to the left I don't enter any index
to the left of my colon sign and since I
want everything to the left of the
fourth character I enter 4 here so as
you can see it gives me A R A and D
which is everything from the fourth
character of my string random to the
left similarly if I wanted something to
the right of it I would just do it like
this I would enter some index here and I
I would leave the portion to the right
of the colon blank so this will give me
everything including the third character
since this is how we treat the indexing
in Python everything including the third
character all the way to the right so
this is Dom as you can see now another
perfectly valid um slicing is say I want
to slice or take out different
characters from the string but I want to
skip certain characters like I want this
one then I want to skip one and I want
to take the next one and then I want to
skip one well in that case we have to
introduce a step so one way of doing
this is now how do we read this so as
you can see I've written 0 colon six
colon two so what this is telling python
is I want every character from my string
test starting from the zeroth character
up until the sixth but not including the
sixth after skipping or taking two at a
time taking two at a time can also be
assumed as uh skipping one at each step
or skipping one character at each step
so what this will do is it'll go to
random it will take the zeroth one we'll
take R and then it will skip the next
one so it will not consider a and then
it will pick n and then it will not
consider D and then it will consider o
up until the sixth character whichever
that whichever that may be and if you
see the output it gives us R and O which
is exactly what we wanted we wanted R we
wanted n we wanted o where we skipped uh
A and D or we skipped the every second
character essentially so this is a way
of
um slicing strings while also skipping
certain characters or skipping
characters and steps now python is also
an uh there's another interesting
technique that we can use in Python to
where we can start retrieving characters
from the rightmost side of a sequence or
a string we can use negative indexes so
if I were to for example show you let's
see what this what this gives me test
what what is the minus one index it
gives me the character M now remember a
string Is Random so minus 1 gave us the
last character of the string random
which was m so this is a way of using
negative indexes and similarly if I used
to test minus 2 it would give me the
second last character which should be
the character o as you can see here now
there are some other important functions
that you may use in Python for that
let's create another let's create
another string let's call it upper lower
all right I'm sorting it again in the
same variable test let's see what
happens when I use the upper function
and what happens when I use the lower
function
now I'm going to use the lower function
for this so these two functions will
respectively give out or give us the
result or give us our string in
uppercase and lowercase respectively so
as you can see the upper function
created the first string in full upper
case and the second one created this by
the string in four lowercase now another
important and probably one of the most
important methods that we use for
Strings especially when it comes to data
science is the split function so let's
see what I mean by split function let me
create another string let's call it
hello world
all right I'm going to use a split
function and I'm going to see what
happens when I use this function
essentially so what I'm doing in these
in this these three lines is I'm
creating the string hello world I am
storing it in test and then I am using
the split function on the test and
whatever result I get I'm storing
another variable called sliced and then
I'm just going to show you what is in
sliced as you can see what's happened to
the string hello world is that I have
broken it into its components or its
component words if that makes any sense
into hello and world and I stored both
of these into what we call a list now
you might ask well how does python know
that it has to separate at a blank space
well the split function by default will
break up a string at its blank spaces
but if we wanted we could break it up
using or at every comma so for example
if I wrote hello world using comma and
if I put a comma inside over here and
now if I try to execute this
like for example I am going to find I'm
going to look for commas in the string
and I'm gonna try to split it as you can
see there's no splitting happening I
have one list with my original string
itself because it's not found a comma
what if I introduced a comma over here
now let's see what happens as you can
see the splitting has happened it's
found this comma and is caused a split
between hello and World similarly if I
in my string if I put this comma again
and I put something else it should give
me the split over there again so we can
Define our split using some whatever we
put between these Circle brackets after
the split function it's just important
to note that by default if in case we do
not enter anything over here it will use
blank spaces to do the splitting uh
another very important operation and
very common operation in strings is what
we call concatenation so if I have two
strings first and say another string
second and I want to join these together
well the operator I would use to do this
is called the plus symbol this is the
concatenating operator when it comes to
Strings so what is the result of this
let's see let's print this out let's
print this whole thing and let's see
what is the result as you can see what
this has done is it has combined the
first string first and the string second
into one string called first second so
this is the concatenate concatenation
operator now finally uh the last Topic
in this lesson is the topic of Escape
sequences now Escape sequences are
special commands that tell python to
either suppress special meaning of some
character or symbol in a string or give
or give the special or give some special
meaning to an otherwise ordinary
character in a string so let's look at
the first example now remember my in my
for earlier in this video where I was I
was telling you like what what is the
way of writing or how do we introduce
single quotes or double quotes into a
string and I had told you the trick if I
want to use single coat in my string I
just close it using double quotes or if
I want to use a double quote I close it
using single well another way of doing
this is using what we call an escape
sequence and an escape sequence in
Python is the backslash character all
right so let's see what happens when I
use the backslash character where I want
to introduce my single code so if I use
my previous example where I wanted to
introduce a single quote and say I am
going to close it using single quotes as
well so I'm gonna go back to my error
example so as to speak now this would
throw me an error right as you can see
it has thrown me an error so what if I
used the escape sequence that I
mentioned the Escape sequences is
backslash character now this is the
point of the string where I want my my
single code so I introduce a backslash
now I have my single quote and I
continue writing the rest of my
statement let's close the string now
will this work as you can see this has
worked so what this has done is this
backside character has told python to
not read this special character or the
single code to not treat it specially
and let it be as a part of the string so
as you can see that's what's happened
here now the next case or the other uh
use case of Escape sequences is when we
want to give a particular character that
is otherwise just ordinary some special
meaning so let's take the example of the
character T and the character n we use
the character T to introduce tab space
and Views a character in to introduce
what we call line break well let's see
by an example so normally the character
T has no special function so the
character T within a string will just be
outputted as the character T itself
however as you can see here I'm going to
introduce a backslash before this
character t
let's see what it does it introduces
this thing that we called a tab space
which is a larger than normal space
similarly if I were to use the backslash
n combination this would introduce what
we call a line break
and if you were to see the output of
this you can see at the point of the
string where I have this combinational
backslash m a line break has occurred so
there are plenty of other Escape
sequences that you may choose to learn
and uh these are just two of the
probably the most common ones that I
used in this video I will give you an
introduction into lists and tuples
starting off with lists lists are a
collection of ordered orbit arbitrary
objects that are similar to what we call
an array in other programming languages
but lists are way more flexible when it
comes to python python lists are a type
of sequence and we might have you might
have seen what a sequence is when we
were learning about strings and much
like in sequences or any other sequence
list objects are assigned a numerical
index and whenever you want to
manipulate an object in a list we use
its respective index how do we Define
lists the lists are defined using square
brackets so this is a simple way or a
simple list that I have just created and
assigned to a variable a which contains
three objects one two and three let's
talk about some of the features of
python lists python lists are ordered
and what this means is that even if two
lists contain the exact same elements if
they if the elements are placed in a
different order the two lists are
actually unique and different and I can
check that over here I have created a
list one two and three and see if I
create another list two and one and
three the same elements were in
different order I will use the is
function to check whether these two
lists are the same and if they are the
same when I use is function it should
give me the value or the answer true and
if they're not the same it should give
me the value false and as you can see I
get the value false because even though
I have two lists with the same elements
they are in different orders and so they
are different and that's what we mean by
lists are ordered the next property for
lists are that they can be manipulated
using their indexes or the elements and
the objects inside a list can be
manipulated using the indexes and we
will see that in the section where I
show you list operations the next
property is lists are mutable what this
means is that once we create a list
object we can actually make changes and
modify them without having to create a
new list object the next property is
that lists are Dynamic and what this
means is that as we are making our as we
are programming we can actually make
changes to an already created list as we
are programming without having to go
through a compilation stage so if we had
to say increase the or we had to add
certain elements to an already created
list that original list grows in size to
accommodate for these new elements the
next property is that lists can contain
any arbitrary objects so if I created a
list right now where say if I want to
store some numbers
say some floating Point numbers now
and I can put strings as well into my
list all of these are valid uh when it
comes to objects that can be put inside
a list we have no such restrictions so
we can put any arbitrary objects inside
our list the final property that I want
to talk about is that lists are they can
be nested to any arbitrary depth what
this means is that I can put a list
within a list and I can keep nesting it
essentially by putting as many lists I
want within my list and I'm only
essentially restricted by my systems
memory so if I created a list like this
within this say I put any other list and
within this list I put another list I
can keep going on to by keep going on
doing this and I'm only restricted by
the memory of my system that I'm using
so moving on let's move on and talk
about some important list operations
that we will be doing when it comes to
lists so let's create a basic list
called a where I'm storing six numbers
so now say if I want to retrieve a
particular element say if I want to find
out what's on the index 3 this is how I
would do it if I wanted a slice of my
original list and much like strings I do
it the same way so what this does is it
tells python that I want all the
elements of list a from index 1 to index
4 but not including index 4. so it'll
give me one two and three index objects
so it should give me 2 3 and 4 in this
case as you can see here two three and
four I can do the same thing by
considering elements say two at a time
if I wanted to consider elements or
consider every second element what I
would do is this syntax I would use this
syntax and when I give this command to
python what it tells what it understands
is I want every element from a from
index 1 to index 4 but not including
index 4 but I am going to consider
considered to every second
element essentially so what it will do
is it will go here and then it will skip
one and then go here and then Skip One
and that's essentially what we uh what
it's essentially what we call
slicing by using strides so I'm taking
strides I'm not considering elements
consecutively but I'm skipping certain
elements in between if I wanted to
consider every third element I would
change this to three and fourth element
double changes to four all right so
let's see what happens when I take every
second element it should give it should
give me uh it will consider say from one
to index three right so it should
consider essentially this section but
since it's going to skip one it's going
to consider this skip this and then
consider this it should give me two and
four as you can see it has given me two
and four and like in other sequences we
can use negative indexes as well
negative indexing essentially starts
looking from the right hand side of the
list so when I say A minus 1 one it's
essentially looking at the last element
of the list so it gives me the sixth or
the last element which is the which is
object six if I did a minus 2 it gives
me the second last element similarly
another neat trick that we can use for
sequences is the following syntax double
colon and we give a minus one what this
tells the what this tells the system is
I want the list a but with all the
elements reversed so as you can see I
get my element uh my list a but the
elements have been reversed right now
let's move on to uh concatenation and
replication well concatenation much like
in strings is done by using the plus
sign so as we know on either side of the
plus sign should be two similar objects
so if I'm doing a plus something a being
a list on the other side it should be a
list as well so let's add a list like
this now let's see what's in a
as you can see my origin list has a 789
added to it and I can also add things to
the beginning of a list similarly so if
I wanted to add say zero you know at the
beginning of a list I just do it like
this
and I get the element 0 added to it it's
very important to note that I I actually
added 0 within a list because if I did 0
like this
it will throw me an error because like
this 0 is just an end object and it's
not a list but when I put the square
brackets I make it a list and then this
concatenation becomes valid because a is
also a list similarly if I did a star 2
this is essentially replication or a
replication function where I'm repeating
the values in a twice if I did a star 3
it's the same function but now I'll have
the elements repeated Thrice as you can
see here let's move on to modifying list
values uh this also shows the mutable
property of lists that I had mentioned
earlier so let's consider this example
so I created a list with elements where
it is the three strings eggs apples and
carrots and I have five int objects one
two three four and five now if I wanted
to change say the first element all I
have to do is take the 0th index and say
if I want to replace eggs with same
mango this is how I would do it now
replace eggs with mango if I check
what's in B you can see the eggs have
been replaced with the element mango
similarly I can use the slice syntax to
replace a particular slice from my list
with a slice essentially so let's look
at this I'm replacing I want to replace
the first three elements I want to
replace mango I want to replace apple
and carrot so what I will do is I will
consider this since this carrot is the
second index so I would consider 0 to 3
because third is not counted now I'm
going to replace this with three
different
um let's see kiwi
and it's a sponge now let's check what's
in B you can see my three elements have
been replaced in fact I don't have to
replace like for like if I want to
replace say three elements with only one
or two elements that is also possible so
now if I want to replace the first three
elements kiwi orange and sponge
with
um just one element this is how I'll do
it let's say
wine now let's check what's here as you
can see three elements have been
replaced with one mine I can double vice
versa as well I can replace smaller
number of elements with a larger number
of elements but here there is a slight
caveat that I want to show you so an
obvious way of doing this would be say
if I wanted to replace the first element
wine with three different elements an
obvious way would be just consider that
elements index and then put whatever
objects you want say I want to add
instead of wine I want to add beer I
want to add ball and say Club yeah well
let's see what happens now if I say B
check what's inside my you can see my
elements have been added but they seem
to have been added as is you know I had
entered a list over here and that whole
list has been replaced uh or this wine
has been replaced by this whole list in
the first position but that's not
exactly what I want it I wanted the
elements within this list to be
individually placed into my list and the
way to do that is not this syntax but
actually what I'm going to show you now
if I want to replace one if I want to
replace the index of the object at index
0 I would give this statement a slice
statement where I will give 0 colon 1 so
when I do this and if I
um so let's create my old scenario again
where I had wine and I had one two three
four and five now if I do this B 0 but I
give a slice then this slice is
essentially a single object slice it's
essentially the zeroth index again but
because of this formatting or this this
type of syntax that I'm using what
python will do is now when I say peer
and ball and club now what python will
do is it will not consider this whole
list and add it to in place of uh wine
or whatever I want to replace it will
actually consider the elements inside of
this individually and then replace so if
you see here now if you see my list I
actually have the I've removed wine and
in place of it I've put beer ball in
club but these three are actually
individual objects within my list and
not objects within a list that is then
placed within my original list so this
is an important caveat that you should
take note of so moving on let's talk
about certain methods Associated to
lists let's take a simple list now one
two and three the first operation that I
want to show you or the first method is
the append method so when I do a append
and say if I want to append the list by
one object called four I just do it like
this now let's see what's in a I put so
as you can see the append has put the
object 4 into my original list now say
if I wanted to append three different
objects I want to append five six and
seven now let's see what a pen function
does oh no as you can see it's done a
similar operation to what we have seen
earlier when we gave a single index or
the single element replacement uh that
we saw earlier it essentially put this
whole list into this particular spot
into the list and this is not what I
wanted I wanted five six and seven to be
individually placed and we do have a way
of doing that and the way to do that is
the extend function that is what I'll
show you next now if I want to extend
Say the original list by three different
elements eight nine ten when I use the
extend function it will not put this
whole thing it will consider each object
inside this thing individually and then
add it to a so if you see my result this
is exactly what I wanted now the next
method that I want to discuss is the
remove method so the remove method is
what you how you use it is within the
parenthesis you put the object that is
present in the list that you want to
removed so you don't give an index over
here you give the object itself so if I
want the object eight all right this
number if I want 8 itself removed what I
will do is put the value 8 here and it
will remove it from my list so if I
check my list a as you can see the value
8 has it's gone an X another similar
function to remove is the pop function
now the pop function by default will
remove the rightmost value from the list
but unlike remove the pop function
actually outputs a value and that value
is what we have popped out of the list
so by default it will pop out the right
route right most value of a list all
right most element of a list and in this
case that element is 10 so it should
give me 10 but of course if we want to
pop out any particular object in this
case we will not give that particular
object we give its index so now say if I
want to remove this uh this list object
from my bigger list
um as I can see it's in index 0 1 2 3 4.
it's the fourth index so if I want to
remove the list which is at the fourth
index I give the index value inside the
parenthesis and it pops that out for me
as you can see over here so this was it
for lists let's move on to tuples next
so tuples are another ordered collection
of objects much like lists but they
differ from lists in two Key Properties
first of all the tuples are defined
using parenthesis instead of square
brackets so this is how I would Define a
tuple with elements one two and three
and the next very important property
that is different or that differentiates
tuples from lists is that tuples are
immutable and what this means is that
once we create an object of type Tuple
we cannot make any modifications to it
we would have to only create create a
new object if we wanted something
different and this is obviously a key
difference between a tuple and a list
but apart from this every operation that
we have done on lists are actually
possible to do in the case of tuples as
well so any operation that we did to
lists that did not modify the list or
that does not do any modification we can
actually apply to tuples as well so if I
wanted the first element of this duple
all I have to do is call it by the index
0 it should give me the value 1 as you
can see if I wanted a slice I can do
that as well it should give me 2 and 3
and if I wanted to reverse my Tuple well
I can use my same neat technique that
I've used for this and that I can use
for the sequence I mean strings as well
so it gives me my old Tuple but with the
elements reversed so now the natural
question is why do we use Tuple server
lists well one important difference is
that when we con when we make a program
execution where or where we are
manipulating a tuple if we did the same
thing for the exact same objects in uh
that if it were present in a list it
would be much faster in a tuple
essentially program execution is just
faster on tuples when compared to an
identical list so use tuples over this
when we want to be efficient while we
are creating an ordered list of objects
so whenever we create an ordered list of
objects that we don't need to or we
don't want to make any further
modifications to we don't need to create
a list we can create a tuple and another
very important area where we use tuples
over list or why we need a tuple instead
of a list is when we are using
dictionaries dictionaries as we will see
later is a data type in Python that
needs an immutable component while we
are creating the dictionary so if we
want to use something that is like a
list but since lists are mutable we can
use a tuple instead and use that when we
are creating our dictionary and we will
see like what what I mean by the
immutable component for a dictionary
when we actually uh learn about
dictionaries but yeah these are some of
the places where we would use a tuple
over a list uh a brief section on Tuple
unpacking and packing is what I would be
doing right now and what that means is
that when I create when I give this sort
of a statement
you can assume this to be me packing
this Tuple into a object or a
variability now what's very interesting
is and this is something that's very key
to tuples is that I can unpack a tuple
onto another Tuple so let me show you
what I mean by that so now that I have
packed one two three and four Tuple into
T let's unpack it into another Tuple
let's call this let's uh put these
elements into this Tuple and I put this
into T alright now let's see what I mean
by unpacking something onto something
let's see what's the what what happens
when I put a if I just want to see
what's in a it actually gives me the
value one if I see what's in B it gives
me the value 2. if I see what's in three
in value three and D gives me value four
so essentially if you think of it what I
have done is I have matched this Tuple
then put it into T and then put that
Tuple T into this Tuple a b and c d so
what it's what what has happened
essentially is the element a has been uh
or a better way to say this would be the
element one has been packed onto or
unpacked onto a two has been unpacked on
to B three has been unpacked onto C 4
has been unpacked onto D to show you
what I've done in a single line is
essentially this this is essentially
what I've done
I have assigned 1 to a 2 to B 3 to C 4
to D I have matched these two tuples
together like this and this is a very
neat feature of tuples the only only
important thing that you have to keep in
mind is the elements of this Tuple and
the elements of this Tuple uh should be
equal so if there are four elements here
there should be four elements here all
right in fact another very important
thing about or a neat feature is that we
don't really need to mention the
parenthesis when we're doing this uh
unpacking or packing so if I did X comma
y comma Z if I did it like this if I put
say 5 and 6 and 7 this is also a valid
way of packing and unpacking so now if I
see what's the value in X it is actually
five if I see what's the value in y it
is six if I see what is the value of x
and z it should give me a tuple
containing five and seven as you can see
over here so this is a neat feature of
tuples called packing and packing in
this video we will cover Concepts
surrounding dictionaries dictionaries
are another type of composite data type
in Python there are also a collection of
objects much like tuples and lists and
like lists they are also mutable Dynamic
and can be nested however a key
difference and property of dictionaries
is that they are unordered items and
dictionaries are paired using keys
unlike enlisted tuples where the objects
are assigned numerical indexes to define
a dictionary we use curly braces each
key value pair in this dictionary in a
dictionary is separated using commas and
the key and values themselves in a pair
are separated using a colon let's look
at an example this is a dictionary where
I have three key value pairs as you can
see they have been separated by colons
and each repair themselves are separated
by commas and these are enclosed in
curly braces to define the whole
dictionary in this example the these are
the keys banana apple and grape and
their respective values are yellow red
and green so this is very important that
in this particular data type we have
what we call a key and that key is
assigned a value and we can have
multiple such pairings and we have three
such pairs in this particular example
another example or the or another type
of way to define a dictionary is using
the dict function this is how we use it
as you can see I have inputted two value
or two object tuples this is a tuple
this is etiopal and this is a tuple and
when I use it in a dict function when I
place it within a list what python will
do is it will consider the first element
of each Tuple as a key and the second
element of each Tuple as its respective
value now if I check what's in D as you
can see the key banana has a value
yellow the key apple has a value right
the key grape has a value green so this
is another way of defining dictionaries
an important note over here is that the
the objects that we use for Keys have to
be of an immutable data type so we
cannot use for example lists as an
example of keys but we can use say
integers or strings for our dictionary
Keys also Keys have to be unique when it
comes to a dictionary you cannot have
two different keys with the or should I
say the same key having two different
values you can have only one key and
that one key will have a unique value
assigned to it duplicate keys are not
allowed however when we speak about
values we have no such restrictions you
can have immutable or an immutable data
type as a value in a dictionary and you
can have duplicates as well so if I
created a dictionary with a key say
banana and if I give if I associate it
with it
a value green I cannot create another
key banana and Associate a value yellow
let's see what happens when I actually
do this if you actually see what has
happened here is python has considered
the second case so it's it first looks
at the first pair it goes okay so my
dictionary has a key banana with a value
green but right after it it sees another
key banana with a value yellow so it
overwrites my first key banana with the
second key and it overrides the first
value green with the second value and we
essentially get one key banana with the
second value yellow so obviously this is
python does this to avoid duplicacies
however if I created a dictionary with a
key banana again if I created I'll give
it a value yellow or say green if I
created another
key and if I give this also a value
green this is perfectly fine and this
will not nothing special will happen in
this case because values do not have to
follow such rules let's speak or let's
see certain dictionary operation
operations and functions now so let's uh
bring back our original dictionary which
we had created earlier with the three
pairs all right so what if I wanted to
we can use keys to essentially do these
operations and functions let's see what
happens when we so much like how we use
sequence how we use indexes in example
of sequences we use Keys when it comes
to dictionary so let's see what happens
when we use a key over here so we as we
know banana is a key in this dictionary
let's see what happens when we do where
we give this command it actually gives
the value associated with that key which
is yellow what if we wanted to change a
particular value Associated to a
particular key I would give I would do
this I would give the key and assign it
uh the value that I want to change it
with all right now if I check my
dictionary you can see the key banana no
more has yellow value but the value gold
what if I wanted to add a new pair you
know a new key with a new value
completely I would do it pretty much the
same same way as I did in the previous
step I would
um essentially write my new key whatever
I wanted say if I wanted a new key
called watermelon I would assign it a
value red and now if I check my
dictionary at the end of the dictionary
you will see that my new key pair key
value pair has been added watermelon red
as as you can see over here now what if
I wanted to remove if I wanted to remove
a key value pair from my dictionary I
can use the delete function which is
called by using this the Del function
now how do I do it see if I want to
remove the key value Apple in Red so all
I have to do is do del d and within
square brackets I have to only mention
the key I don't even need to mention the
value just the key so you can probably
draw parallels in how we use indexes
when it comes to lists and tuples and
even strings and how we use Keys when it
comes to dictionaries they are quite
similar so if I did this and if I
um oops I think red is actually not a
key as you can see red is a value my key
is Apple actually it's not red it's
apple as you can see now if I see my
dictionary the key apple and its value
red has been removed so these are some
of the operation questions that we can
do for dictionaries using keys what if
we wanted to use certain inbuilt
functions that are associated with
dictionaries well some of the examples
are as follows there is a get function
when we use the get function all we have
to do is enter a key inside the
parenthesis and it will get the value
associated with that key so if I gave
the key grip let's see what value is
associated with it as you can see it's
green there is also a function called
items that Returns the key and value
pairs in our dictionary as a list of two
object tuples where the first object is
the key and the second object is the
Tuple so let's see what it does as you
can see it gave me a list and in this
list the objects inside the list are two
object pupils where the first object is
always the key and the second is the
value and and it's the same for each of
the tuples so this is what items
function does let's see what uh the next
so the next function is Keys let's see
what the keys function does as you can
see it returns a list of all the unique
Keys within our list I mean within our
dictionary similarly we can there is a
function for values as well and as you
can see it returns all of the different
values that are present in our
dictionary in the form of a list also
it's important to note that if we have a
particular value that has occurred
multiple times in a dictionary it will
appear as many times it has occurred in
the dictionary or appeared in the
dictionary in our list over here when we
use the value function so if say a
particular value say I had another key
where its value was green again so I
would have the value green appear in
this list once more essentially our next
function is pop item what this does is
much like the pop function in list it
gives us the last entered key value pair
that is present in our dictionary so the
last centered pair was watermelon key
watermelon with the value red and that's
what has popped out when we give this
function another important function
associated with dictionaries is the
update function and the update function
is a very neat function that is used to
merge two dictionaries together so say
if I had a dictionary let's say I'm
creating a dictionary using the dict
function where I have say some key
called KV so as I had mentioned I will
use two object tuples in this case and
say I give this also a value green all
right and another pair would be say
mango and
let's give it a value yellow
all right so this is another dictionary
that we have created as you can see over
here we have created a dictionary with
the key called kiwi with value green and
another key mango with a value yellow
and I already have a dictionary D with
these values all right now if I want to
merge these two dictionaries I can use
the update function what I do is say if
I want to merge D with X or x with d
only the ordering will change and that
doesn't really matter when it comes to
dictionaries so if I want to merge D
with X I use D update and then inside it
I put my target dictionary now when I
check what's in D I have the the
dictionary X and its key value pairs uh
merged inside my original dictionary as
you can see I have my original ones here
and I have the merged ones over here so
this was the update function in this
brief video I will explain what we call
the type hierarchy or the standard type
item it's also known as the data model
in Python and it probably has other
names so essentially in the what we do
or what we speak about in this is uh how
the different types that we use in
Python are categorized and classified
and what are their subtypes so it's
important to note before we continue
further that there in future versions of
python there might be new types that are
introduced or the existing ones may be
modified but it's safe to say that what
I will speak about in this video will
still form the core of what we call
python standard type hierarchy so let's
begin so the first type is the non-type
uh it's accessed through the built-in
name none its truth value is false it's
essentially used to denote
um functions or it's you it's returned
as the value for functions that don't
really return anything so if you have an
expression or a function that returns no
particular value you actually get a data
type called none that is how python
interprets it uh then there's the
ellipses uh ellipse is something that
you might encounter later uh it is
accessed through the built-in name
Ellipsis
um it is used to indicate the presence
of this particular
um syntax this particular symbol or
expression uh or syntax in a slice its
truth value is true again don't worry
too much about ellipses right now next
is numbers and numbers is something that
we are very familiar with we've seen we
work with numbers a lot they are an
immutable type they are created through
numeric literals and they are the
outputs of arithmetic expressions and
built-in arithmetic functions its
subtypes are integers floating Point
numbers and complex numbers
um within integers you have plain
integers that represent numbers in the
range this number and this number so
this this number is basically the
largest positive value that you can
represent using 32 bit notation induce
complement and this is the equivalent a
for the the negative the negative side
long in teachers on the other hand are
used to represent numbers in an
unlimited range that is only subject to
the available memory of your system so
these are two types of integers and as
we know floating Point numbers represent
Machine level double Precision floating
Point numbers or numbers with a decimal
point and a component after that complex
numbers are numbers that contain a
floating Point number that represents a
real part and a floating Point number
that represents a an imaginary part so
these are the types of numbers then we
have sequences sequences are finite
ordered sets indexed by natural numbers
so each element in a sequence has an
index and that index is a natural number
the different types of sequences are
based on the mutability whether the
objects can be changed or not is
essentially what we mean by mutability
right once we create an object whether
we can modify I don't know and that is
how we differentiate different types of
sequences so there are mutable and there
are immutable types now the different
types of immutable ones are strings we
know what strings are they are sequences
that contain characters Unicode is the
other immutable sequence and then there
are tuples uh tuples are a collection of
arbitrary python objects and unicodes
are sequences that contain Unicode
characters then we have mutable
sequences and uh there is only one
currently there is only one built-in
mutable sequence in Python and that is
lists lists are also again collection of
arbitrary python objects finally we have
well not finally but next we have
mappings and mappings are again
um sets of objects but these objects are
now indexed using arbitrary index sets
you know the difference between a
mapping and a sequence you could
consider uh sequences are ordered but
mappings are not ordered and the index
is given to the objects and sequences
are always numbers they're natural
numbers whereas in mappings they are not
natural numbers but they are certain
arbitrary objects that we can set for
ourselves again in Python there is only
one built in standard mapping type that
is the dictionary dictionaries are there
they represent finite sets of objects
indexed by nearly arbitrary values the
only condition is that these indexes
must be of an immutable data type so
these uh so what I have mentioned until
now are probably the most common data
types that we encounter or that we have
encountered now so next types are like
callable types such as user defined
functions user defined methods built-in
functions built-in methods classes and
class instances so again callable types
as a whole are referenced using the call
function and this is something that we
will learn when we start learning about
functions when we learn about object
oriented programming and methods and
functions and such the other type of
modules so modules are module objects or
modules essentially are referenced or
called using the import function again
modules can be considered as these large
libraries or larger pieces of code or
applications that we that contain
various different methods and functions
and objects and classes within them
again modules are something that we will
think about a little later files are
data types that are called using the
open function so anytime we and as we
will well during the course of this
tutorial we or during the course of this
this course essentially we will be
working with a lot of files these some
of these files are text files some of
them are comma separated files so all of
these files that we open using uh the
function open or some other certain
specific functions where we create file
objects out of these files these are
what we call file data types finally
there are internal types that are used
by python interpreter again this is
something that does not concern us right
now but just know that The Interpreter
for python uses these data types for its
functioning in this video I will show
you some of the categories of operations
that are possible in Python so let's
start off so the first category of
operations are arithmetic operations and
as you can see in this table there are
different types such as addition
subtraction multiplication so let's go
over them one by one so so a simple
addition operation would be like five
plus six giving me the value 11 I can do
5 minus 3 and that's subtraction
similarly I can do a multiplication
using five say five into two there's
division where I use the backslash so
say I did division of 8 divided by 2.
now you might encounter another type of
division which is called the flow
division where we use a double backslash
and what this does is it returns us the
largest whole number that is lesser than
the result of our division so the
division difference between the float
Division and and the normal fluid and
the floor division or the single and the
double backslash is this say I did 9
divided by 2 using a single backslash it
should give me as you can see 4.5 right
so this is the actual value now let's
see what happens when I do 9 double
backslash two it will give me 4 which is
the largest number lesser than or equal
to 4.5 that is also a whole number so
this is what we call flower division
essentially finally we also have if we
want to raise something to the power or
something so if I want to do fire say 6
raised to the power 3 that I would use
double asterisks and this is how I would
do it it'll give me 216 as you can see
uh if I wanted remainder between the
division between two different numbers I
will use the percentage sign so if I
wanted the remainder of the division
between seven and three this is how I
would do it I get the answer 1 as you
can see so next category of operations
are logical operations the first one is
the logical and operation where we use
the operator end all right so let's see
what we mean by this I am creating so as
we know the and operation Returns the
value true if both the operands are true
so let's actually let's actually do this
for an example let's give this variable
the value true and this the value false
so it should be done like this false so
now uh think of it like one and zero so
a one and zero is obviously zero right
so if I did A and B I should get the
answer false or zero because I'm doing
true and false so it's like doing one
and zero so if you see this I should get
the answer false if I change this to
true as well now if I do this I will get
the answer true as you can see uh the
next logical operation is the or
operation where well uh logical or is if
either of the operands are true then we
should get the answer to our or
operation as true as well so in this
case obviously if I did or over here it
will naturally give us true if I change
this to false
it should again give us true and it will
only give us faults if both are false as
you can see here now it's false the next
operation is The Logical not uh it's
done by using the not operator so in
this case the value that we get is true
if the operand is false so let's take a
as we know a is false over here so if I
did not a I should get the answer true
but if I change this to true now if I do
not a I should get false as you can see
so this was The Logical operations let's
move on to the next set of operations
that is comparison operations so there
are a bunch of them let's go over them
one by one if I want to check if two
operands are equal so if I did X is say
equal to 2 and now Y is equal to 3. if I
want to check if they are equal I will
use the double equals to sign and if
they are equal I will get the value true
if they aren't either I'll get value
false as you can see since X is 2 and Y
is 3 as you can see X and and why are
not the same so there's false they are
not equal if I change this also to 2 now
I will get the answer to another the
next comparison is the not equal to or
where we use the exclamation sign so
over here this is this um the result of
this is true if X and Y are not actually
it's the same so I should get false over
here as you can see but if I change this
to say 5 now I will get true because X
is not equal to Y in this case the next
one is greater than so if I did X
greater than y as we can see 2 is not
greater than 5 I will get false over
here similarly there is a lesser than if
I did X less than y I should get true
over here as you can see well there's
also a greater than or equal to and
lesser than or equal to which simply add
the equal to sign here so let's see now
if I say x is less than or equal to 3 I
should get true because X is 2 and if I
put 2 here I should also get true but
what if I put 1 here since X is equal to
2 and 2 is not less than equal to 1 this
is a false statement and I can do the
same thing with like this using the
greater than equal to now it's true
because 2 is actually greater than equal
to 1 and so this was comparison
operations the next set of operations
that we can do in Python are assignment
operations we've already seen a whole
bunch we've already been assigning
values to variables we've been doing
assignments throughout already but let's
go over them and see some of the
assignment operations so as we already
know the equal to operation is assigning
everything that is on the or the value
on the right hand side of the equal to
sign to what is on the left so if I did
a is equal to 5 plus 6 it will assign
the value of 5 plus 6 or 11 to a let's
check what's in a as you can see it is
11. there is a plus equal to sign and
what this does is so for example if I
did say a now since a is 11 let's create
another variable called B and call this
5 all right so now if I did a plus equal
to B what this will do is it will add B
to a and then store it in a so let's see
what this does once I do this now let's
check what's in a it should be 5 plus 11
as you can see 16. so this a plus this
is this plus equal to sine is
essentially the same as doing a is equal
to a plus b it's essentially the same
thing they're both the same uh there's a
similar thing for this the negative or
subtraction as well minus equal to so
now that a is 16 and B is still 5 of
course if I did minus equal to B now I'm
subtracting the value 5 from 16 so I
should get a is equal to 11 again as you
can see here and this is the equivalent
of doing a minus B A is equal to a minus
B I mean as you can see so uh the next
similar like assignment operation let's
create a is equal to say 6 in this case
and say B is equal to I will say 2 right
now if I do a star star equal to B what
this does is it multiplies B to a and
then assigns it back to a so if I see
what's in a now it should be 12 as you
can see here similarly there is a
similar thing for subtraction as well so
if I did a is equal to 6 and B is equal
to 2 and if I did a sorry for division
so if I did a division symbol and equal
to sine and then if I give B what it
will do is it will divide a by b or 6 by
2 and it will assign that back to a so
my value in a should be 3 as you can see
here 3.0 obviously this is a single uh
single backslash so this is a float
division the resultant of a single
backslash is always a float I can do the
same thing with a double backslash so
let's see if I did a is equal to 7 now
and then B is equal to 3. now if I did a
double backslash equal to B now it will
do the same division but uh it will do a
floor function so it should give me 2 in
this case if I did the same thing with a
single backslash just to show you the
difference between single backslash and
double backslash division in this case
it will give me
um the value around 2.3 or something a
float basically 2.33 as you can see here
then there is the modulus you can use
the modulus sign as well with this
assignment say a is equal to say 5 now B
is equal to 2 now if I do a percentage
symbol equal to 2 I mean the it should
give me it will assign the uh it will
take the modulus in both sides and then
assign it to the left hand upper end now
let's see what's in a as you can see it
it did a divided by 2 the modular symbol
is basically the remainder of the
division between two objects so in this
case it will divide a by B and then give
me the remainder and then put the
remainder back in a and as you can see
the remainder of 5 divided by 2 is 1 and
we get that over here similarly we can
also do exponential so if I have a is
equal to say so 5 b is equal to 2 and I
want to raise a by if I wanted to raise
the value of a by the value of B and
then store that back in a this is how I
would do it so it should be 5 to the
power 2 which is 25 as you can see here
so this is assignment operations so
finally we move on to uh two special
sets of operators one is the identity
set identity operators and the other is
the membership operators uh let's look
at the identity operators so when we
talk about identity operators what we
when what we mean is the is and the is
not operator so what the is operator
does is it checks whether two operands
uh have the same location in the memory
essentially this does not mean that it
does not check for whether two objects
have the same value and this is very
important so let's look at this if a is
equal to one thousand and one and B is
equal to one thousand plus one all right
if I did a is equal to 2. this is an
equality check are they the same values
true now if I say a is B let's see what
happens as you can see it's false this
is because this object and this object
are not the same and this is what the is
Operation does uh we can confirm this by
checking the ID of a the ID of a gives
us some value like this and the ID of B
gives us as you can see a different
value so the two objects are not located
in the same place of the memory as we
have seen using the ID function and that
is what we check uh through the is
operator and is not is essentially just
the opposite of that so so that is the
identity operator now the membership
operator is used for checking whether
something is present in a sequence or
not so let's create a sequence I will
create a list to show in this example my
list is one two and three basically
simple list with three integer objects
one two and three I will check whether
now say 2 in a so is 2 in a if it is it
will give me true as you can see is 5 in
a it should give me false because 5 is
not in a and the a naught n operator is
just the opposite of that it checks the
other condition essentially so this is
the membership operators in Python in
this video we will be looking at the
math module in Python and we will look
at some of the math functions that are
associated with this module in Python so
starting off what is this math module
well uh the python map module is an
important library or a feature that is
uh designed to deal with mathematical
operations this math module is part of
the basic python installation so you
don't have to install this separately to
use this math module all you have to do
is import this module and this is how
you would do it you just do import math
and this will import your math module
for you to use in your programming and
in this in the course of this video I
will be showing you certain Concepts
surrounding the math module such as what
are the constants that come with the
mass module some of the arithmetic
functions the logarithmetic functions
power functions and even trigonometric
functions that we can do using this math
module and the function inside the math
module so starting off let's look at
some of the constants that are part of
this so as you can see the standard
constants are available in this module
are Pi there is Tau there is Euler's
number Nan which is a special it's a
it's a programming specific concept and
infinity so let's look at this one by
one so starting off our first constant
is pi
um Pi is as you know in maths it's the
ratio of the of a circles circumference
to its diameter and Pi is an irrational
number you know the value of pi is 3.14
something since it's an irrational
number it does not we cannot Define it
in terms of a specific fraction but it
can be approximated to the fraction 22
by 7. so how do we access this Pi
constant is as simple as this once you
have imported maths uh the match module
all you have to do is do match dot pi
and it will give you the value as you
can see so as you can see the value
returned to us is a float this is
important to note and the number of
number of decimal digits uh the number
of digits after the decimal point that
we can see here are 15 and this is like
a by default thing for python that if
you call the pi a constant it will give
you the value of pi correct up to 15
decimal points so an example of where we
can use this thing is say we have the
radius of a circle 3 it can be in any
units 3 meters or whatever you want and
you want to find out it's say
circumference so as we know the
circumference of a circle is 2 pi r so
if I had to find the circumference of a
circle in my C in my code for some
application with the radius 3 however
all I would have to do is use the
formula 2 pi r and to call the value 2
pi r instead of specifically writing
3.14 something I can just use this
function math dot pi over here and then
I can enter the r as you can see it will
return me the radius as you can see so
moving on the next constant that we will
talk about is Tau Tau is similar to Pi
in fact tau is the ratio of a circle
circumference to its radius Pi is the
ratio of a circle circumference to its
diameter and tau is the ratio for
circles circumference to its radius so
important to know this difference so
because of this definition tau is always
2 times the value of pi this is by
definition and much like Pi if you call
the Tau constant in you from the math
module it will also return you a float
number and to find that this is the
function that we use or this is the
syntax so as you can see this is this is
actually two times the value of pi 6.283
and even this is returned correct up to
15 places to the right of the decimal
point and this is by default uh next
constant is the Euler's number the
Euler's number is a it's one of the most
widespread constants used in the world
of uh in the scientific community in the
mathematical Community
um you will be using the Euler's number
probably a lot as a if if you move into
data science or AI or something like
that so what is the Euler's number it is
uh it is the base of the natural
logarithm if you know what the natural
logarithm is it is used to calculate
rates of growth or rates of Decay and as
with number is a constants like pi and
Tau even the Euler's number is an
irrational number with infinite decimal
places uh the value of the Euler's
number in short it's denoted by the
small letter e so this value of e is our
usually approximated around 2.718 so how
do we call this constant is simply as
math dot e this is how we do it so you
get this value again this is also a
float and it's correct up to 15 decimal
places so the next concept that we will
be talking about is infinity now
Infinity is a it's more of a
mathematical concept and this is very
important to note because Infinity
doesn't is not really a number there is
no number called Infinity it is it is
used to define something that is
infinitely large or infinitely small so
positive Infinity is something that is
higher than any known number to us and
negative Infinity is lower than any
known number to us so this is the
concept of infinity and how do we call
this uh function well so let's see what
happens when we call the math function
math constant Infinity so this is how we
do it and as you can see it will return
us this it might look like a string to
you but this is actually a special type
in Python
um which is not a string this is all
also a float it's a type of a float in
fact this Infinity value it's it's a
it's like a special data type it's a
special data type that you can you can
consider as an equivalent to a float but
um it's not it's not a typical float
that we know like you know 3.14 or 2.71
the value of method.ins will give us INF
and this is this INF is actually not a
string so we can we can confirm that
over here as you can see when I do a
type when I check the type you see it's
actually a float in fact this was
recently added in Python 3.5 a special
type known as math.inf it returns this
INF data type which is equivalent waste
float so this is this is how we use
Infinity if you wanted to get the value
of say minus infinity all you would have
to do is match dot INF with a minus sign
preceding this constant and you will get
minus INF now let's check if the
concepts or the properties of infinity
are maintained you know like every a
positive Infinity is greater than any
number that we know and negative
Infinity is greater than any number that
we know so let's just confirm this
um so I will take method in and I will
do a check is this greater than say some
really large number something that comes
off the top of my head immediately okay
so let's see if it's if this is true
then this is conceptually correct and as
you can see it is true in fact I can
change this number to anything as large
as I want this will be true because
Infinity is true is larger than any
number that we know and similarly if I
did minus math dot in INF and I checked
some very small number you know a very
very small negative number so just
consider some minus uh 10 to the power
something right this should also be true
uh sorry it should be in a smaller sense
symbol this should also be true because
I'm checking minus infinity it's smaller
than any known number it was and it is
true as you can see so it's very uh also
if you did a if you did something like
so let's say if we do let's add
something to this you know it's a number
so we should be able to do arithmetic on
this let's actually see what happens
when I add say 10 to positive Infinity
it actually gives us the same value back
infinity because uh intuitively we know
that infinity plus anything is still
going to be Infinity right and this is
exactly what python does for us even if
we add a number to this the math dot INF
or the infinity constant in Python it
will still give us uh the same value the
same data type of INF or Infinity
similarly if we subtracted something
from the negative of math.inf you know
uh say minus say again let's say minus
100 so if you subtract something from
minus infinity we're technically still
minus infinity itself so this will again
give us my S and then minus INF as you
can see and this is absolutely what we
need and this is a very very interesting
feature in Python uh finally the last
constant that we will discuss is the na
a n or the not a number constant so this
is not really a mathematical constant
there is no constant in maths called not
a number this is a computer science
related concept that it's used to is
used to denote invalid inputs or in it's
used to indicate a certain places where
say a variable that should have a number
it's been corrupted for whatever reason
and it it now has a text or a symbol and
our code throws an error then in these
in these cases where python expects a
number from us or from your code and it
does not get it it will throw you a n a
n value and this is usually used in
cases where you have errors in your code
so again just to check like what this
this constant like how to call it this
is how you actually do it maths.nan and
it will give you a data type called Nan
also much like the infinity cons
constant let's see what's the type of
this this constant again might look like
a string to you but of course this is
not a string this is enough a numerical
concept and as you can see it's still a
float so this is like um it's another
special uh data type that was created
for specifically this case where uh it's
some it's the equivalent of a float but
um it's not really the typical float
that we are that we associate with so
this is a constants in the math module
so our next topic will be arithmetic
functions that we can do in the using
the math module so some of the common
arithmetic functions that are available
to us are factorials the ceiling
operation floor operation uh there's
permutations there's combinations you
can find the greatest common divisor or
the gcd and the LCM or the least common
multiple and you can truncate numbers so
let's look at them one by one so
starting off with the factorial
operation the factorial operation is
done using the factorial function as you
can see here actually is defined like
this math dot factorial all right so now
what we pass in between the parenthesis
will be uh what we calculate the
factorial for as you know factorial is
so factorial is always for a positive
integer and the factorial for say a
number 10 would mean 10 times 9 times 8
times 7 so on until the number one
obviously factor is only defined for
positive integers uh it is not defined
for negative values or it's uh and it's
also not defined for decimal values so
let's see let's look at an example so as
we know
um so let's say we pass match dot
factorial for six and let's see what's
the value so this is exactly what we
expect so we expect the value of 6 times
5 times 4 times 3 times 2 uh that is
actually 720. let's see what happens
when we pass 0 this should give us one
since we know 0 factorial is one now
let's see an error case where we pass a
minus 5 as you can see this will throw
us an error because factors are not
defined for negative numbers now Moving
On Let's uh so the next function that
we'll talk about is the ceiling function
so the ceiling function is defined using
math dot CL as you see here so again we
pass the number that we want the ceiling
for in between the parenthesis so what
is the Searing function it gives you the
largest uh sorry excuse me it gives you
the smallest number that is uh greater
than or equal to what we pass over here
so for an example if I give you 6.6 and
I asked you okay what is the ceiling
function for 6.6 it should give you 7
because 7 is the largest integer in
integral value that is greater than 6.6
or equal to it obviously if you give the
ceiling function for an integer it will
give you the integer itself so let's
look at an example 7.8 so this should
give me the value 8 as you can see here
let's look at it now a negative number
so minus 12.3 uh an integer that is
greater than minus 12.3 is is minus 12
the smallest integer that is greater
than minus 12.3 and this should give you
12 as you can minus 12 as you can see
here a similar function is the floor
function which is defined like this
again the floor function what it does it
gives you the greatest number that is
smaller than whatever value we pass
between the parentheses so if I gave it
2.3 it should give me the value 2. again
if we pass integers it will just give us
the integer itself again it is to
reiterate this ceiling and flow
functions they give you into integer
values so the floor function will give
you the largest integer that is smaller
than what we pass over here so let's
look at 6.7 so the largest integer that
is smaller than 6.7 is 6 and as you can
see this is our answer over here uh the
next function that we will look at is
the truncate function the transcript
function is defined using this truncate
is very similar to what we have seen
this is how we Define the rocket
function uh it is very similar to the
ceiling and floor in the truncate
function what we do is
um we pass a decimal value a float
number to the between between the
parenthesis and what we get back is the
number without the decimal component so
only the integral component so if I gave
it 7.8 for example it will give me only
the seven part it will return me only
the seven part and I will chop away the
point eight part if I gave it minus 12.3
uh it will chop away the 0.3 part and
give me only minus 12 back so let's look
at an example 8.9 it should give me only
eight as you can see here see I did
minus 8 or minus 6.9 this will give me
-6 so you can think of truncate function
as it does the floor function for
positive values and it does the ceiling
function for negative values because it
rounds down and rounds up respectively
for positive and negative values so now
let's look at the next set of arithmetic
functions
um let's move on to permutations
permutations are defined using this as
you know so in between the parenthesis I
have to pass two values n and K okay so
I have to pass n n and a k the K has to
be less than or equal to n because the
permutation as you know is uh the number
of ways in which we can permute from n
objects K Tire K different objects uh so
what this mathematically what this is is
um permutation of N and K is n factorial
divided by n minus K factorial so if I
pass say 10 and 6 it will give me the
permutation of 10 and 6. so let's look
at what's the value as you can see it's
a very large value 15 one fifty one
thousand two hundred similarly there is
a combination function and this is a
combinations of permutations are used a
lot in probability so if you are going
to move into that sphere which you will
encounter a lot in machine learning AI
you will be using these functions quite
a bit
um so the combination function again you
pass an n and a k again the N should be
greater than or equal to this K what
this evaluates is n factorial divided by
n minus K factorial times K factorial so
again this is a mathematical concept so
let's look at the permutation sorry the
combination of 10 and 6. so as you can
see it gives me 210 which is the
combination of 10 seconds in the
arithmetic function section
um our gcd and LCM as we know gcd is the
greatest common divisor LCM is least
common multiple so as of the newest
version of python in three point python
3.9 the math module gets these two new
functions that were very lately added
actually
um since uh I cannot show you that
because I don't have the absolute latest
version of python on my system but using
the
math.gcd function this is the function
and in between this we would what we
would do if we had the latest version is
we would pass two numbers or as many
numbers in fact and what this function
will do is find the common divisor
amongst them so if I give these say for
example if I gave these numbers it would
give me the value 10. similarly the LCM
function again added in the python 3.9
finds the common multiple amongst or
whatever we pass over here so if I
passed say 20 and 30 this will give me
uh the value of 60 which is the LCM of
20 and 30. so again these are it's
something neat that if you say you have
python 3.9 or uh if you have python 3.9
or after that uh you will have access to
these functions as well if you when you
import the math module so that was for
the arithmetic uh functions let's move
on to the next section which are power
and logarithmetic logarithmic functions
so let's start off with the power
function
um there are two there are uh multiple
ways you can actually do a power
function in math in Python so you can do
something like this which is the
equivalent of 2 to the power 3 or you
can use the inbuilt uh module math and
you can use the pow or the power
function which is this is how you do it
and if I had to do same 2 to the power 3
I would just pass 2 and 3 has arguments
like this and it should give me the
value as you can see 8 over here what if
so there's actually one more function
which is simply the pow function and
this is uh not part of the math module
it's a function not part of the math
module but it's still part of the base
python use this as well and you can do
the same thing pow 2 and 3 should give
you the value 8 again the you know you
might ask what's the difference between
these two functions well it's not much
for at least in a beginner standpoint
it's not that much just note that the
maths dot power function is slightly
computationally faster than the simple
power function so yeah moving on their
next topic would be the next function
that we'll discuss is the exponential
function which is defined like this
again exponential function is again e to
the power something so if I did
exponential of 3 this would give me e to
the power 3. so as you can see oh of
course I did not Define the module
beforehand so math.exp now when I do
this it should it will give me some
value which is basically Euler's number
or e to the power 3. so this was the
exponential function and let's look at
an example so we will look at the
example of rate of d k and we will use
the uh this function in that example so
the exponential rate of Decay
um uh for uh is used to calculate the
amount of radioactive elements that is
present in a substance after a certain
amount of time so the the the the the
expression is uh something like the
initial amount of radioactive elements
that were present uh right at the
beginning times the exponent of minus
693 times t t for time divided by the
time period the half-life time uh so
let's just write it down to make it
simple so again as you can see the uh so
this will give me the remaining amount
of radioactive elements right so let's
uh so write down remaining let's assign
this to a variable remaining so the
initial again
um initial is the initial amount of
radioactive elements so let's give it
some value say 100
um the time let's assume it's 10 years
and let's say the half-life
um Half-Life is around I don't know
let's give some value say three or
something again this is uh the details
are not important so this will I'm using
the math dot exponential function over
here as you can see and for these values
uh now when I check what's the value of
remaining after I calculated something
uh so this is it's basically what this
tells me is that I started off with 100
units of some radioactive element
um and in 10 years if this is what is
left so yeah so this is how we would use
say the X exponential functions in a
particular example of us so next the
next type of again functions are
logarithmic functions so let's look at
some of the logarithmic functions that
are part of the math module so basic log
function would be written like this math
DOT log in in between this I would pass
the number that I want the log for by
default if I just pass one number it
will it will calculate the log of 8 to
the base of e as we know e is the
Euler's number so let's see what it does
in this case gives me some value what if
I wanted to specify a particular base
well I would pass a second argument in
this case I want to find the log of a to
the base 2 this should be the value 3 as
you can see over here uh there are two
specific functions that are also
provided in this math module that is log
2 uh what this will do is again it will
again I have to just pass one argument
and this will automatically find the
value of the log of 8 to the base 2. as
you can see here similarly there is a
math DOT log 10 function if I give if I
did this I will find the value of
something here to the base 10 as you can
see so this was a logarithmic functions
then you have the finally you have the
square root function so how would we use
the math the square root function is Max
dot sqrt again we passed what we want
over here if we want the square root of
say 49 this should give me the value 7
as you can see finally maybe move on to
the final set of functions that we can
do using this math module uh they are
trigonometric functions and they are
hyperbolic functions so let's start off
with some of the trigonometric functions
as we know
um we can do sine we can do cosine and
tan uh some of the basic functions
um the way we would do it is math DOT
sign in between this what we this is to
calculate the sign of a particular angle
and this angle must be passed in radians
and this is very important to note we do
not pass it in degrees but in radians so
if I say past sine of 3.14 as we know
3.14 is an approximation of the value by
sine Pi is supposed to be in fact it's
supposed to be zero so let's see we get
something close 0 again since this is an
approximation it won't give us the exact
value similarly we can use math dot cos
to find the value of a particular angle
if you want to find yeah if you want to
find the value of the sorry the cost of
a particular angle we can use the tan
function in case we wanted to find the
tan similarly we have the next set for
arc sine and the arc cosines of uh the
certain of angles so to use to find the
arc sine for example we would use a DOT
sign I mean sorry a sign for R cosine we
would use this and for r10 we would use
this the next set would be hyperbolic
functions again hyperbolic functions are
basically the sine and the cosine and
the time calculated not circles but on
hyperbolas again the details don't have
to be you don't have to know the details
you just should you should know that if
you wanted to say for example find out
the hyperbolic sign of n and a of an
angle we would use math dot sine H and
we would pass what we wanted between
this similarly if we wanted to find the
cosine it would be cos H tan it would be
tan H and if we wanted to find the
inverse of the hyperbolic inverse we
what we would do is what we would do is
use a so we would use a tan H if you
wanted to find the hyperbolic inverse uh
of sine we would use a sine H and
similarly for cos it would be cos a COS
H in this video we will learn about
conditional statements uh and we will
learn about how do we create these
control structures where we have these
conditional statements we will learn
about the keywords if we use in Python
to create a conditional statement block
the if keyword the alif keyword and the
else keyword we will also learn about
indentation and its importance in Python
so let's get started so the basic uh
syntax if you will for a if statement in
Python consists of the keyword if
followed by an expression as you can see
from this pictorial if there's an if
statement there is a expression uh there
is this a block of code which if you can
actually see is slightly indented to the
rest of the code uh and then we have the
rest of the rest of our code after that
so what we're looking at is this so this
is our if statement block
um now let's let's break this down so
what is this expression that we're
speaking of uh an expression in this
context is a Boolean expression which
evaluates to a true or false statement
so when we are speaking about the if
statement we have an expression and if
this expression evaluates to true then
we X execute everything below the if
statement otherwise we skip that portion
as you can see if this statement is true
we execute this statement or these
statement blocks uh otherwise if it's
false we move on to the next the next
statement block or the beginning of a
new statement uh so let's look at an
example to further understand this let's
take this if statement over here as you
can see in this if statement I have this
expression 50 greater than 30. so what
python is going to do now is it's going
to check whether 50 is greater than 30
and it's going to check in a Boolean
context if this is true then we can move
on to the next portion which is this but
if it is false then we will skip this so
let's see what this uh what happens over
here so since we know that 50 is indeed
greater than 30 this is a true
expression we move on to this block of
code which is saying that print 50 is
indeed a larger number than 30. so let's
see if this actually gets printed so as
you can see we get this uh the result
which is this is a true statement and we
get our print statement getting executed
what if we give a false expression over
here so let's look at what happens if I
gave a false expression now I'm checking
if 50 is lesser than 30 which is a false
statement so if it's a false statement
we do not move on to this portion of our
if statement block and we we directly in
fact we directly skip so if I have to
execute this you will see nothing gets
executed and in fact my print statement
is just not executed because we never
entered this because our expression over
here was indeed false so yeah this is
how a basic if statement block looks
like in Python and this is how the uh
how we move on to how we check for the
true the truth truthfulness or the
falseness of a particular expression in
the if statement so moving on
um let's move on to the topic of
indentation in in Python so as you can
see this uh this if statement is an
example of a control structure so
without moving without defining uh what
a control control structure is in detail
control structures consists of these
conditionals or Loops or iterations if
you will uh so all of these control
structures involve heavy indentation so
so what does an indentation mean well
what if I gave you an example say I gave
you some variable called H and I wrote
20 over here now if I give you an if
statement saying if age is greater than
10 now uh it's very important to note
that when I'm defining an if statement I
need this colon otherwise this if
statement is not defined so this colon
is important anyways so now I'm checking
this expression if age is greater than
10. now what is this what happens if H
is greater than 10 now what if I want
python to do something only if age is
greater than 10 well how do I tell
python that there is a piece of code or
a section of code that I want executed
only if this condition is met well this
is where indentation comes into play so
if I want say if I want this line this
person is an adult again this is some
random line where I'm assuming age is
pertaining to this adult all right or
this person so if I have uh this
variable age where I write this number
20 which denotes the age of some person
and I'm doing a check if age is greater
than 10 actually let's be specific here
well the adult age for most people is 18
in most countries so let's see if age is
greater than 18. now if I'm doing this
check uh I want to print this statement
only if this person is a person's age is
above 20 above 18 so how do I tell
python that I only want this statement
to be uh executed only during this if
this condition is met well this is where
indentation comes into play and as you
can see exactly as you can see uh this
part this portion of the code is
slightly indented compared to the if
statement so when this condition is met
then only do we move on to this if this
condition is not met we move on to
whatever the next section of code will
be like whatever whatever code that we
have after this if statement so let's
see so this since this condition is
actually met as you can see this print
statement is actually executed so this
is the importance of indentation now we
will see uh in as we move as we learn
more about if statements and else
statements and alif statements how
indentation plays a key role in defining
what we want as an output when a certain
condition is met all right so for now
it's very important to understand that
this is how indentation is used in
Python in other languages we might use
uh we probably don't use indentation in
fact popular language the C language
does not use indentation at all but some
languages and python in probably the
trademark language for indentation and
programming so you might say that so
different people have different opinions
on indentation the general consensus is
that indentation helps make the code
look very presentable and very readable
and this actually is one one of the
facets of Python Programming is the
indentation and the easy readability of
it anyways moving on so what if we have
um multiple conditions in our code or if
in our if statement block that we want
to see so let's create this list or
let's actually just copy this example
that I have written over here as you can
see what I am doing in this piece of
code is I have a list X where I have
this integer 50 I have two strings cat
and apple now I want to check a bunch of
things so I want to check if 60 is an X
and I also want to check if the string
cat is in X and I want a final sort of
like if none of these conditions are met
I want something to happen so how do we
do that well we start off our state our
if statement block with the standard if
keyword all right now if we have one
more condition that we want met then we
can use the L if which is kind of a
short form for else if uh so we use the
L if keyword so it so what this python
uh what python reads is it checks this
condition then it will check this
condition and then finally we have this
else keyword and else is a keyword used
in our block to tell python that if none
of our earlier Expressions have been
true then do what is in the uh there
that is within the else keyword that is
indented within the else keyword so
again we don't pass an expression for
else because else is only we only Reach
This LL statement in case all of the
earlier conditions have not been met or
have uh come to be false and not true so
let's look at uh this particular code
example so we have a list of 50 cat and
apple and I'm my first expression that
I'm checking is uh is 60 in X so this is
how we check actually so if 60 and X
should be read as is 60 in the list X so
is this 16 elix list X well actually no
we don't have the object 60 so this part
is not executed we move on to the next
condition is the string cat in X well
actually it is uh the string cat is
indeed in X so we move on to this
statement block which is within the
condition that is met which is print cat
is in list X and you will see that none
of the other statement blocks will be
executed because we have met our
condition over here so if I execute this
as you can see that the print statement
cat is in this text is what is actually
executed and we do not execute this
obviously because it is false and we do
not even check or we do not even move on
to the statement because well we have a
condition mat over here so it's a one
thing that is important to note is that
we can use as many alif statements to
check for as many conditions that we we
want to check for but it's very
important that we only use and if we are
using that we only use one else
statement and only at the end end of our
block okay so moving on now I'm going to
show you a very neat example about how
python actually does its uh these
condition checkings so it's very
important to note that once a condition
is met none of the other conditions are
even checked for so
um we do not even consider the next
statements and we directly leave this if
statement block so let's look at this
example over here now in this example
that I have over here is where I've
stored the string cat in X now I have
three uh I have three conditions that
I'm checking I'm checking is 50 greater
than 60. I am checking if the value of x
is indeed cat and I'm checking I'm some
random expression 1 divided by 0. this
is not even a check this is literally
just checking if 1 divided by 0 is true
or false and as we know we cannot divide
anything by zero so let's see what
happens when I execute this statement
now typically if I wrote 1 divided by 0
python will throw me an error because 1
cannot be divided by 0 that is an error
statement so let's see what happens when
I do this actually as you can see I have
a statement being printed but I have no
error even though I gave it wrong I gave
an error statement in 1 divided by zero
well now you might ask why is that so
well it's simply because I have actually
never reached this condition I have not
even uh python is not bothered looking
at this because if you actually see
there is a condition previous to this
over here which is met and which is true
so we move on to this block we execute
this block and we forget about the rest
of the code so we don't actually get to
this error statement which is an
interesting thing and which is an
example that I have shown uh to show you
that once a condition is met in an if
statement block we do not look at any of
the further conditions that are being
checked okay so finally
um I have one one small topic that I
would like to share with you is the
conditional expressions or the pythons
ternary operator now this is slightly
different to the if statement that we
have talked about up until now in the
sense that it is not a control structure
so what this actually is is more of an
operator that defines some expression so
let's see what I am trying to say over
here so as you can see over here
highlighted is the uh Syntax for what
I'm trying to talk about this ternary
operator so let's look at this example
and let's see what I'm trying to do over
here so I have this variable age all
right and this age is 26 now X now just
just read this statement X is equal to
adult if age is greater than 18 else
child now I could have done an elaborate
control structure with an if statement
then an indentation within that if
statement and then I could have written
else and then another indentation and I
would have written another statement
over there but instead of that I have
used this operator to assign a
particular value to the variable X and
this uh what value I'm assigning to X
depends on if this condition is 2 or 4
false so as you can see the condition
says is age 18 greater than 18. so if
this is true then I assign this
particular string if it is false then I
go on to the else statement and I assign
this so since age 26 is greater than 18
I should assign the string adult to X
and as you can see if I execute this and
check what is an X you can see adult is
indeed in X so this is a very neat a
very needable readable and a very um
it's a it's probably a more it's it's a
better looking way to perform simple
else uh Sim simple if and else
statements where you don't want to
create a whole um if stay if if else
statement control structure block so
yeah this was the ternary operator
finally we Let's uh we we make a short
note on the pass statement uh in Python
so the path statement or the past
keyword is a a place where it is is a
placeholder of sorts so what if I had an
if statement and I'm writing a piece of
code but I don't know what to do with
this if statement so if if a statement
is correct if a statement is true but I
don't know what to do if this statement
was true how do I tell python well let's
just keep it a hold for now and I might
put something into this block later in
the future well I would use the pass
statement so if I had this say this some
condition again so I'm checking age is
greater than 18 but I don't know what to
do with this I would just simply use
this pass statement and this basically
does nothing uh it it's a way to it's
like a way to create a placeholder where
maybe in the future I might have I might
write some sort of a say a print
statement or some sort of a different
function or something else within this
indentation so but in the meantime like
currently I don't have anything to place
over here so I just leave it with a pass
statement so this is a way where you can
use a pass statement in if and else
statement or if an else control
structures in this video we will be I
will introduce you to the concept of
iterations in Python and we will be
speaking in specific about the
indefinite iteration advice and
otherwise known as the while loop so
let's look at what an iteration means an
iteration is executing the same block of
code over and over potentially many
times a programming structure that
implements an iteration is called a loop
now in programming we have two types of
iterations definite and indefinite
iterations and in this example we will
be speaking about indefinite iterations
in definite iterations in Python is the
while loop where we use the while
keyword to Define an indefinite
iteration so let's look at the basic
syntax as you can see this is the basic
syntax where we have the while keyword
followed by an expression and again the
colon and below that is something
indented again we encounter indentations
just like NFL statements a set of
statements where what happens here is
following the while keyword we have this
expression where this expression is
evaluated in a Boolean context again we
check if this expression evaluates true
or false and if it is true V we execute
all the statements or the statement
block that is indented below this file
statement this is another example of
control structure much like FNL state in
blocks where we use a lot of indentation
so let's look at a basic example now of
while loop so let's copy this example
and let's see what this does so I have a
variable n where I am assigning it a
value 0. this is called an initializing
process and it's very important to note
that most while Loops consist of an
expression which contains a variable a
control variable uh which is usually
initialized prior to starting the loop
and then this control variable is
typically very modified somewhere within
the main Loop body so in this case my
control variable is n and I am
initializing it by assigning it the
value 0. so let's move into the loop now
so the loop has this wire keyword as you
can see followed by a an expression n
lesser than or equal to to 5. now what
this is is an expression which is going
to check if it's true or false is n
lesser than or equal to 5 and as long as
this expression is true we will continue
doing whatever is indented below this y
statement and what is below this y
statement is a print statement first of
all which says value of n is and it
basically prints a value of n in that
particular iteration and as you can see
this uh compound assignment where we add
the value of n by 1 and we assign it
back to n so what this is uh let's see
what this does actually let's execute
this and see what this does important to
note the value of n again is initialized
at 0. so this while loop will keep going
on until the value of n remains lesser
than or equal to 5. so as you can see I
have the execution of this uh particular
block of code or this while loop where I
get the multiple different iterations of
this print statement that you can see
here the first iteration it says value
of n is 0 then it will value of n is 1.
what I am doing is I am writing I am
assigned I'm writing uh the value of n
multiple times uh and each time the
value of n is written over here based on
what iteration it is so what is
happening actually is uh the initially
value of n is 0 and I print the
statement value of n is 0. now I add uh
the value of what is In N by 1 so now
what is the value of n so again we do
this check so after this first iteration
we come back or like once this whole
block of code is executed we again come
back to this expression and we again
check if the statement is true so now
that the value of n is actually 1 this
statement is still true so again we
execute this and as that you can see
over here value of n is one now again we
add the value of n by 1 and again we go
back here once this uh this block is
executed and we check if this statement
is true again and as you can see the
value of n when it's 2 is still making
sure that this expression is true and
this keeps happening until the value of
n is greater than 5 so once the value of
n becomes 6 this condition is no longer
met and finally we do not execute the
statement because this expression
evaluates to false and we do not do this
anymore and we finally leave our while
loop so let's check what the value of n
is just to confirm this as you can see
the value of n is indeed 6 and that is
why we have left this while loop over
here so this is an example of a basic
while loop where we check for this uh an
expression if it evaluates to true we
evaluate everything within it once this
is done we go back and we evaluate this
expression again if it is again true we
again go back into whatever is indented
within it and we keep doing this until
the expression gives us false and
interestingly we don't uh we don't
necessarily have to Define these control
variables always we can actually use uh
iterables and we will learn about
iterables actually in a future video but
we can use iterables and an example of
an iterable is the list so let's look at
this list and let's look at this whole
block all right so I created this list a
which contains five objects one two
three four and five all integer objects
and I have another variable X where I
store the integer one now I'm this wire
statement now it might look confusing
now it's it says it says while a now
what is a well a is not uh your typical
expression where you're making sure if
some condition is being met or not but
this the way you read this is while a
exists so in the context of a list as
long as a which is a list contains
objects within it a is true if it does
not have any objects within it a is
false so while a basically what it means
is while a has objects within it and if
it does have objects within it or as
long as it does we continue executing
whatever is indented within this while
statement and this y statement is a
print statement again we do like we we
have this value X where we we're doing
this this web printing this is iteration
number and uh we pass X so the first
iteration obviously pass X is equal to 1
and then we add X by 1 and then the
second iteration should pass this
iteration number two and then so on and
finally we have another statement within
this block called the a call the uh pop
statement where we're popping the
elements of a now as if you would have
seen the list the video on list the pop
statement removes the rightmost value uh
from a list so if I do a DOT pop
initially it will remove 5 from this
list and I will have the rest of them
and again if I do pop it will remove
four from this list then you will have
the rest of these so let's actually see
we'll actually check what's left in this
list each time we do this pop statement
so I'll also print the list a it's uh
during each iteration and let's see what
happens over here as you can see what is
happening out here is while a or while a
has elements we are going to continue
doing this y statement whatever is
within it so in the first iteration
obviously we have all of it uh and it is
iteration number one and as you can see
the list contains everything then I pop
it then iteration number two it again
has elements but it has lost its most
rightmost element and this keeps on
happening until the list finally has no
elements left and once the element or
invents a list has no elements left we
this expression while a evaluates to
false and we do not execute this anymore
and we leave the while low and again
let's check what is in a a should have
no elements as you can see it's an empty
list when I check what's in a it's an
empty list and that is why while a
return near false and we do not print
any further so this is an example of
using a wire statement using lists and
of course the next topic would be
discussing nested while loops and this
is a broad topic what I mean by this is
that when when I'm saying nested while
Loops I'm actually talking about nested
control structures so we can have while
Loops within while Loops not only that
we can have FNS statements within while
loops we can have while Loops within if
and else statements and we can have FNL
statements within FNL statements so if
you think of all of these loops and we
will even speak about four Loops in the
in the in in a in another video for
Loops again a type of control structure
so all of these are control structures
while Loops are control structures for
Loops or control structures if and as
statements are control structures all of
these are control structures and nesting
can happen within them and it does not
matter uh which is the like the parent
of the nest and then the child of the
nest we can have a while loop within an
ifnl statement you can have for Loops
within a while loop all of this is valid
in Python and uh it's one of the one of
the great features of python that is
very flexible in this way so let's look
at an example where I have a while loop
within another while loop so I am
copying this piece of code where I have
this list one two three four five and
another list first and second now my
first while loop I print I print what is
pop from a so I take a then I pop the
zeroth index so basically from the left
hand side and I print what is that all
right and then I have another while loop
where I have this list B and I'm doing
the same thing but this while loop is
within the first while loop and let's
see what happens out here so as you can
see my first uh my first iteration of
this parent while loop causes me to pop
what is the first element which is one
then I do these while loops and this is
completely executed and only then do I
go back to this first one and then I
come back and do all of this again then
I go back to this one and then I come
back into all of this again and that's
why you can see this repetition so I
have this first iteration and then I do
uh the second while loop then I have the
second iteration and then I do the
second while loop and I keep doing this
and this is an example of a nested while
loop okay so our next Topic in this sec
in this video would be break in continue
statements now break in continue
statements are ways to abruptly end
iterations uh in in a particular Loop
you can use break in continue statements
not only in while loop where you can use
it and also in for Loops so let's look
at how we use it in while loops and
let's look at what we mean by breaking
container statements first of all well
the break statement terminates the loop
entirely so once the break statement is
found the the complete while loop that
we are using is completely terminated
and the continue statement on the other
hand terminates only the current Loop
iteration and it goes back to the
beginning or the expression and it
checks whether the expression or the the
controlling expression is again
re-evaluated and it is checked whether
the loop will execute again or terminate
this pictorial that you can see here
actually emphasizes or it shows the
difference between break and continue so
I have this while loop and I have an
expression all right I have a bunch of
statements and I have a break command
over here and I have a continue command
over here so if I encounter the break
command it will not execute any of this
in fact it will not execute this wire
statement at all and it will move on to
the next piece of code that we have but
a continuous statement if a continuous
statement is encountered in a while loop
will not completely break away but it
will not uh it will not execute the the
rest of the statements in that iteration
only these two but it will go back here
it will check this expression again and
again we will do this all over again so
this is this small uh difference between
the break and continue statements but
both are used to abruptly end an
iteration in a loop so let's look at an
example of how we use the break
statement so I will use this example
where I have again I have initialized
some controlling variable n to 0 my
first Loop will check whether n is less
than equal to 5 if this is true then I
will print this statement then I will
what I'm doing over here is I am
incrementing it by one now in my
previous my earlier example using a
similar uh using the similar example I
had no like this this part was not there
so what you got was I was printing the
value of n so it was printing as like
value of n is one I mean 0 and then one
and then two and then three four and
five but over here I've included a small
I've nested an if statement and within
that I put a break statement and this if
statement is checking if if n is equal
to equal to 2. so once n is 2 I move on
to this and I do the break statement so
let's see what happens now as you can
see once so when I have executed this I
don't get the whole value of n is 0 and
then one and then two three four five I
I stop at one and that is because once n
is equal to 2 I actually do not execute
this while loop again I do not go back
and execute print value of n is 2 now in
fact I break from this whole while loop
and my while loop terminal is right then
and there and that's why you only get
these two iterations value of n is zero
and then value of n is one okay so now
I'm gonna show you a neat example of
what happens or what is the difference
between a break and a continuous
statement okay so let's uh go back to
our initial example where we're printing
this value of n is 0 1 2 3 4 and so on
but I have added one more statement
where I print hello at each iteration so
let's see what happens when I do this as
you can see it will print hello after
each of whatever I was doing already now
let's introduce our break statement
first of all so when I do break well
let's go back to this if statement if
his if we check this condition then we
break let's see what happens now as you
can see something interesting has
happened where we have this first
iteration completely being executed but
the second iteration kind of stops where
there's no hello and that is because we
have broken from this while loop before
the second iterations hello was printed
let's see the difference between a break
and continue now so now I have this
continuous statement instead of a break
let's see what happens here as you can
see it seems familiar to our first
example where we do not have any break
or continue but there is a small
difference that I want you to catch and
that is very important about this
continue uh statement so as you can see
the first iteration has value of n is 0
and then hello and value of n is 1 but
there is no hello and this is because
this is because once this condition is
actually met we do not move on to this
statement but we go back to this
expression and we will evaluate this
expression and then once we evaluate
this expression again and it's found to
be correct we do everything the same
again when we print hello but except for
that one step where this if statement
was met and we did continue and this
following statement was not executed and
that happens only for one iteration and
that is when n is equal to equal to 2
and as you can see that is what happens
over here in one of the iterations we
may say hello and that is the difference
of the continue statement between uh
there is a difference of the continue
statement with the break statement this
video will be an extension into that
topic where we will be looking at three
examples where we are using while Loops
along with other stuff like say if and
else statements so our first example
will be where we calculate the factorial
of a number in this example as you can
see here we are first going to ask the
user to enter a particular number for us
now this number is supposed to be an
integer once we have this integer we
store it to a variable called number now
we have this you can say this variable
called fac which stores 1 and you we
will see how we are using it later now
we know that the factorial of 0 is 1
that's how it's just defined so we have
an if statement checking whether our
entered number is 0 and if it is 0 we
say that the result is 1 or the
factorial is one however if we enter a
number that is greater than 0 we must
calculate the factor oil for this number
and that is what we are going to do in
this else statement block over here now
in this else statement block we have a
while loop in this while loop the
condition is checking while number is
greater than or equal to 1. so as long
as this condition is true everything
within that while loop will be executed
so as long as number is greater than
equal to 1 we are going to execute these
two lines now what do these two lines do
let us see so the first line takes the
variable fac where we had the number one
stored and we are going to store FEC
times number into it number being the
number that we have inputted so in case
for example we we entered 8 then what
this will do this line will do is 1 into
8 and it will store that back into fac
now once that is done we move on to the
next line where we are decrementing the
number variable by one so if we have
stored 8 or we have entered 8 into our
input it will become 7. now as we know 7
still greater than or equal to 1 so this
condition is still being met and then we
do this process again where we are going
to multiply fac this time fac stores the
value 8 and we multiply it times the new
number which is 7 now so we do 8 into 7
and then again we decrement this uh also
1 3 to 8 into 7 we store it back into
fac and we keep doing this where we keep
multiplying 8 times 7 and then we
decrement the number variable uh by one
and then we check this condition again
so what ends up happening is we are
going to keep doing 8 into 7 into 6 into
5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1 and once
we are at 1 again when we do this
document operation the number variable
we store the value is 0 and then this
condition will no longer be met so
number will be 0 and this condition will
be false and we can move out of this
while low then finally we store the
result into a variable called result
which stores the result of 8 into 7 into
6 into 5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1
this is of course if we did enter 8 when
we were asked to give an input so let's
see this
um in real time once we execute this so
I'm executing this the first thing it
asks me is to enter a number so let's
say I enter my number 8 as I was
speaking about eight all right now that
I have entered 8 as you can see the
result that it gives me is factorial of
8 is 4 0 3 2 0 which is correct and you
can check this for yourself where it
will show you
um 8 times 7 or 8 factorial is basically
this this number okay so now in our next
example we will be looking at how we can
generate Fibonacci numbers for this
example we will be using bunch of if and
else if statements along with a while
loop so let's look at this piece of code
where we are actually doing this so as
you can see the first part of the code
is basically an input statement asking
us how many Fibonacci numbers we would
like to generate and then the user would
be asked to give an input which is
stored as an INT into a variable count
now in this if a statement the first if
statement checks whether what we have
entered is 0 in which case we just store
an empty array in the variable called
FIB next if our entered integer is 1 we
just store the value 1 in this array
called FIB if our enter number is 2 we
store 1 and 1 in the array FIB all of
these are different sets of Fibonacci
sequences this obviously an empty an
empty array shows that well there is no
numbers to be generated in this sequence
if we have one we just print the first
number of the Fibonacci sequence which
is one itself if it is 2 we print the
first two numbers which is one and one
now the actual calculations happen when
we say we want a Fibonacci sequence for
more than two numbers now in that case
we move on to this block in this
statement block we initialize the FIB
variable with the first two Fibonacci
numbers one and one and we store in this
very in this array now we are going to
do a while loop within this and in this
while loop we're going to keep executing
this statement block as long as this
condition is met or this condition is
true and what this condition is is it's
checking this variable I which we have
initialized as 1 over here and we are
going to check whether that is lesser
than count minus 1 count being the
number that we have been asked to input
if the statement is true and as long as
the statement is true we will be
executing this statement block which is
basically us appending this expression
into the array FIB now what this
expression is is basically it's going to
keep adding so each subsequent numbers
and we're going to store each subsequent
numbers back into the array Fib so in
this case if you see the fourth the
first step will do is it will take the
value at the first portion of the array
film and it will add it to the value at
the 0th position of the array fib and
both of these values since they are 1
and 1 when we add them we get 2 and we
append that to Fib so now our FIB will
look like 1 comma 1 comma two then we
increment this by 1 and what we do is we
do the same process again so in the next
step what will be what we would do is we
would do 2 plus 1 so we would get three
now this would keep going on until this
condition is met or basically until uh
the numbers that we actually want to
generate in our sequence so let's like
let's let's uh execute this and let's
see an example of what happens so it
asks me how many Fibonacci numbers I
would like to generate and I will say I
want the first let's say six Fibonacci
numbers so I execute this as you can see
this gives me the first six numbers in
the sequence which is 1 and 1 and then 2
which is basically one plus one and then
three which is 1 plus 2 and then 5 which
is 2 plus 3 8 which is 3 plus 5. so if
we wanted more numbers we would just
enter over here like say if we wanted
the first 10 numbers it would give us
the first 10 numbers in the sequence as
you can see here now in our next example
what we are going to do is we are going
to write a program which takes two
digits that represent the dimensions of
an array for example if we want a three
by three array we will enter three comma
3 and we are going to generate a two
dimensional array in which each of the
elements of the array are basically the
row times the column position of that
particular element and what I mean by
this is say we have a position I comma J
on the array the value of the element at
that position would be I times J so for
example if I'm looking at something at
the third row and the fifth column or
say the third row and the third column
for example the value of the element
would be 3 times 3 and if I'm looking at
something at the second row and the
fourth column I am going to do 2 times
4. so let's uh let's see how we can do
this using Code so if you look to the
right over here I have a piece of code
where I'm going to uh in where it asks
me to input two numbers two integers to
represent the dimensions of my uh
example my sample array now once we have
done this we are going to store these uh
these dimensions in the inputs in in a
variable called input string so
obviously when we enter say 5 comma 5
that will be stored as an in in this
particular string or this variable what
we want is we want five say we entered
five comma five we want five as a
separate integer and the other five as
another separate integer and that is
what we do in this particular statement
where we're going to split up our input
string based on the comma separator and
we're going to store the first part of
that string into the 0th position of
Dimensions which is an array and the
next dimension in the first position in
this particular array now we are going
to store the number of rows as row
number and that is the zeroth position
of this array and we're going to store
the number of columns as the first
position of Dimensions or whatever we've
mentioned in the input so now we we have
this our results array called multi-list
which is basically what what our final
array is going to look like and we are
going to store into multi list and in
this example we will be using for Loops
to do this or to create this particular
array so as you can see here our first
uh we have initialized our multi list
saying that um we're going to have only
zeros in our sample array so initial
leave once we have initialized this
array all multi lists will contain is a
say for example we have inputted a five
by five array it will have basically a
5x5 array with all elements as zero and
that's what this line does once we have
done this we are going to move on to the
for Loop portion where we are actually
going to create our array that we want
so as you can see we are our first for
Loop is going to say four row in range
row number so obviously a range will
generate a an iterator which can be
iterated over and since it says range
row number and say our the number of
rows that we entered were five what it's
going to do is it's going to create an
iterator containing the value 0 1 2 3
and 4. so for row and range it will
basically basically row will take the
value 0 1 2 3 and 4. and a similar thing
is going to happen in this nested for
Loop which is within this where we're
going to again uh create a an iterator
using this range function and for the
column number once we have this we're
going to do the simple process of
multiplying the uh the value of the
element based on its position so if it's
at the position 3 comma 4 we're going to
store the value 3 times 4 into that
particular position of the array and
we're going to do this for every
position which is what happens in these
two for Loops we are going to first go
by each row and then within that we're
going to check each column and we're
going to perform these calculations and
finally we print our result so let's
look at an example now I'm going to say
I want a 3 by let's say a 2 by 4 Matrix
so let's see what the results will be
when I give this as so what I'm saying
is I want two rows and four columns now
as you can see here it might not be very
clear to you right now but what you can
see here is this is the first row and
this is the second row and each row
contains four columns so these are the
this is the my final array that I get so
what you can see here is this is the
zero width position and the uh or you
can say this is the first row First
Column first row second column and since
python is zero based so this is actually
the zeroth row and this is the first row
so as you can see uh this this value
basically is zero times one this value
is zero times two zero times three zero
times four and over here it is one time
zero one times one one times two one
times three so similarly if I did for
example a five by five Matrix what you
will get is five rows now five rows and
five columns and for example like this
particular value is uh one two three or
zero one two three so zero one two three
and the First Column so this is three
times one
um if I took this value this is like the
fourth row for example fourth row times
the um zero one two three third column
so this would be four times three which
is twelve so and each value of this has
been generated in the similar process so
this is an example of how we can use for
Loops
um for a particular particular exercise
that I have shown you right now in this
video we will be covering the topic of
definite iterations using for Loops in
Python so starting off we know that
there are two types of iterations in
programming a definite and indefinite we
have already covered indefinite
iterations in the form of while Loops
definite iterations on the other hand
are done using the keyword for and the
basic syntax or the standard Syntax for
a basic for Loop in Python is as you can
see over here we have this four keyword
we have some variable we have the in
keyword and we have this iterable and we
of course Define this control structure
with the colon and then indented we have
this statement block so once this for
Loop has started we execute all of these
statements within the statement block as
part of the for Loop iteration so yeah
let's uh now let's to understand like
how for loops work uh exactly let's look
at the concept or meaning behind what we
call iterables and iterators so so think
of it in a stepwise manner all right so
we in Python we have different objects
that can be used as iterables and an
iterable is basically some object that
uh it's it's a collection of other
objects so you know think of your lists
uh think of dictionaries and sets so all
of these are essentially collections of
objects so once we have these collection
of objects we can create an iterator out
of it how do we do that is we use the
iter function so for example if I passed
this list a if I pass this list a
through the iter function and I store it
in some variable either underscore a and
I see what is it underscore a it is
actually a list iterator at some random
memory location which we don't really
care about similarly if I gave a tuple
and I did the same thing I will create a
tuple iterator and in the left if you
can see over here I've done the exact
same functions with sets and
dictionaries as well so I'm creating
iterators out of these iterables so as
to speak uh now what is an iterator well
an iterator is an object that yields
values successively so if my list
contained five values or five objects an
iterator of this list will yield these
values one after the other and that is
kind of how or that is the basis for
which we do we create Loops let's see
what we exactly mean using this uh using
another function that we call the next
function so the next function keeps
moving from object to object within an
iterator so since I've created this list
iterator let's just do it once again so
as you can see I've created this list
iterator item underscore a now with this
item underscore a what I'm going to do
is I'm going to use this next function
what next function does is starting from
the leftmost object within this iterator
I will keep yielding or keep producing
the values so let's let's just see what
happens when I do next iter when I do
next for this particular variable it
gives me this object first now let's see
what happens when I do it again
now it gives me the object second what
if I did it again it gives me third now
if I kept doing this it will keep giving
me the different objects that were
initially stored in a that is first and
then second third fourth and fifth one
after the other so let's actually
perform that now I get fourth now I get
fifth now a natural question is now that
I've exhausted all of these values what
will happen if I perform the next
function again well let's see what
happens I get a uh an error or and this
error is the stop iteration function
error which basically is telling me look
you have exhausted all of the objects
that were initially present in this list
a and you cannot you cannot keep doing
the next next function anymore you
cannot keep going further so yeah so
this is what the next function does when
it comes to the concept of iterators all
right so now we've learned two things
what is an iterator and what is the how
do we create an iterator out of
different collections of objects like a
list or a tuple and we've also learned
how to use the next function now let's
uh move or let's come back to our for
Loop that we started off this video with
so our for loop again let's consider our
for Loop over here
as you can see some for loop with the
objects again one two three four and
five all right this is a list now I'm
going to do for X in a print X and let's
try to see what happens when we do this
okay as you can see when I have executed
this it gives me one two three four and
five so I have first of all let's look
at this for loop I in this for loop I
Define a new variable X and then I say
for X in a print X and what's happening
well in each iteration I am printing
whatever the value of x is at present so
in the first iteration it is the first
object one in the second iteration it is
the second object two then three four
five and then finally uh on its own like
uh this for Loop knows that okay now
once I have exhausted all of the objects
within my iterator I can stop doing this
for Loop and I can move on with the rest
of the code all right so think of it
like a three-step process a for Loop in
Python the first step is it calls an
iter function to obtain an iterator for
whatever we pass over here this iterable
second step it calls the next function
repeatedly in each iteration all right
to keep getting the next item from the
iterator so it gets one then it calls
next then it gets two then it calls next
and it gets three and then four and then
five and so on and then finally the
third step is determination step is when
after we do the final next where we get
this error as you can see the stop
iteration error or exception finally
this tells the for Loop function or the
for Loop that okay we have reached the
end of our definite iteration or the end
of our definite for Loop and this is
where we must terminate our Loop and
then continue with the rest of the code
all right so this is how a for Loop
Works in Python now it's very important
to note that whatever we have discussed
when it came to while Loops such as
nesting of while loops and nesting of
other control structures is also
applicable in the case of for Loops so
if I had a for loop with in another for
Loop that is perfectly fine if I had a
while within a for Loop that is
perfectly fine so all of these are valid
statement blocks that we can do and
again for Loop is another control
structure and so we must follow the
concept of indentation when it comes to
writing our statement blocks within a
for Loop okay so now I'm going to speak
about in specific I'm going to speak
about the this something called the
range function that is uh quite you
could say it's used definitely it's used
in other areas of programming but it's
widely used in Python uh I mean I mean
the for Loop in Python uh what I mean by
this is that um Range this range
function is very important for the for
Loop and we will see why okay so let's
look at one of the examples of using the
range function so what does the range
function do is if I give range 5 let's
see what it does it gives me range 0 to
5. what this basically tells me is that
this will create an iterator that
contains uh integers from 0 to 5 so it
will contain the object 0 1 2 3 4 and 5
and we can use this as an iterator so
let's let's look at this uh I have Range
Five let's store this in X okay now
let's do a type just to see what happens
when we do Type X it should give me the
type of range as you can see and this is
a type of an iterator in Python now
let's see what happens when I do for I
in X print I okay let's see what happens
as you can see it prints the number 0 1
2 3 4. an important caveat when it comes
to the range function is when we say
range 5 it creates an iterator from 0 to
5 but it contains the objects 0 1 2 3
and 4 only it does not contain the
object 5 itself okay this is something
that is very important to so once again
I created I use this range function to
create an iterator from if iterator 5
objects from 0 to 4 0 1 2 3 and 4. I use
that in my for Loop and that's what that
is what you are seeing here now let's
use this range function in the context
of something else for example let's see
so I had my earlier list a right look at
my list a here
so you can see list a contains these one
two three four five five objects okay
let's see what length of a is length of
a is five okay uh let's use the range
function on top of the length of this
list a and this is uh like I can't show
you an example right now without any
context but this uh this form of using a
for Loop is used is widely used in
Python Programming you will use it so
much in data science you will use so
much in machine learning and AI I cannot
tell you uh this is so this is a very
important like sort of uh for Loop
expression so you have four let's say I
in range Len a let's see what's going on
here first I create first I do length of
a that gives me 5 then into range of 5
that creates an iterator between 0 and 4
right when you do range 5 it gives you
an iterator of zero one two three and
four as we saw earlier and this is what
we're doing over here we have created an
iterator out of the length of a list now
when I do print I it should give me
again one two three four zero one two
three four of course so as you can see
here it will give me zero one two three
four and this is a very neat way of
using the range function on top of the
length of a particular collection of
objects in this case we're using the
list a this is something that you will
use a lot so I I would recommend that
you get used to this form of creating a
for loop as well using the range
function also of course
um there are uh the you can use break
and continue statements as you have in
the case of while Loops uh exactly this
it works exactly the same in the case of
for Loops wherein the break statement
will abruptly stop the for Loop
completely and we will move on to the
next piece of code whereas the continue
statement will break that particular
iteration and then we will resume with
the next iteration so yeah that was
break in continue statements and for
Loops uh finally I would like to show
you something about uh how to use
dictionaries as an iterator or or as an
iterable when it comes to for Loops so
let's create our dictionary let's go we
have a dictionary already here in fact
create this dictionary again it will
store it in a okay so I created this
dictionary a all right so I have
dictionary a uh what I'm going to do is
I'm going to pass it through the iter
function as you can see and now I'm
going to just for the sake of showing
you it will show I'll show you that it
is actually an iterator of type of a
specific Direct Key iterator type all
right so now let's uh let's do something
on this so as you can see in the
dictionary I have the key first that has
the value 1 I have the key second that
has a value two I have the key third
that has a value three and then fourth
for four fifth for five now a good
question would be when I do iteration or
when I do a for loop on top of this a
well what is it going to pick up is it
going to pick up first uh is it going to
pick up the keys like these or is it
going to pick up the values or is it
going to go one by one key and then
value and then key in the subsequent
value uh let's see what actually happens
let's do 4 I in iter underscore a print
I let's see what what is The iterations
Happening upon using this so as you can
see we're using the keys so by default
when we do this when we perform when we
create an iterator out of a dictionary
we use only the keys as our iterator
elements or at iterator values but of
course like if you wanted to use values
all you would have to do is pass a DOT
values over here and if you remember
from a dictionary video this uh a DOT
values gives us a list of or it it gives
us the essentially a list of the values
in our dictionary so when we pass this
to the iterator uh iter function and we
create an iterator out of it let's see
what happens over here now let's see
what is iter underscore a you can
actually see it's now the dict value
iterator at a particular memory location
so it's not the dick key as we saw
earlier it's a dict value iterator so
now that we have this dictionary value
iterator now let's print what are our
iterator elements and as you can see now
we are printing values and not um the
keys so this is how to this this is
basically two different ways of
iterating through a dictionary one
through keys and one through values in
this video we will be doing a small
exercise on if statements now in the
previous video you might have already
seen some of the basic concepts
surrounding if statements however in
this video just to drive home the point
or the purpose of an if statement we
will be doing a small exercise so let's
first revise some of the concepts of an
if statement so basic if statement can
be something like this we have a small
condition where we are checking if a
variable X is greater than 5 or not and
if it is greater than x we print a
statement over here so if this condition
is met we print this statement as we
move to the statement log now our
variable X has the value 5. now since X
is not greater than 5 what this will do
is it will check the statement and since
this will be false we skip the statement
block and move on to this statement so
as you can see here similarly we can do
something where we are checking multiple
statements we use the L if statement in
such a case so now in this block we are
checking in one of the one of the
conditions we're checking is if x is
equal to 5 or if x is greater than 5 and
then finally if both of these conditions
are not met we say else and we print
whatever or we do whatever is in this
particular statement block which is a
simple print statement so as you can see
X is indeed get is equal to 5 so this is
the block that will get executed as you
can see here now another example our
nestative statements so nested FL
statements are if else statements within
if else statements so let's look at an
example
as you can see here we have a string
stored in a variable called orange
quality and the string is fresh now we
have an integer or a float in this case
4.0 stored in Orange price now our first
statement is checking whether orange
quality the variable orange quality is
it equal to the string fresh now within
that if the statement or if this
condition is met we do another check
where we're checking what is the price
is it lesser than 5 if it is V to this
block else we execute this block finally
if our initial uh statement our initial
condition is not met we move on to this
else block now when I execute this what
should happen is I will enter this block
because this is true and finally I will
enter this block because this condition
is also true so I should have this
printed I will buy five dozens as you
can see here now let's move on to our
main exercise for this video so this was
all just the revision now we're gonna
use some or all of these Concepts in a
sample project or a sample exercise to
for your further practice so in this
exercise what we are going to do is
we're going to request the user to enter
a number between 1 and 20 and our our
code is going to check whether this
number entered is an even number or an
odd number so as you can see there are
two sets of checks that we're going to
do in this code the first check is going
to be whether the number that is entered
is between 1 and 20 or not and if it is
not we have to say it's an invalid
number but if it is entered between 1
and 20 we have to move on to the further
checks which is whether it is an even or
an odd number so let's see how we do
that so in this piece of code what we
start with is a print statement saying
please enter a number between 1 and 20
and then we add an input command this
input command will open a box where we
can enter whatever number that we want
to enter now we use this int keyword to
make sure that whatever we have entered
into the input box is stored as a int
data type in the enter num variable once
we do that our first if statement is
going to check whether the entered
number is greater than or equal to 1 or
lesser than equal to 20. sorry and less
than equal to 20. so both of these
conditions have to be met if this
condition is true then we have a valid
input and this statement is printed that
we have entered a valid number and then
we move on to the rest of the statement
block within this if statement which is
another set of if and else if statements
if our number is not between 120 we move
to this block and this block prints that
we have entered in invalid number now
once we have say entered a valid number
we move on to this block this is an if
else if LF statement block now what this
block is checking is whether the entered
number is an even number or not now as
we know an even number is divisible by 2
only the remainder 0 when divided by 2.
so this is what this check is doing if
this check is true that means our number
is even and we get printed that our
number is even the other other check or
the other uh if statement is checking
whether it's an odd number and that
means when we divide by 2 we should get
the remainder 1 as you can see here and
we get printed your number is odd so
let's execute this and see what happens
when we enter a number now it's asking
me to enter a number let's say I enter
17.
now that I've entered 17 as you can see
it's a valid number that I have entered
and the code is telling me that my
number is indeed odd let's look at some
other what if I entered something else
here let's say if I enter 16 now since
it's an even number as you can see 16 is
also a valid number as it's between 1
and 20 and my number is even and the
code checks for that let's see if I what
happens when I enter an invalid number
let's say 25 now when I enter 25 as you
can see it says I have entered invalid
number and in this case what has
happened is this condition itself is not
met and I have moved on to this
statement block so to give you a
breakdown as to how our code has
executed this let me show you an example
for the number say 9 when I enter nine
the first check that happens of course
is this check whether it's a valid
number or not and since it is between 1
and 20 we move on to this block and in
this block it's checking whether our
numbers divisible by 2 or not and since
it is not it will remain it will leave a
remainder 1 and we execute this block it
says our print our number is Odd as you
can see here in this video we are going
to learn about the topic called file
handling now file handling is basically
needed because so most of the times when
we are handling large and different
types of data in python or in general we
cannot store everything into a variable
and we will have to use files now there
are two types of files that we are going
to deal with they are binary and text
files so binary files are some of the
files that we most of the files that we
commonly encounter like document files
image Files video files Etc now all
binary files are encoded in a particular
format and they cannot be read by a
normal text editor and we would be
needing certain specific softwares for
specific files text files on the other
hand do not have any specific encoding
and they can be opened in the normal
text editor itself and they are like XML
CSS HTML files and so on now there are
four main operations that we can do 2 on
file in Python on files they are open
read write and close
um there are certain other operations as
well though like rename delete so some
of the most basic operation that we can
do is obviously creating and opening a
file and the syntax is as you can see
here where we store where we use the
open command and we give a file name and
we give a mode and we store that in a
particular variable now a mode is uh
basically telling python how to handle
this opening so we can have a read-only
mode which is done by this letter r a
write-only mode which is done by letter
W and for there are a bunch of other
modes such as read or write mode which
is done by R plus and we're going to see
them as we encounter them now the it is
important to note that what I just
mentioned is for text files if we are
going to do for binary files we are
going to do this file handling then we
would be using the letter B in front of
whatever we were using in the case of
text files so if we were doing a
read-only mode for opening a binary file
um we would be using RV and if we were
doing read and write mode a read or
write only mode for a binary file we
would be using RB plus so basically just
adding the b in the case of binary files
let's look at a basic example when we
want to open a particular file we are
going to open like in this example I'm
going to open some file called
firehandling.txt in a read and write
mode read or write mode and I'm going to
store it in fo so this is as simple as
it gets similarly if I wanted to do it
for the binary file since I'm using a
binary file I will use the letter B as
well in the mode and that's how you do
it here now let's look at different ways
in which we can read from a file and
there are three commands that we can use
we can use the read command followed by
optional number of characters we can use
the read line command followed by an
option number of characters and the read
lines command so this optional number of
characters denoted by n over here
um and basically telling us how many
characters we want to print so let's
look at a simple example of where I'm
going to print something called so I'm
going to take this and I'm going to do a
print on top of this so I have done
first I've opened it and I've stored it
in my file and then I'm going to do a uh
a method or a function called read and
I'm going to say like in this example
just read the whole thing so as you can
see my file that I have opened has all
of these lines this is like the whole
file basically but now what if I wanted
to open only the first five characters
of this file which is basically this
well in that case let's open this once
again now let's do the same read command
except we will give the character number
which is five as you can see it's only
printed five now let's do a print read
command and try to read the whole thing
again and you will notice something very
interesting now when I do the read
command you can see it's kind of picked
up from where we left off you know from
our previous command and that is the
nature of how python handles files so if
I wanted to again take the cursor back
in such an example I will have to open
this again and then I use this read
command once again to get back to where
I started from as you can see here now
another command that we can use is the
read line command so let's once again
open this over here and now we're going
to use the read line command and over
here so what readline command is going
to do is going to each time we use this
command it's going to go one by one and
read each particular line from this file
so in first case it will take artificial
intelligence then data science big data
and so on so as you can see if I execute
this it first takes artificial
intelligence now if I did this command
again
it will say data science next time if I
do it it should say big data as you can
see here okay so this is the read line
command now within the redline command
also we can enter characters and that
will tell us basically
um that we want these number of
characters from the next line so if I
want the first six characters of the
next line uh I will say six I've learned
to six here and it will give me the
first six characters of this particular
line which is the next line that is to
come as you can see here now another way
in which we can print whatever is there
in our file line by line is by using a
for Loop so again I'm going to open this
file I'm going to store it here now I'm
going to use a for Loop saying that well
for line in my file and what this does
is basically at each each iteration it's
going to take each line and store it in
this variable that we enter over here
which is called line itself and we're
going to print that at the end of the
loop what we'll have is all of the lines
have been printed one by one and another
thing that we can do right now is um
save we want to read a a particular line
see I wanted you to read the fifth line
of my file I can use this technique
where um I just say okay I'm gonna store
five in this variable called line number
and I have this another variable called
current line which I'm going to
initialize with one and I'm gonna any
I'm gonna what I'm going to do is I'm
going to do the same Loop where I'm
going to say four line in my line but
I'm gonna add a condition saying that
only if current line when it's equal to
line number am I going to print the line
and then I'm going to break out of this
whole thing and at the end of each Loop
I'm going to say current line is going
to be incremented by one until basically
these two variables are equal so when I
do this I get my result which is uh
machine learning which is the fifth line
of um my which is the fifth line of
whatever file I had now we're gonna move
on to the topic of image file handling
so we we saw how we handled and we we
saw certain operations around text files
and text files are obviously something
that we're going to use a lot but we are
also going to be using files such as
images a lot and let's look at certain
examples and certain use cases around
image file handling so my first step is
going to be importing a bunch of modules
and packages now the details of these
modules and these packages are not
important as of right now because they
will be covered in a future video but
just keep a note of some of these
packages such as um they say numpy and
image the image package so once I've
done this let's move on to my example so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
store certain file locations in two
variables so it's basically two strings
I've attached the uh this prefix R to
say that this is a read-only uh sort of
a prefix so the next topic that we're
going to be handling is image file
handling now we have already seen many
examples pertaining to text files so
text files are obviously something that
we're going to be using a lot but image
file handling is something very
important as well and we're going to see
certain operations that we can do around
image file handling so starting off I'm
going to import a bunch of
um packages and modules uh what these
packages exactly are and what these
modules exactly are are right now not of
that important of not are not that
important to you right now but it's
something that will be covered in a
future or in future videos uh it's
important to just keep note of what
these are such as numpy and image so
once I've done that what I'm going to
store is I'm going to store two
particular file locations into variables
location one and location two and I've
prefixed them with r just to say that
these are raw strings so once I've done
that I am going to use the image from
the image package I'm going to say open
and I'm going to say open from this
particular location in this particular
location and I'm going to store these
image images in im1 and im2 over here
very similar to a normal text file file
opening now once we've done this we can
access certain properties of this image
using say format which tells us the
format of the file it attributes the it
identifies the source of an image and if
the image will not read from a file it
is set to none we can also see the size
of the file using the size attribute and
we can see the mode which basically
defines the number and names of the
bands in the image and also contains a
pixel type and depth certain common
modes are like L for luminescence RGB
for true color images and CMYK for
pre-press images so let's look at them
so when I access this you can see my
first file is of jpeg of this size and
an RGB format image and my second image
is another jpeg slightly bigger image
and again RGB now we can also of course
display these images and to do that we
can use the PLT again PLT is the is
supposed to stand for matplotlib DOT Pi
plot it's a particular for a particular
package that again you don't need to
know the details of right now but this
is how we would do this so I'm going to
use a bunch of commands and methods such
as figure and subplot and then I am sure
so once I have done this as you can see
both of my images with this being im1
this being im2 have been produced on the
screen as you can see I can also use
display this display function followed
by the name of the file and this will
simply display my image as you can see
here now I can obviously save a
particular image using the save function
which is as simple as just doing this so
I'm going to save the image as I am
underscore save.jpg over here now if I
wanted to crop an image I can do that as
well so I initially I stored the
dimensions that I want cropped in the
form of a tuple as you can see here and
I'm going to pass that Tuple to the crop
function and I'm going to apply that on
top of im1 and I'm going to store that
to region once I've done that as you can
see so basically what I've done is I've
cropped this image based on whatever
I've passed here and I've stored it into
region and now if I wanted to see what
was um actually in that crop I can just
do the IM show function and I'm going to
pass the particular cropped image which
is denoted by region as you can see here
and you can see my cropped image is
basically a certain a left portion of
this whole image has been cropped out
and I have produced it over here now I
can also use the copy function using
it's a simple basically copy basically
you use the copy function and it copies
an image onto another variable that you
have assigned and then I use the IM show
function I am going to show you the
copied image which is basically the same
now we can do the transpose operation as
well so let's see some of the let's see
what we have done here so in this
transpose opposite operation so in this
uh basically I've done a bunch of
operations such as rotating by 90
degrees rotating by 180 rotating by 7
270 and finally once I've done with all
of these multiple operations I am going
to show you the final output which is
basically a certain transposed image
like this which is basically the result
of whatever I have done before this so
this is it for this video on file
handling uh I have shown you two
slightly more comprehensive examples on
text files and even certain examples on
image files however we can use file
handling in different libraries
pertaining to file handling for audio
files and even for like stuff like PDF
files and this is like this is just only
the beginning and I'm sure you will
encounter a lot of different use cases
different examples as you continue
learning Python Programming this video
is going to be the first of a part of a
series on object oriented programming so
to start off with let's try to
understand and get an introduction into
what is object oriented programming well
as the name suggests object oriented
programming is about creating objects an
object is a group of interrelated
variables and functions variables can be
referred to as the properties of the
object whereas the functions can be
referred to as the behavior of an object
so if we were to treat say for example a
car as an object its properties would be
its color its model its price and its
brand whereas Its Behavior or functions
for that matter would be like
accelerating gear change braking
similarly if I give you an example of a
dog as an object we could consider the
properties of the dog as its weight or
its name its breed its color whereas its
functions could be say barking playing
eating walking
Etc objects provide a better and a clear
structure for a program now let's move
on to what is a class and an instance
now a class is like a blueprint or a
template of certain functions and
entities whereas an instance is a
particular realization of a class
classes are used to create user-defined
data structures and Define certain
functions call methods within the class
whereas instances are realizations of
these classes and when we are speaking
of classes and instances classes don't
contain any real data they are just
merely templates instances on the other
hand contain real data to think of an
example of the difference between a
class and an instance think of a class
like a empty form or a questionnaire now
an empty form of a questionnaire does
not have any information but it does
have a template to it it tells you to
fill in certain information and based on
who is filling in the information that
information or the data on a particular
form will be different so an instance is
like a filled out form with its own a
unique set of information that is one
way of treating or understanding what is
a class and in instance now for our
first example on classes I will be
taking you through a class where I've
defined based on the circle object so
this class is going to define basically
information about your general circles
such as this radius and this area so
let's go through it now obviously to
define a class we need a keyword well in
the case of classes we use the class
keyword followed by a name for that
class so in this case my name is circle
now after the colon every every
information that is part of the class
has to be obviously indented as is
typical for python now you can see over
here A bunch of Dev keywords followed by
something that you might not be familiar
with and I will try to get you through
this so if you see here you have a def
keyword followed by init and this init
is prefixed by a double underscore and
it's suffix by double underscore and you
can see the same thing for HDR and repr
well this double underscore is called a
Dunder and any method these are of
course methods this is a method this is
a method this is a method this is a
method now any method that is prefixed
and suffixed by double underscores are
called Dunder methods these Dunder
methods are or can be thought of like
predefined or built-in methods for any
class that you define so these we have
like three Dunder methods over here and
we have one user defined method that we
will get to so this first method that
you see here is the init method or the
initialization method and this is
invoked or called whenever we create an
instance of this class Circle and what
we do here is basically we pass when we
create this instant Circle we are what
what happens is that we are we get an
option to pass an a value for a what
what is this uh keyword or variable
radius so if I pass so you will see me
later on creating an instance where um I
will be passing a value and that value
is basically stored as the radius and by
default the radius that will be passed
whenever we we create an instance for
this class is one the Str method is
basically used to return a descriptive
string for the the instance of class our
API is not something that you have to
bother with right now and now get area
is something that you should follow
because if you see here I have not used
any double underscores so this is a user
user defined method user defined methods
are some methods that we Define and
these are like tasks that we Define on
our own so in my user defined method
called get area I will be returning the
area of this circle based on the radius
that I passed to it now if you notice
here before every in every method I have
this self keyword before any other
attribute so like this has self this has
self even the get area herself now what
this means self is like an optional
keyword that is used to improve
readability of a program first of all
and it's also the function of the self
keyword is basic quickly telling python
that well any of the methods that we are
invoking in this class or the instance
of this class has to refer to attributes
and variables within that instance of
that class so if I'm going to use get
area function I am going to get values
and attribute values and variable values
based on only the current instance of
that particular class self is obviously
optional we don't really need it but
basically the first attribute of any
method is is basically the is basically
what the Mel is is the instance that the
method is invoked upon so if I say self
I am telling this particular function
that okay all the value that you're
going to get for performing whatever
task you want is going to be found in
that particular instance where you have
been invoked itself now don't worry if
all this is very confusing this might be
in the beginning but just try to
understand that this is something that
we do for good practice and you will
understand when when to yourself or when
not to yourself as you learn about
objective oriented programming so if you
see here my get AR function is supposed
to return the value radius times radius
self dot radius is basically telling um
whatever value I've passed for radius
for that particular instance you can
read this as radius times radius times
pi as well so obviously this is pi R
square which is the area of a particular
circle now let me show you an example
where I am going to perform some of
these functions so if you see this first
line I have created an instance of the
class Circle where I've passed 2.1 for
the radius of the circle so now the
value of the variable radius in this
particular instance is going to be
stored as 2.1 and this particular
instance is going to be stored in the
variable C1 now the print C1 function
invokes the Str self-defined or
predefined function now if you remember
Str was it's basically used to return a
particular string that describes like
what the class will do and this is
something that we Define on our own in
our examples line we say print C1 dot
get area so this is going to print the
value of the what what gets returned
when we invoke the method get area for
this particular instance C1 so obviously
in this particular instance our radius
is 2.1 so the get area function should
do pi times 2.1 square and the value is
as you can see here is some 13.85 so
that is the area that we got now if we
want to print a particular radius
um we just say print C1 dot radius so
this will print the value of what is
what is stored in radius for the
particular instance C1 now you might
notice me using a DOT whenever it comes
to defining a certain function or a
keyword well any time that we want to
invoke or use a method of a particular
class we have to use the dot keyword so
we use the instance name C1 dot followed
by whatever method that we want to use
so if we want to use the get area
function we say C1 dot get area if you
want to find out what is there in the
radius uh key radius variable of a
particular instance we say C1 dot radius
now before we move on let's talk about
some of the naming conventions class
names are initial capitalized so if our
class name is for example
um like for example if it's camel case
well each word that is part of this
class has its first letter capitalized
variables and Method names are in lower
class so if my class was called Circle
we say class circle with C being in
capital now moving on let's talk about
how we initialize or Define instance
variables now instance variables are
declared within the init method if you
remember from the earlier example of
circle init is it under method it's
followed and it's preceded by double
underscore as you can see here now if
you see in this particular case I have
again used the self keyword and as I
mentioned earlier the self keyword is
the first parameter of all member
methods and it this basically binds that
particular method to the particular
instance itself during invocation so
every time a new Circle object is
created the dot init function sets the
initial state of the object by assigning
the values of the object's properties so
if the init function basically
initializes each and every new instance
of um whatever of our class so we can
give in at any number of parameters but
the first parameter must always be a
variable called self now when a new
class instance is created the instance
is automatically passed to the self
parameter in init so that new attributes
can be defined on the object inside the
init method the self dot radius
basically means that we want the value
of radius based on the current instance
itself so as you can see radius defines
an instance variable radius and we're
going to use the particular instance and
its value of 4 radius in our variable
radius now our instance uh the inner I
mean the init function is not a
Constructor but it is an initializer to
create instance variables the init
function also will never return a value
and it is optional and can be omitted if
there are no instance variables now
let's move on to
um class variables so now as we
mentioned earlier all the attributes
that are created inside the init
function are instance specific
attributes and the instance attributes
are obviously specific to a particular
instance of the class for example all
dog objects now if we have a class
called dog then all dog objects have a
name and age but the values for the name
and age will vary depending on which dog
we are topic talking about or basically
which instance of the dog are we talking
about now class attributes are
attributes that have the same value for
all class instances and we define a
class attribute by assigning a valuable
value to a variable outside of the init
function so if you look at this example
over here we have created another class
called Circle and we have this initial
again where we have class specific
variable called radius which whose value
will change depending on whatever we
pass for that particular instance
however if you look before the initial
the init um init function or the
initializure function if you see here we
have another variable called shape
object which stores the string Circle
and this variable is going to be the
same and constant for every instance of
the class Circle and unlike the variable
radius we will not have different values
depending on a particular instance okay
now let's talk about instantiating an
object and let's see what happens when
we create two different instances of the
same class so as you can see here I've
created an instance C1 for class Circle
and I'm going to check its ID well if
you see the ID is something like this
now if I created another instance over
here called C2 and if I check its ID
well it's something different now so if
you see each instance basically has a
different memory location in our memory
um and each instance is this is how each
instance is different each time we
create it and they are created in
different memory locations finally
before we conclude this topic on um the
introduction into oop let's talk about
class methods instance methods and
static methods now class methods are
usually declared are actually declared
with the at class method operator or
decorator as you can see here it accepts
a class as its first argument so in this
case I am going to say I'm going to
define a class called my class I'm going
to use this at class method decorator to
say that whatever follows here is going
to be a class method and I've defined a
class method called hello that takes in
a um that uses again self and a name
attribute so what this does is it prints
um whatever I have passed to it in the
form of hello from self.name now what
this this is going to do is basically
it's going to give out a string saying
hello from name of us is is a column the
string name my class with a comma and
then whatever we passed initially which
was Rakesh next is then instance methods
and these are the most common types of
methods these are invoked by an instance
object so we have to create an instance
to actually use an instance method and
it takes the instance or the keyword
itself as its first argument so if I say
class dot class if I define a class my
class in this example and I'm going to
Define another function called hello as
you can see I have not used any
decorator like at class method so this
is going to be an instance method and
it's going to be invoked by the
particular instance so in this case it's
going to print hello from and it's going
to basically say the name of the class
again so I create my instance called my
instance one and it's an instance of
this class and then I'm going to invoke
the instance method by using this dot
dot operator in the instance name and
the result will be basically this string
over here as you can see now finally we
have another type of method called the
static method which is declared using
the add static method decorator so a
static method does not know its class
and is just attached to the class for
convenience it does not depend on the
state of the object and could be from a
separate function of a module a static
method can be invoked via a class object
or an instance object so if you look at
this example over here I have defined a
static method I've defined hello and it
basically says print hello world so it's
going to basically just print this so if
you can see here I created my instance
and I'm going to say dot hello it should
basically print print hello world that's
all in this video we will continue that
discussion on oop with inheritance
inheritance is used to describe the
relationship between two classes wherein
one class takes the methods and
properties from another class in this
relationship we have something called
the base class or the parent class from
which we will derive all our sum of the
properties and methods and the class
which actually derives these properties
and methods is known as the derived
class so you can think of the derived
class as a specialized version of a base
class to explain what inheritance is in
a basic way I will show you an example
where I'm creating a cylinder class
which is going to be a subclass of the
circle class that you might have
encountered in the earlier video on op
so what we're going to do is create a
cylinder class that is a subclass of
circle where we're going to get the
attributes radius and get area from
Circle class and we're going to add the
attribute's height and get volume to the
cylinder so right off the start you can
see we have our class Circle that you
might have seen in the earlier video so
this class Circle has the familiar
initialization where we are supposed to
enter a value for a radius that gets
stored in self dot radius now we also
have a description string which
basically is a Dunder method that
returns a string when we invoke the
print command on a particular instance
and we have the get area method as well
now if we move on to the cylinder class
you can see that I'm defining this class
with the class keyword with the Slender
name but you can see that I have added a
parenthesis and within it I have
mentioned the name of the superclass
that I want the cylinder class to be a
subclass of so this is how we actually
Define a subclass in the most basic way
you enter the name that you want and you
enter the name of the superclass that
you want the subclass to be if a
subclass of in parenthesis right after
the name now next if you move on to the
dunder initialization
um the initialization is very familiar
familiar except now we have another
attribute for height which has a deeper
default value of 1 just like the radius
so this basically means that we have an
option of entering two different
attributes for our cylinder instances
now if you see here there's a line which
says super dot in it now this is like um
this is a command which we use to invoke
the super classes initializer so anytime
we create an instance for cylinder we
also want an initialization for the
circle method as well as a part of our
cylinder instance next you can see that
much like how we stored self I mean the
radius attribute in self.radius we're
also storing the height attribute in
self dot height now even this uh
cylinder class has an Str method to
return a particular string if we use
this print function and finally we get
on to a more a new method that we have
defined only for the cylinder class
called get volume now if you see the get
volume it returns as basically the
volume of the cylinder that is being
described in the particular instance for
which we enter the height and the radius
so if you can see here what we've
basically added extra is an a height
attribute and another method called get
volume and the other parts of the circle
super class such as radius and get area
are also going to be a part of cylinder
even though you do not explicitly see
them anywhere here and we will see how
in uh in the form of an example that's
coming up so let me just execute these
classes now that that's done I'm going
to create an instance for cylinder I'm
going to store it in cy1 and I'm going
to pass 1.1 for the radius and 2.2 for
the height and once that is done let's
just print to invoke the HDR method and
as you can see the Str method basically
tells us the information that it's a
cylinder with radius 1.1 and height 2.2
so now let's print what is the value we
get when we use the get area method now
it's important to note get area was not
explicitly defined in the cylinder
subclass but it's a method that is a
part of the circle super class and we
can see that we can actually access
methods that are part of the superclass
simply by accessing any other method so
if you use the dot get area you can see
that we get a value for the area of the
cylinder so this basic this area is
basically the area of the circle I'm
going to do is create another instance
of cylinder but I'm not going to pass
anything for radius or height so
basically it's going to take the default
values for radiation height which was 1
and 1 respectively so once I print
um this is this statement is basically
going to print the Str method or
whatever we stored in the Str which is
basically the description of the object
followed by what is its radius and
height uh this method will give us the
area and this method will give us the
volume so once I execute this as you can
see here this is what we get and this is
what we expect as well so now in this
example what I'm going to show you is uh
now I'm going to go back and I am going
to create another instance for circle
now this is the super class of course
and I'm gonna give it and since the
superclass has only one option uh one
attribute that we can enter which is for
the radius so I pass 3.3 and I'm gonna
print what what happens when I just
print uh this instance it's going to
basically give us whatever was a part of
the HDR method uh after that I'm going
to print is instance which this is
basically a check on whether C1 is an
instance of this class Circle and X I'm
going to check if C1 is an instance of
its subclass cylinder now when I execute
this you can see that uh well this is
what we uh this is the SDR method that
gets printed but if you see here you can
see that it says C1 is indeed a an
instance of circle when it says 2 over
here but when we look at the next line
is C1 an instance of cylinder it says
false and this is obviously because
um a super class object is never an
instance of a subclass object whereas
whereas vice versa it would be true now
in the next part of this video what
we're going to do is look at the
different types of inheritances in
Python so there are basically five types
of inheritance in Python there is the
single inheritance there's multiple
inheritance multi-level inheritance
hierarchical hierarchical and Hybrid
inheritance so we'll go one by one and
see each of these examples starting off
we have the single inheritance this is
simply where we have one Base Class and
one derived class from That Base Class
so this is a simple single inheritance
and in this example you can see I have a
class called country where I have a
method that I've defined called show
country which is basically going to say
print this is India it's basically going
to go print this every time we invoke
this show country method then we have a
class called state which derives from
the super classical country where we
have a method called show state which is
going to say print this state every time
so you can see I created an instance of
the class State and I'm through that
instance I can access the super class
and the subclass methods over here next
we have the multi-level uh sorry
multiple inheritance and this is when a
derived class contains more than one
Base Class so let's look at an example
to understand this so if you can see
here I have a class called student with
the two methods defined called method
one and Method two in method one we can
pass two attributes Sno or I think is
this this is supposed to be like an ID I
guess like SN number and we have S name
so this is basically two attributes we
can pass that are probably descriptors
for a student and in the next method you
have basically two print statements
which Says student number and then they
will print the student number and it
will also print the student name next we
have a class called marks this is also
um so these these two classes are
basically what our super classes are
going to be and we're going to derive a
third class from these two so this
second class is a class called marks and
we have two methods again one method is
called set marks which has the option of
putting in two attributes M1 and M2 both
are representative of the two marks and
we store them in self.mark 1 self.mark
2. the second method is put marks which
is going to print the marks namely mark
one and then it's going to tell us how
much marks are there in the first
subject for example and another print
statement doing the same thing for the
second subject number two finally we
have a third class called a result which
derives from two classes marks and
student as you can see here in my
parenthesis I've passed in marks and
student both are super classes and our
class result is going to derive from
both of them this is an example of
multiple inheritance and within this
class result I have two methods specific
to this derived class called calc
wherein I'm going to basically calculate
the two the total marks of um uh the the
total marks which is basically the
addition of Mark 1 plus Mark II and I'm
then I'm going to have any other method
called put total which is going to print
me what is the total so if you can see
here I have created an instance of this
derived class called result I am storing
it in R then I'm going to access method
one which is obviously a method from the
first Super class called student and I'm
going to store okay so this is name is I
guess lucky and he has 60 marks secondly
then I'm going to do our set marks which
is the method from the second Super
class which is going to set the marks uh
respectively so you have lucky student
and his ID is 60 and he has got 50 and
60 marks respectively in say the first
two subjects and finally I'm going to
access the derived class method called
calc so this is going to do the sum
finally I'm going to also do are method
2 which is I'm going to print our
student number and student name next
we're going to have put marks which is
going to tell us the what are the
individual marks for Mark 1 and Mark 2
and then finally we're going to print
the total marks with the put total so
once I execute this you can see here it
says student number 60 student name
lucky Marks One is 50 as I had written
here marks 260 as I passed here and then
total is 110 which is basically 50 plus
60. our next type of inheritance is
called multi-level inheritance now
multi-level inheritance can be assumed
as where you take a super class let's
call it a and you derive a Class B from
that class A now what if we derived a
Class C from B and we kept doing this so
until say a Class E now each of these
steps is in its own an inheritance but
this whole relationship can be described
as a multi-level inheritance so let's
take an example again so after this this
time I've defined a class called student
where I have defined two methods called
set stud and put stud or you can call it
set student and put student in my first
method I have two options of adding two
attributes again this is the story
number this is the student name in my
second method I am going to print what
is the student number and what is the
student name finally uh so sorry next we
have another class called marks which
derives from the first class called
student this has two methods called set
marks where I'm going to again get the
option of adding two integers for M1 and
M2 which is going to represent Mark 1
and Mark 2 and finally I have put marks
the method which is going to print Mark
1 and Mark II finally I have another
class called result and this if you see
this derives from marks now if you see
this relationship you'll notice result
derives from marks whereas marks itself
derives from student and this is an
example of multi-level hierarchy and
even as a part of this third class we
have its own methods called file can put
total calc will calculate the total as
we had seen earlier and put total will
basically print the total and we're
going to do a very similar operation
we're going to create an instance of
this third class uh result and store it
in R then we're going to do basically
we're going to set the student details
uh his uh student number and his name
we're going to give him his marks 50 and
60. we're going to calculate what are
the total we're going to say okay now
put the details of what is the student's
number and name we're going to also
store enter I mean display his marks my
Quantum Mark 2 and finally we're going
to display the total marks so let's
execute this and if you see it's
basically the similar operation that we
did earlier but the only difference is
in the earlier example I was uh our
third class result was derived from Marx
and student together so this was an
example of multiple inheritance whereas
in this example the result class derives
from marks and marks itself derives from
students so this is an example of
multi-level inheritance finally we have
have sorry not finally penultimately we
have as our fourth example of
inheritance called a hierarchical
inheritance apart in my Ms presentation
it's hierarchical inheritance so in this
case a base class basically will contain
more than one derived class so let's
look at an example of what we mean here
so I have a class called one where I
have defined a method called display
where what I'm going to do is I'm going
to store set.x is equal to 1000 and self
dot Y is equal to 2000 then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to print a
statement saying this is the method in
class 1 and I'm going to say after that
I'm going to print another statement
saying value of x is a self.x which is
going to be 1000 uh then I'm going to
have another print statement saying
value of y is self dot Y which is going
to be 2000. finally uh I mean next I
have another class called 2 this this is
going to derive from class 1 as you can
see here and in this class 2 I have
defined another method called add and in
this method add what I'm going to do is
I'm going to first print a statement
saying this is the method in class 2 and
then I'm going to actually print the
result of X Plus Y which is 1000 plus
2000 finally I have another class called
3 and this is also deriving from one so
if you notice we have one parent class
called one and from this one uh parent
class we're going to derive two
different subclasses called 2 and 3. so
this is an example of hierarchical
inheritance now in this class 3 what
I've done is I've defined a
multiplication method what I'm going to
do is print first of all I'm going to
print this when I invoke this method
that this is the method in class three
finally I'm going to say uh I'm going to
print the result of x times Y which is
1000 times 2000 so if you see I am going
to create an instance of 2 and I'm going
to create an instance of 3 and I'm going
to store them in T1 and D2 now since uh
T2 I mean T1 is an instance of 2 so I
can access its methods add and I can
access this methods display so I'm going
to use t1.display and even into uh T2 I
mean since it's a class uh it's an
instance of class three and this also
derives from class one I can also access
its method display but now I cannot
access add but I can access multiply so
if you see here I access add through T1
instance since add is a part of Class 2
whereas multiply is a uh is is a method
in class three so I access it in its
respective instance which is D2 so if
you see here now once I execute this
what you will get is basically
um the results so first of all it will
basically display the method from class
1 which is the display method it will
display the values of X and Y and since
I've done this twice from two different
instances it will basically show a
repetition over here finally I've done
the addition and since this is a method
in class 2 it is going to say as much
that is the method in class 2 and then
it's going to say X Plus Y is 3000 and
now multiply is a method in the third
class so it's going to say this is a
method in class 3 and it's going to tell
me what is the multiplication result
finally we have what is called Hybrid
inheritance and this is a combination of
multiple plus multi level inheritance
that you saw earlier so let's again
understand this through this example so
we have a class called student where we
have a method called set student again
two attributes we can pass here for
student number and student name next we
have a another method part of the class
student called put student so this will
print us the student number and student
name next we have a class called Marx
and this marks inherits from student so
we have a method in class marks called
set marks where we can pass two
attributes for Mach 1 and Mark 2
respectively and as we saw our seen
earlier we also have a put marks which
will display the marks for Marks One and
marks two we have a class called
practical this practical is basically a
another Super class if you see here
since this does not derive from anything
it is super class on its own and what it
does is it it has two methods get
practical and we can pass an attribute
for P1 here and we store that in self.p1
and then we have an attribute for foot
practical which will print us the
Practical marks whatever we passed for
this attribute in P1 finally
we have a class called result now in
this result we have we are going to
derive from marks and practical but if
you notice here marks itself is a
subclass of student so this is an
example of multi-level inheritance
whereas since result derived from marks
and practical both it is also an example
of multiple inheritance so if you see
notice here this is an example of
multiple and multiple level inheritance
which is basically what we call Hybrid
inheritance and as we had seen earlier
this result class will have a calc
method to do a total of the marks in
this case Mach 1 plus Mark 2 plus the
Practical Mark P1 and we have a put
total method which is basically going to
print us the total so now we're going to
create an instance of this result and
through this instance of result we're
going to first invoke the parent class
method called set student which is the
the second level parent basically the
student the student class set student
method so we're going to set student
here in going to say 60 is a student ID
and name is Ash then we have set marks
which is again the the second level
parent which is a student class where we
set the marks finally we access this get
practical now if you notice get
practical is part of the Practical uh
the student details then we put the
individual marks then we put the
Practical marks and finally we enter
what is the total so let's execute this
and if you notice you will see here
student number 60 student name and all
the basically whatever details we wanted
um is shown over here in this video we
will continue our discussion on object
oriented programming with the topic of
polymorphism now the term polymorphism
in oop refers the ability of an object
to adapt the code to the type of data it
is processing polymorphism is one of the
key concepts of python and it is also a
built-in feature of python an example to
get us started on polymorphism would be
how we use the plus operator we use the
plus operator not only for arithmetic
additions but we also use the plus
operator for Stuff Flex string
concatenations or joining two lists
together this example where we are able
to use the plus operator for different
different operations is an example of
polymorphism to show you what I mean I
have basically done a simple addition
operation here where I'm adding two
variables number one and number two when
I do it on integers it basically adds
one plus two now when I use it on two
strings str1 and str2 which contains
Python and programming to separate uh
strings and when I use the plus operator
on these you can see what it does here
it forms one string containing both of
these individual strings so this is
basically the plus operator showing
polymorphism and is one of the simplest
occurrences and yet most common
occurrences of polymorphism in Python
another example of polymorphism would be
through the lens function the lens
function in Python is something that we
use a lot and over multiple data types
depending on the data type that we use
the length function for we get a
different value or a different sort of
information from the lens function now
if you see here from this diagram when
we use the length function on a string
it gives us the length of the string
when we use the length function on a
list it gives us the number of items
whereas if we use the length function on
a dictionary it gives us the number of
keys so this is well another example of
how we have polymorphism in a function
now what we are going to do is look at
the different techniques through which
we can enable polymorphisms in our code
our first example that we are going to
look at is through method overloading
now method overloading in its
traditional sense where we can have a
method with the same name more than one
method with the same name in the same
class is not exactly possible in Python
so if we have multiple methods with the
same name in a class in Python which may
differ in in types and number of
arguments are not allowed and not
supported in Python in fact if we did
something like this where we created a
method with a different uh with
different say types and number and I
arguments but having the same name in
the same class then what python will do
is it will only recognize the the last
defined method and it will not recognize
any of the earlier methods with the same
name but we can simulate polymorphism
through method over overloading by using
default arguments in a method now for
example what I'm going to show you here
is an example where I have a method
called sum Now by default it has three
attributes that you can pass through
this method a does not have a default
value B does not have a default value
but if you notice C has a default value
0. so this is a simple example where I'm
going to show you that the sum method is
going to be used in two different cases
in one case we are going to Simply add
two-way digits I mean two numbers and in
another case we're going to use the sum
method to add three different numbers so
we have this class overload demo within
it a method sum and I have three
attributes A and B are uh I have uh are
supposed to be given by the user since
they don't have a since they do not have
any default values whereas C has a
default value of zero so if you see here
in my first case I have uh I first of
all created a an instance called over uh
and an instance called OD for the class
overload demo and uh I have uh what I'm
going to do is I'm going to store the
value of the sum of 7 and 8 in the
variable sum now if you see here I have
not passed a third argument so what this
method is going to do is it's going to
take the value of C as 0 by default so
it's basically going to do uh 7 plus 8
and it's going to give us the sum for 7
plus 8 and in the next instance I'm
going to give three ad arguments seven
eight and nine so now c will be replaced
by 9 instead of 0 and then I'm going to
get the sum of 7 8 and 9. so in this
this is a not a very used not a very
commonly used thing but it's basically a
method just to show you that we can
actually simulate method overloading in
Python by using default documents so
I've basically shown you how the same
how the same method sum has been used to
do the addition of two digits and then
in in another instance is doing the
addition of three digits it might look
very similar but you'll basically notice
that by having this third attribute C I
have a default value of 0 I have induced
some form of polymorphism through method
overloading now the next way that we can
induce polymorphism is through
inheritance which is called method
overriding as well now method overriding
gives us the ability to change the way
or the change the implementation of a
method in a child class which is defined
already in one of its super classes now
if there is a method in a super class
the method having the same name and same
number of arguments in a child class uh
then the child class method is going to
override the method in the parent class
so what we do is when a method is called
with the parent class object the method
of the parent class will be executed
whereas if we call the method using the
child class object the method of the
chart class will be executed executed
and it will override the method in the
parent class so the appropriate
overrated method is called uh is called
based on the object type which is an
example of polymorphism so let's look at
an example to understand this so we have
a class called person and we have
defined uh what we're going to define
the initializer is two attributes which
we have to pass called name and age and
we're going to store them in cell plot
name and self.h now we have a user
defined method called display data where
we are going to print if this display
data has been called through the parent
called person
um if it's going to be called through
the parent class object then we're going
to print in parent class display method
and when we're going to print the name
and age that we have entered now we have
another class called employee which is
going to be a derived class 1 person so
it's going to um so it's also going to
have an initializer and this Constructor
will basically what what this
initializer will have is it will have a
Constructor for the superclass where
we're going to do this the same
initialization that we do in the
superclass but we're also going to store
another attribute called ID in self dot
employee ID and if you see here we also
have another method called display data
which is the same name method from
person but now if you see in display
data I have every I have all the same
almost the same information I'm going to
print the name I'm going to print the
age but if you see the first statement
I'm going to say if I'm going to call
this method from the employee object
then I'm going to say in child class
display data method instead of in parent
class display data method to say that
basically I'm invoking this method from
the child class object and I'm also
going to print on top of the whatever
I'm printing before I'm also going to
print the employee ID so if you see here
I have created an object called person
which is an object of the class person
with the information of name John and
age 40 and then I'm going to display
this now next next I'm going to create
an object called amp which is the child
class employee object which is going to
now have the same information of John
for the name and age 40 but now is going
to have an employee ID and then I'm
going to store this uh in amp and I'm
going to display the data for this child
class object and we will see the
difference in how the display data is
differing from the earlier earlier case
so when I execute this you see the in
the first case it says in parent class
display data method so this display data
has been called through the parent class
object and I'm only going to show the
information of name and age whereas when
I invoke this method from the employee
class object it's going to say it's
going to specifically say that it's a in
child class display method and then I'm
going to say the name is and also the
employee ID over here so this is the
difference between how display data has
been used in its parent and its child
class and this is basically the example
of method overriding now our next
example of polymorphism is going to be
through operator overload loading and
operator overloading is the ability to
overload the operator to provide extra
functionality in additional to its real
or core operation and operator
overloading is also an example of
polymorphism as the same operator can
perform different actions the earlier
example of where we use the plus
operator for different operations is an
example of operator overloading
polymorphism now when um when when this
operator overloading required well
anytime you want an operator to perform
a different function for you in your
custom objects you would basically do
operator overloading now an example of
this would be what I'm going to show you
below so if you see this class called
point it has an initializer where I'm
going to store two attributes X and Y in
sub dot X and Y and subtle in sub.x and
self dot y now I'm going to create one
object called P1 where I'm going to
create point one and two so you can
think of this object as basically like a
coordinate x coordinate one y coordinate
two this is one point and another Point
called x coordinate 3 x 1 and 4 I'm
going to call that P2 now I want to
print P1 plus P2 all right now if I try
to execute this you will notice an error
it says unsupported operand types for
plus point and point this basically
means that plus does not know what to do
when it's given an object of this type
it has no idea what to do whereas what
we wanted to do is add the the x
coordinate from this point and the x
coordinate from this point so we wanted
to do a 1 plus 3 and we also wanted to
do this y coordinate plus this y
coordinate or 2 plus 4 and then we want
to print basically like something like 4
comma 6 or the addition of the two
points or the the vector addition of
these two points so this is what we want
this plus operator to do but the python
does not have any inbuilt feature for
the plus operator and we are going to
have to basically do some operator
overloading to create a polymorphism on
this so let's see how we can do that so
to do that first of all we have to
understand that all operators in Python
have internally defined methods to
provide some functionality for these
operators the operator or the special
method to provide functionality for the
plus operator in Python is the add
method and whenever the plus operator is
used we are basically internally
internally invoking the add method so
these these sort of internal methods
that provide functionality for The
Operators are part of a big a bigger
class of methods known as magic methods
and these magic methods are
automatically invoked whenever it's
corresponding operators are used so we
want to change the uh the operation for
the plus operator in this example we are
going to have to use the the add method
in this case and since it's a magic
method magic methods are also are
basically what we saw earlier in the in
the form of Dunder methods so magic
methods are going to be invoked using a
double underscore a prefixed and suffix
to it so similarly to how we defined an
init of an init method or an HDR method
we are going to also invoke the add
method using the same double underscore
before and after its name so now let's
see how we're going to do this so if you
see this class I have now my class point
and I have the same initializer when I'm
going to store X and Y now I am going to
Define on uh these this add magic method
I am going to override the the normal
functionality of plus and I'm going to
give it a very specific function where
I'm going to say
um for two two different objects you're
going to add its uh the first part the
first part or its so called x coordinate
with the other x coordinate and if the y
coordinate with the other y coordinate
and you need to return return this to me
in the form of a similar object so now
when I pass 1 and 2 and 3 and 4 it
should return me four and six as you can
see here I have basically done what I
wanted to do by operator overloading I
have changed or I have overloaded this
add this plus operator using this add
magic method and I have created a new
functionality for this add function for
these two points 1 and 2 three and four
now I'm able to add 1 comma 2 3 comma 4
in the way I want it to so now that you
saw how we did our operator overloading
I'm just going to show you a list of
similar magic methods for different
operators that we are familiar with so
the plus operator already we've seen has
the add method then we have the minus
operator with the sub method and
similarly we have for all of these
operations such as multiplication
division we have its respective magic
methods these magic methods are again
prefixed with two underscores and suffix
with two underscores and they are
basically they're also called uh Dundas
in Python so this is how we would do
operator overloading in Python for
whatever operator we want similarly we
can do this for like comparison
operators and for unary operators as
well so look at this example now where
I'm going to overload the multiplication
or the Asterix operator so I've again
defined a point I mean a class called
point I'm going to Define an initializer
but I'm going to store some attribute X
in cell dot X now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to over overload the
multiplication operator where I'm going
to basically allow the this Asterix
operator to multiply two objects from
like for example 12 and 5. usually I can
just do a normal 12 times 5 but in this
case my object is slightly different my
12 is being passed through an object of
a class called point and five as well in
another uh instance of the same class
now when I want to multiply these class
instances like the the multiplication
operator does not perceive these class
instances to be integer so by default it
would not be able to multiply what we
want to multiply but when we Define or
we overload the multiplication operator
within our class it's now able to
understand what to do um using the
attributes of these classes in its
respective class instances so it's able
to say okay so I want this attribute
from this particular instance V1 12 and
I'm going to multiply it with the
attribute 5 from instance P2 whenever I
say P1 times P2 over P1 as 6 P2 so when
I executed it will give me 12 times 5.
similarly I can also do this for the
greater than operator over here so I
have a class called person where I'm
going to Define an initializer where I'm
going to pass name and salary and store
them in sub.name server.s salary the GT
method is basically the greater than
method magic method and it's going to uh
we're going to use this to overload the
greater than operator and now again
using this greater than operator I am
able to basically say object 1 greater
than object 2 and I'm basically able to
check through this and a if object 1 is
greater than object 2 it will basically
tell us if it is true or false or
basically whatever like we want to know
so this is the the print statement will
check for object one dot name and it
will say earns more than objective.name
if in case object 1 is indeed greater
than objective so when I execute this
you can see here my first information
says John has is earning 4500 some units
Natasha is earning 6000 of some units so
it will say John earns more than Natasha
well it's false because object 1 is not
greater than object two so since 4500 is
not actually greater than 6000 and this
is the check that I'm doing by
overloading the GT operator over here
where I'm so when I'm returning the
Boolean value of uh what is greater self
does salary or other dot salary self
being the first uh object in any
comparison so in the if I'm basically
any comparison if I'm doing say if I'm
doing 5 greater than 5 greater than 6 so
what the GT will do is this will be the
self object and this will be the other
object so this is what I'm doing over
here I'm checking self dot salary with
other dot salary in in the form of these
objects and it's basically the same same
way that we we are able to do five plus
five through these class instance
objects that you saw earlier or 12 times
5 that you saw earlier so this is all
examples of operator overloading in
Python in this video we will be taking a
brief introduction into what is a
function so a function in Python is a
group of related statements that
performs a specific task or tasks now
functions help break our program into
smaller and modular pieces of code and
it's very good and very convenient to
use functions to make our code organized
and manageable especially as our overall
program grows larger it also helps us to
avoid repetition and makes the code
reusable so let's look at the basic way
of defining a function so this is a
basic function that I am calling Fun
underscore name all right now the rest
of the function or whatever the task is
going to be performed by this function
will be written over here within indent
of course as a standard when it comes to
python so I'm going to Define this one
something in triple uh double quotes so
don't worry about what this is right now
this is a doc string don't worry about
what this means and I'll explain it to
you just in a short bit all right now
now the rest of the statement the rest
of it uh will obviously be what this
function will do let's include a simple
print statement all right let's uh it's
done here let's call this so of course
now once you've defined the state
function to call the function you just
have to use its name like this this is
how you call a function so as you can
see when I call this function it should
print this statement hello now let's go
let's uh look at some of the uh like
what happened over here so we've used
the keyword def to define a function we
give it a unique name which makes it uh
which with which we uniquely identify
this function
um and also once we've done this we
um we can give it we can give this
function a particular header it's called
a doc string so what this doc string is
basically something that we include in
triple quotes over here just after the
div the dev keyword and this is like a
brief we can use this to give a brief
give brief information into whatever
function is doing so we can say this is
uh this function performs addition
performs
um subtraction or whatever like some
basic information as to what our
function does so we can use a doc string
for that of course this is an optional
thing this does not have to be we don't
have to include this as well all right
but for the sake of this let's just keep
it here after that of course rest to the
function uh will contain whatever tasks
we want to do with it and that will be
indented
um finally we can also include a return
keyword and what the return keyword does
is at any point you find the return
keyword in a function you immediately
leave the function you go back to where
this function was called okay so now
let's see
um now there's also one more important
component of defining a function and
that's parameter now if you've noticed
over here within these parentheses I did
not include anything this is like an
empty path this is opening and closing
what if I said a if I included some A
and B over here so what this means is
whenever I call this function I need to
pass two parameters A and B these can be
like strings or numbers or whatever but
now it becomes almost mandatory that I
pass these two things for my function to
uh to work so let's define a function
where I'm going to add a and b so
instead of this print statement let's do
this I create a variable C and in that
I'm storing a plus b all right and then
I return C so you can use a return and
you can you you can return certain like
variables along with the return
statement so I'm saying not only return
from this function but also given output
a return in output called C which is the
addition of A and B now how do we use
this well now instead of just calling
the function like this I'm going to add
but I'm going to include parameters so
I'm saying Pass 2 and 3 to function name
where 2 will take the place of a and 3
will take the place of B all right what
will happen now is addition will take
place and we will get return the result
so let's see what happens now as you can
see two plus three and I already got the
data the addition of two plus three and
it returned me five so yeah this was
like a basic uh usage of a function and
parameters so of course uh we can if you
want to know like what a what the doc
string of a particular function does or
says uh you can use this uh particular
you can use this like statement so let's
say for so uh it's very important to
like just keep a note in your uh while
you're going through this or while
you're learning that uh whenever we use
some sort of a function which has double
underscore right this is like a built-in
a built-in command provided by python
um within the python Library itself so
these are like built-in commands to
check certain details so I want to check
what is a doc string and this is how I
do it so let's do print let's print what
is the doc string over here this is a
doc string so this is basically what I
wrote over here I can change this to
this like this does Edition for example
all right now this will say this does
addition when I execute this line so the
this is the way to check what is a dog
string anyways so now that you have seen
a basic basic function two basic
functions that I defined for you and how
we use them what a parameter is let's
look at another concept that we call
scope and lifetime of variables so scope
of variable is the portion of the
program where the variable is recognized
all right now a parameter and a variable
that are defined inside a function are
not visible from outside the function
this is a very key thing so if we Define
something within the function we can
only use it within this function and we
cannot like we cannot use it once the
function has already been executed so as
to speak
um these variables and these parameters
uh have what we call as local scope
since they are only
recognized within a particular function
now the lifetime of a variable is the
period throughout which the variable
exists in the memory itself and it's
very important to note that life time of
variables that are defined inside a
function are as long as the function
executes once we return from a function
whatever we have defined within it are
destroyed so when we use a function it
will not remember the values of a
variable from a previous iteration of a
function call so let's try to understand
this example or this concept using
certain examples so out here I have
defined a function where I am going to
create a variable my underscore VAR my
variable and I am going to store the
value 10 in this and then I'm going to
print so whenever I call this function I
will always create this variable I will
store 10 and I will print the value of
this all right now what I am going to do
is I'm not only going to create this my
VAR inside this function I'm also going
to create a variable outside so you see
there now you might be confused as to
okay how is the behavior going to be
because outside the function session I
have created my wire with a value 20 but
inside the function I will always Define
my virus 10 okay now I'm going to print
so my first what I'm going to first do
is I'm going to execute this function
that I created initially where I store
the value of 10 in my bar and then I'm
going to pray and print the value of my
wire that was present outside the
function let's see what happens you can
see two different things happening so
when I execute this function it prints
the value inside the function as 10 but
when I print the next line which says
um okay now get the value of my word it
actually prints a value of 20 and this
is a very key concept because What's
Happening Here is when I initially call
my function within this function it
creates a variable called my wire and it
prints the value as 10 and the moment my
function has been executed it destroys
this variable and the variable which
contain the value 10 is of course now
destroyed and all we have is the my wire
that contains 20 from the outside and
when we print that we get the suspective
value as 20 so you can also think of it
like this the my wire that is present
inside this function is different to the
myvar that we create outside so the
scope of the my wire within this
function is local only to this function
and once the function is executed that
variable is destroyed all right now
let's look at a another case or the
other side of this case where um say
we're dealing with variables that have a
global scope how do we deal with them so
let's create a variable called myware
okay and I say I stored 100 in this all
right now if I Define a function I've
stored my where let's say I Define a
function define underscore say again
same name where what I'm going to do in
this is I am going to print the value of
whatever is there in my where Okay so
let's do print
um value of variable is value stored in
variable is okay let's uh my
so let's see what happens when we do
this let's call this function on
underscore name see what happens here so
as you can see the value I store the
value 100 in Y where and I've called it
inside the function and this is because
since I've defined it outside I can use
it inside as well now what if I try to
change the value of this variable inside
the function though so let's see
if I did this and now if I try to print
let's see do is this Allowed no it's not
allowed in fact I get an error it says
local variable my where reference before
assignment
um and without going too much into
detail what it's saying is that the
variable inside over here is still local
to this function and I have not defined
this my where as a global variable so I
cannot make changes to it within this
function right now and uh to change that
I can use the global keyword what if I
did Global over here so if I did Global
and now if I said okay Global myware and
I declare this variable as a global
variable now if I do this now if I do
the same incrementation now let's see
what happens when I'm trying to do this
you see I get the value 101 it's exactly
what I wanted and that is because I've
defined my variable to be a global
variable within this function so I can
in fact make changes to it within this
function so this is how we use the
global keyword and Global variable uh
also just to make a quick note there are
three types of functions uh the three
types of categories in which we can
divide functions first one being
built-in functions these are the ones
that are built into the standard library
of python the other is user defined
function that is the ones which we
Define ourselves and the third type is
called Anonymous functions they're also
known as Lambda functions and this is
something that we're going to cover in a
separate video now let's talk about the
arguments that we pass in Python so
there are four types of arguments that
python user-defined functions can take
first one being default other one is
required then there is keyword and then
there is variable number of arguments so
the default argument is when say
um if I Define the function where
underscore sorry fun underscore name and
I'm saying a comma B right but what if
the user has not like save I I want a
default value of a and b each time when
I use this function so in the case where
if say I don't pass a value for A and B
like this will always be used so I can
just say a is equal to 2 by default and
B is equal to 3 by default and then
within this function I will say C is
equal to a plus b and then return C so I
do this and if I say found underscore
name and in case I don't pass any
arguments here let's see what happens by
default I get the answer 5 because by
default a is 2 and B is 3 but this is
not fixed and I can always change this
by passing my own values here 5 and 6
and in this case I should get 11 as you
can see here now the next type is
required arguments and when we are
defining a required argument we just
simply do not use the equal to sign for
the parameters over here and this
basically it makes it so that now
anytime we call this function we have to
pass something over here so now if I try
to pass like this I won't get a oops
Yeah I won't get a default value then
that's because
um that's because well there is no
default value and it needs an AM B so I
have to pass it a 3 and say 4. now it
should give me 7 as you can see the next
type of argument that we'll be talking
about are the variable number of
arguments so let's look at an example
here so what I'm doing in this
particular example is I'm defining a
function called my sum where I'm passing
some parameter called my integers and
I'm doing something out here and what
this does is
um it will take the values of a
particular like collection of objects
and that's called my integers and each
value I'm going to keep adding it to
each other and I'm going to result a
particular sum I'm just going to resolve
the sum of whatever is there so in this
case what happens is I'm creating a list
one two and three which contains one two
and three and then I'm going to print
the summation of whatever is there so it
should give me 6. now the problem in
this case is that each time when I'm
going to perform this function I have to
create a separate list where I'm going
to store these objects but what if I
didn't know I do not know like what
exactly I'm going to pass here what if I
don't know if it's going to be a list of
objects or like what is it going to be
exactly well in that case I can use a
variable variable key variable number of
arguments so it's like a variable
keyword argument so what we use here is
um a specific way of passing um keywords
and we do it like this so I say Define
my under underscore name and I use an
asterisks now I give it any name this
can be args this can be integers it
doesn't really matter what this is but
it's just this is the key the asterisks
here and this tells us that whatever we
pass here is now if we're supposed to
create an iterable out of this and then
we can perform whatever tasks we want so
let's just uh since I've already created
one here let's see how I'm going to use
it in this case so as you can see I'm
doing uh I'm creating a particular
variable argument function over here and
I'm doing the same task I'm just going
to keep performing at uh I'm going to
add whatever I pass over here but now
when I'm calling this function I don't
need to create a separate list as I did
over here I'm just passing all the
numbers that I want to in the form of
like it's pretty much like a tuple so
I'm just passing these numbers here and
what this function is going to do is
it's going to create an iterable out of
this and then if we're going to iterate
over it as you can see that's happening
over here and I can keep uh I don't need
I I can just keep like uh so since I've
done it for one two three and seven the
summation should be 13 in this case I
can add another number here just
explicitly just like this and you can
see the value will change and that's
because this is a variable uh this is a
variable argument uh method of creating
a function now the fourth type of
function arguments is the variable
keyword uh argument so let's look at
what is the keyword argument now so I
have defined a function here called the
concatenate function and let's see what
I'm going to do with this so in this I
have passed a keyword argument I've said
that okay this is going to be a keyword
argument function and what I'm going to
do in this is I'm going to create a
blank string and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to add or I'm going to
concatenate certain strings that I'm
going to pass to this function so I in
this example I have passed Python and is
and Google and an exclamation mark all
separate strings and what I'm going to
do in this function is I'm going to join
them together
um and I'm going to create one whole
string out of it let's see what's the
result python is cool so this is so of
course like uh if I had to add some
something else like python is a cool and
say I just wanted to say hello and say
one more string I can add I can add it
just like this I don't have to like
Define a fixed number of arguments I can
pass any number of arguments I want and
this works exactly the same as variable
in the only differences instead of
positional arguments we're using keyword
arguments over here hello by like this
it doesn't really make sense but just to
show you as you can see so this is how
we use keyword arguments in this video
we will be learning about X exceptions
exceptions are errors that are raised
during the execution of a program when
an error occurs python generates this
exception that can be handled which
avoids our program from caching python
has many built-in exceptions uh however
we can create many uh user-defined
errors or exceptions as well to catch
whatever errors we're looking for in our
program so when an error occurs python
interpreter raises an exception and
stops the current process and it passes
it to a calling process until the
exception is handled and if this is not
handled the program will crash some of
the built-in exceptions are like I O
error in the case when a file cannot be
opened or import error python cannot
find the particular module being
imported and there are so many similar
uh so many exceptions that are built in
Python for the appropriate cases now
before we move on and see how we raise
these exceptions let's look at the
difference between an exception and a
syntax error so for that I will be using
an example where I will be dividing
something by the number zero of course
this is not possible so let's see how
python handles this particular problem
well it traces something that it raises
what we call a zero division error and
this is an exception that is built in in
Python whenever we try to divide
something by zero now let's look at the
difference between this exception and a
syntax error so this is the same
statement except I'm going to add this
extra bracket which does not make sense
syntactically in this now if I try to
execute this as you can see we get a
different type of error known as the
syntax error when it says the unmatched
closing bracket so this is what a syntax
error looks like like an extra bracket
or a comma that basically makes the line
unreadable to The Interpreter in the
first place so the The Interpreter
doesn't even get to the point where it
needs to figure out that there is
something being divided by zero it
doesn't even get to that point because
it finds this extra bracket and it
cannot execute this line at all so that
is like the difference between an uh an
exception and a syntax error all right
now for our first case of how we raise
or how we handle exceptions let's look
at the keyword arrays so for this
example what I will be doing is I'm
going to take this variable X all right
and I'm going to store a value 10 and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
check for a condition if x is greater
than 5 then I'm going to raise this
exception using the raise keyword like
this and in case this condition is met
if x is actually greater than 5 I want
this particular message to play out in
my exception so let's see what happens
when I execute this as you can see the
exception is raised because X is indeed
greater than 5 its value is 10 and the
mirror message says so that X should not
exceed 5 the value of x was 10. so this
is an example of how we can raise an
exception and as you can see when a
condition was met the program comes to a
halt and an exception was raised now
let's look at another type of handling
exception where we use the assert
statement so when we use base command we
waited until an error occurred and our
program crashed Midway right what if we
want to check if a condition is met and
if this condition is met then then the
program can continue but if the
condition turns out to be false then we
want a particular error namely the
assertion error exception to be thrown
to us so we can use the assert command
in such a case so in our example we will
be checking whether the system that we
are working on is actually Linux or
Windows 32. so let's see first of all
let's import a library called sys this
is the it's a library which where we can
access system information one of the
modules and that is one of the functions
and that is the platform it basically
tells us what system are we working on
so we're working on a win32 system okay
so um let's now let's use the assert
keyword all right now we're going to
check if Linux is what we are working on
and in case it is not then we want an
error message and this will be the error
the error will obviously be an assertion
error because we are using the assert
keyword
so this is how we use the assert
statement and if we execute this as you
can see we get the assertion error
because systart platform contains win32
and not Linux and so we got this
assertion error so if we change this to
check for Windows system we won't have
any error when we execute this as you
can see so this is uh the example where
we use the assert statement another way
of handling exceptions is by using the
try and accept block so this is probably
one of the most common ways of handling
exceptions in Python where we use the
try keyword and an accept keyword now
within the try keyword as you can see
here we have a chunk of code which we're
going to check and if everything is fine
in the try keyword then this is perfect
so we don't need to move on to what we
call the accept part of the try and
accept block but if say there was an
error in the try block then we move on
to the accept block where we're going to
run the part of the code in the case we
find an error in the drive block so
first we check the channel the part of
the code that is under the try block and
if if there is an error we move on to
the accept block and we run that part of
the code over there and where we and in
the accept block where we that is where
we handle our whatever error that might
get thrown our way in the try block okay
let's look at an example at how to use
this technique so I have a basic
function out here all right it's of
defining a function called Linux
interaction what this is basically doing
is that when I call this function I want
to do an assert check I'm going to check
if Linux is the system I'm working on
and if it is not then I want this error
to be thrown okay and um so yeah let's
see what happens in the case and if if
the search statement is actually passed
then we will move on to this statement
so you could look at it like this if
whenever I mean when I call this
function it will first check for this
assert statement in case something wrong
happens and we get an assert error then
we do not move on to this line so we
only get this printed but if this assert
statement passes then we move on to this
line and we get print doing something
okay so let's see I'm going to call this
function out here let's see what happens
here as you can see I get an assertion
error because obviously this is a
Windows system and not a Linux system
and I get this message okay now let's
see what happens when we use it in a try
and accept block all right so now I have
a try block over here in which I am
going to try the same this function in
Linux underscore interaction if in case
I find an error I immediately jump from
the try block into the accept block now
you see the slight difference in how we
handle this like what happens so as you
can see when we use the function
explicitly we directly went to what we
called an assertion error but when we
use a try and accept block we will not
use the assertion error because we are
leaving the try block immediately and
we're going to go into the accept block
where the only thing we're doing is
printing the statement as you can see we
are not on Linux found some error okay
now what if we wanted to catch the error
within this function itself which was
the assertion error and we can do that
explicitly like this so now what I'm
doing is I'm going to try all right and
it's going to catch an error in this
right so now in the accept block I'm
going to say the assertion error that we
found in this function in the try block
we're going to use that in our except
block so as you can see we're going to
print that assertion error it will
basically print the statement function
can only run on Linux systems as you can
see here function can only run on net
systems function can only run on Linux
systems and the next part of the thing
was the Linux interaction function was
not executed okay so this is uh a very
this is like um this is a key there's a
key uh something very important
happening here when we use this assert
statement the whole program is actually
getting executed right but when we're
using the try and accept block we are
immediately jumping on like the moment
we catch an error we are immediately
jumping onto the accept statement and uh
however and all the handling of the
exception is done in the accept block
and not in the try block anymore so
where to uh think of it like this that
the try block is only to check if a
particular piece of code is like does it
have any errors or not and in case it
does then every like all the handling
that we do is uh in the accept block of
this particular statement now let's look
at another example in this example I am
going to try opening a particular file
now this file does not exist so I will
be I will get a file not found better
and this is a built-in exception and I'm
going to catch that and I'm going to
print that error over here in the accept
block all right so as you can see file
not found and whatever like error I have
I printed over here all right so this is
another like this is uh a file not found
error that we are going to that we we
caught in our try block and we're
handling it in the accept block now
let's use now let's combine both of the
examples where we use this Linux
interaction and we also try to open a
particular file and we try to do both
things in the try block and since both
of these contain errors let's see what
happens when we try to what happens when
we have like multiple errors in a try
block so as you can see in my try block
I'm not only doing this Linux
interaction I'm also trying to open a
particular file that does not exist
obviously so now you might think will I
get two exceptions well let's see what
happens when we try to execute this so
it's important to note that in our
accept we have one except for catching a
a file not found error and we also have
an except for finding the assertion
error that that is part of this Linux
interaction function so so since both of
these are error statements or they will
throw exceptions so now the question is
will we get both of these except blocks
or we get both of these exceptions where
we can only one of them will we get the
first one so let's see what happens so
as you can see my error statement is is
very much like the assertion error that
I had that we had done as part of this
Linux underscore interaction function
function can only run on Linux systems
the Linux function was not executed as
you can see that that is the one that
has been caught and for some reason the
file not found error has not been caught
and this is because this is a very
important feature of the try block the
moment we find the first error in our
try block we immediately leave and we do
not execute any of the further
statements and we jump into the
exceptions and we handle it using the
accept blocks so the moment an error was
found in this function function we do
not execute this part of the statement
and we directly jumped into the
respective exception that was the
assertion error exception so this is a
key takeaway so some of the some of the
other key takeaways when it comes to
exceptions is a try Clause is executed
up until the point where the first
exception is encountered and in the
accept clause or the exception Handler
we determine how the program responds to
this exception we can have multiple
exceptions and we can differentiate how
the program uh responds to each of these
and it's also very important to not use
accept clause on its own it's very
important not use a bear except Clause
now finally before we conclude this
topic of exceptions let's look at the
else and the finally Clause so the else
Clause is used when we want to execute a
particular piece of code in the case
where we have no exceptions or no errors
found so let's look at this just like we
had the Linux interaction function I am
going to define a win under underscore
interaction and this is going to check
whether our system is Windows or not in
case it is not then we get this error
message all right and in case it is a
Windows it is a Windows system we print
this in the case of when we call this
function so let's again use our try and
accept statement only in this case we
will be using an extra else Clause so we
first try this function in case there's
an error we catch it as an assertion
error and we print that error but if
there is no exception that we move on to
the else statement and we print this so
as you can see our we have actually
moved on to the else statement and we
print this line executing the else
clause and that is because we have found
no exceptions over here so again it's
key to remember that the else Clause is
used whenever you want to execute a
particular statement in the case where
we do not find any exceptions in the try
block the finally Clause is used when we
want to execute something regardless of
whether we have an error or an exception
or not so no matter if an exception
happens I mean is raised or or if it's
not raised we want this finally block to
always get executed and let's look at
how it's let's look at an example of it
being used so I have this block where
I'm doing a lot of things the first
thing that I'm doing is I'm going to
check for this Linux interaction
function which is going to check of
course whether it's a linear system or
not this is I'm doing the try block now
if I catch an error that I want to be I
want to handle it by simply printing the
error over here and in the event that
there is no error then I will move on to
the else statement and I will try this
particular block of my statement which
is again that when I'm trying to read a
particular file that does not exist and
it's very uh it's very important that
you note that within the else block I
have another try and accept block and
this is perfectly legal and it's
perfectly valid in our program we can do
this so think of it like this I'm first
trying this if I have an error then I do
this and I don't execute this but if I
don't have an error then I execute this
whole statement which contains its own
try and accept block all right but
regardless of whether I get an error
here or not I will always execute this
portion of my statement or under the
finally Clause let's execute this as you
can see of course the error is raised in
this try try block so we move on to the
exception and that is what is printed
over here and after the exception is
done we move on to the finally we of
course skip this else block because the
exception was actually raised so after
that is done we move on to the finally
block where uh we print this particular
statement well that was it for an
introduction into exceptions in Python I
hope you learned something from this and
um of course this is just the beginning
exceptions are something that you will
be that you would probably encounter a
lot especially when you're beginning and
it's something that you will learn to
extensively work with and that will also
help you improve in your programming in
this video we will be covering the topic
of iterators now an iterator in Python
is an object that contains a countable
number of values or it's a larger object
it contains a countable number of
sub-objects an iterator is an object
that can be iterated upon and what that
means is we can Traverse from each value
and we can manipulate or perform certain
functions or operations and tasks using
each of the sub-objects or values Within
These larger collection called iterator
now
um when we're looking at it technically
an iterator is an object which
implements the iterator protocol in
Python which consists of the methods
iter and the method next so to begin
with let's look at a simple iterator
we're going to see the example of a list
where we're going to Traverse through
the objects of a list using the for Loop
so we have objects one two three four
and I'm going to print each of these
values one by one as you can see here
similarly we can also do the same thing
for another iterable known as the string
where we can go character by character
again using the for loop as you can see
here another example of an iterable in
Python is the dictionary so let's say I
have a dictionary where I have two value
use two key value pairs key X which
contains the value 1 and key Y which
corresponds to value 2. now when I'm
going to do a for Loop through this by
default I will be traversing through the
keys X and Y as you can see over here
and of course the other types of weight
troubles in Python are like sets and
tuples as well all right now let's look
at um what this iterating protocol is in
Python so first of all we take an
iterable it's an object that contains uh
it's a collection of objects it contains
sub-objects and when we use the eater
function it creates an iterator out of
it so we can one by one we can Traverse
through each of the objects and we can
manipulate each of the objects that is
contained in this and anytime we want to
move to the next object we use the next
function and when we have finally
completed all of the or we've
manipulated or traversed through each of
the sub objects we encounter the stop
iteration exception which tells us okay
there are no more objects to be
manipulated or iterated upon so and as
an example I will create a list where I
will store the values some simple values
in teachers one two three four one three
four five okay I'm going to create an
iterator out of this where I will use
iter function and I'm going to say this
is let's say this is called my my editor
okay and I'm going to use iter function
as I had mentioned and I'm going to pass
my list in this
now if you see what is my editor it
should say it should be a list iterator
at a particular memory location now
let's use the next function to keep
going through whatever is there in this
so of course the first object should be
one as you can see now when I look at
the next it should be three then I
should get four and now I should get
five as I use the next uh successively
now since I've reached the last of my
objects in this collection now the next
time I use this next function I should
get a stop stop iteration exception that
is raised as you can see here so this is
the basic iteration protocol in Python
now you might have already gone through
the for Loop video and in that I have
spoken in quite a bit of detail as to
how a for Loop performs this um this
iterator protocol and how it creates an
iterative iterable object out of say a
list or a tuple and how we how it
internally performs the next function
and it um breaks out of the for Loop
once it encounters the stop iteration
exception so
um for Loops are like they're very very
similar to your standard iterator and
they use pretty much the same protocol
for its functioning now let's do a basic
comparison of what is a a basic
comparison between a generator and an
iterator in Python so in generator we
use a function we use like we Define it
using the def keyword and we Define it
under one function to create a generator
whereas in the case of iterators we use
two separate functions the iter function
and the next function the generator
makes use of the yield keyword whereas
the python iterator does not in
generators we save the states of the
local variables each time we use the
yield keyword and we pause the loop
temporarily whereas in iterators we do
not make use of any local variables all
we need is any triple like a list to
iterate upon we may use any number of
years statements in generators and we do
not use yield statements in iterators
generators are not memory efficient
whereas iterators are very memory
efficient so this is like basic
comparison between generators and
iterators in this video we will be
covering the topic of modules at python
now a module in Python to put it simply
is basically a python file that has
functions and classes written into it
and is saved with the dot py extension
to specify that it is indeed a python
file a Python program can use one or
more modules and modules can have one or
more functions they basically help us
organize our code and instead of having
one like one long python file we can
have several files for several modules
now my modular programming is the
process of breaking a large a large
event or task into smaller and more
manageable subtasks and we call these
subtasks basically modules now
individual modules can be grouped
together like building blocks to create
a larger application there are several
advantages to modulizing code in a large
application and we will be going through
them right now so first of all there is
Simplicity because instead of focusing
on a big big problem or big task we can
break down the problem into smaller
smaller portions or modules now
maintainability of code is much better
through module because they are designed
to create these sort of boundaries or
clear demarcations between different
problem domains there is usability
reusability in the sense that once we
create a module we can use it in
different parts of the code or even
different different applications itself
there is also scoping and what this
means is modules typically Define a
separate namespace and this helps us
avoid collisions between identifiers in
different areas of a program functions
modules and packages are basically all
constructs in Python that promote code
modulus modularization you might have
already come across a coordinate intro
into functions in this video we will be
going through modules and another video
we will also cover the topic of packages
to import a module we use the import
keyword and in this example what I'm
going to show you is a simple function
or a simple operation of importing the
OS module this is short for operating
system and as the name suggests we can
perform a system tasks through the
functions and methods that are part of
this OS module so simply executing the
statement will import this module onto
our program for us to use now if we
wanted to see all the functions that are
present in a module what we have to do
is use the dir function so if we print
the dir OS function it will print us
basically a directory of all the
functions that are present in the OS
module as you can see here that like all
of these are basically names to
different functions that are part of the
OS module finally moving on another
function commonly used with modules is
the getcwd function and what this does
is it will give us the current working
uh directory that we are working upon
right now so if I execute this it will
tell me what is the directory that I am
currently working upon right now as you
can see seed notebook dir stem if you
wanted to see all the files in a
particular directory what we can do is
use the list dir function followed by
giving a path by default if we do not
enter a path inside the parenthesis it
will basically give us all the files in
the current working directory which in
our case is temp so if I were to execute
this it gives basically gives me a list
of all the files that are presently uh
there in the directory that I am
currently working upon now a basic step
is um creating a python module the
simplest way to create a python module
is basically creating a python script
with whatever functions and tasks that
we want and methods that we want inside
uh whatever module and saving it with a
DOT py extension
um so in in my example what I'm going to
do is I have already created a script in
notepad and I've stored it with a DOT py
extension that contains these four
functions add subtract product and
Division I have basically copied I
basically use this code and I've stored
it in a.py script and I'm going to be
using this as my uh as as a test module
for this particular example now how do
we import a module now once that I have
created a script in my example it will
be called my character UI and we've
stated stored it in our directory to
import the module all we have to do is
use the import statement so if I had to
import my calc all I have to do is say
import my underscore calc and now my
calc has been imported um so we can use
the import statement or if we want to
import something particular from my
calculator we can do from my calc import
uh now we can whatever like for example
if we wanted the ad uh the add function
we can basically just say only add or if
we wanted add and subtract we can say
add and subtract for example so this is
basically by using from we can say that
we want something from something but
only parts of it we don't want
everything we can also use from my calc
import and we can say asterisks to
basically say uh import everything that
exists in my calc right now so this is
another way of importing something from
a module now to access contents in a
module we have to use the dot operator
and I will show you how right now so
what I'm going to do is in my example
I'm going to import my calc as calc so
now what this since this is the original
folder or the original module but I'm
going to give it a shorthand name so
that I can easily use it in my code and
I don't have to type out my underscore
calc every time so now I'm going to
import this as calc so anytime I have to
refer to a particular method or function
inside the script or this module I will
just use this uh this placeholder this
variable name so now I have two
variables A and B and I'm storing 20 and
30 in them so my first func what I'm
going to do is basically four operations
I'm going to print the addition of A and
B then the subtraction multiplication
and the division of these two numbers
and each time to do this operation I am
going to use the add function that is
present in the my calc module so to do
that I have already imported my karukas
calc all I'm going to do now is invoke
these functions using the dot operator
that we're already familiar with so I'm
going to say carrot.add and then I'm
going to pass these two arguments or
these two variables to say that I want
to add these two and similarly I'm going
to do it for subtraction um uh
multiplication and division as you can
see these are the results of my tasks
now if I had to do a directory uh
operation on the module calc it will
basically give me a bunch of inbuilt uh
or Dunder methods that are already a
part of any uh python script by default
such as built-ins so if I execute this
just to show you what happens when I use
the dir function it will basically give
me all the functions that are part of
this python script so these double
underscores that you see are basically
uh denoting magic methods or Dunder
methods and these are like inbuilt
methods as a part of the script and if
you see here add division prod and sub
these are the methods that we have
defined earlier on in our script
ourselves now to go slightly deeper or
more detail into what happens when we do
a module search
um let's let's actually look at what
happens so what happens is when for
example we execute the statement import
my calc as calc as we did over here so
the first the steps that actually take
place are the interpreter executes the
above statement and it searches for this
python script in a list of directories
assembled from these following sources
that you see here so it takes the
directory from which the input script
was run or the current directory if The
Interpreter is being run interactively
which is the case right now secondly it
will list all the directories contained
in the python path environment that you
set up uh that you can set up or you can
change later on as well and this format
for python path is OS dependent of
course but it should mimic the path
environment variable that we see in
Windows systems and then the other
source or the other directories is
basically an installation dependent list
of categories configured at the time
python is installed now the resulting
search paths that is accessible in the
python variable system.path and this is
basically obtained from a module named
sys so if I import it this is and I did
sys dot path now these are all the
directories that we are going to look
for when we want to search for any
particular module so if I am doing uh
import my import OS it's not only going
to look at the current directory that I
am working on it's also going to look at
all of these directories that have been
set up as you could say directories or
paths in the system.path in this video
we will be covering the topic of
packages now what if we developed a very
large application in Python that
contains many different modules and we
have so many different modules that have
similar names and functionalities and
they're all kept in like or dumped in
the same location that it becomes very
difficult to track these modules what if
there was a way to organize and access
these in a much simpler and more
organized manner well packages allow us
to do just that packages are a
hierarchical structuring of the module
namespace using dot notation and this is
the same dot notation that we use when
we want to access methods or functions
that are part of other classes or
modules so let's try to uh let's look at
certain examples to understand what we
mean so I have a directory called PKG
this can be basically treated as what we
call a package now in our package we
have two modules mod1.py and mod 2 Dot V
by and what we're going to store in mod
1 and mod 2.py are the follows so I'm
going to define a function called Foo
and I'm going to print this particular
statement mod1 and then I'm gonna
basically say Foo and then I'm going to
say in class Foo I'm gonna have an empty
pass command similarly I'm going to
define a function called bar in mod 2
dot py where I'm going to print this
statement so basically mod1.py has a
simple function where I'm going to print
this statement and mod 2.py has a simple
function then I'm going to print this
statement
um and I'm going to store them in mod 1
and mod 2. Ty respectively and these two
modules I'm going to store in the
directory tkg in my local folder now
I've already done this so we can already
get to working with this now if I wanted
to access these particular modules from
the PKG folder I can simply use the
import command and use the dot notation
so I can say PKG dot mod1 so this will
invert in this will import the mod 1
module from PKG folder similarly I can
do the same thing for the mod 2 module
from the PKG folder in the same line so
now that it's been imported just simply
execute this and this Imports whatever
we needed now if we wanted to perform a
function that was a part of
mod1.py we can just extend the dot
notation and use the function as over
here as you can see it performs this
print command whatever it was supposed
to do similarly I can invoke the
function that was part of the mod 2
module by extending the dot notation to
it in the same way now another way that
I can invoke I can import a package is
by directly importing the package Itself
by using import pkz and not accessing
any of the specific modules within it
now let's see what happens when we do
this so just for this example what I'm
going to do is I'm going to restart the
kernel so that the PKG modules that were
already imported get cleaned away so we
see what happens when we execute this on
its own now if you see I haven't
imported this now let's see if I can
access my mod 1 and mod 2. now if you
see here it's throwing me an error and
this is because using simply using the
import command on a particular package
only Imports
um you could say the package name space
but it does not actually import any of
the modules and files that were part of
this package so if I wanted mod 1 from
this package I would have to actually
say import pkz.mod1 directly and I
cannot simply say import PKG and python
will not import everything that is part
of a package on its own I have to
specify it myself
specifically now I'm going to create and
I'm going to I mean I'm going to show
you another type of importing from a
package using the star operator so I
have this package PKG once again now I'm
going to store
um three I mean four different modules
within this package
mod11.py mod 222.py and I've already
done this you don't need to bother about
seeing me doing it right now because
I've already created these files and
what I'm have done is within mod11.py I
have defined I've passed I've written
this statement and I've stored in the
python script similarly I've created
another Python scripts script called
mod22.py and I have basically written
this in the code and I've similarly done
this for mod 333.py and I've done
another for mod 4.py now once I have
done this I've stored these Python
scripts into my uh into my package uh
PKG package so now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create I'm going to
execute this command if you see this
from pkg.mod 333 import start so once I
execute this now I'm going to say print
directory and print directory basically
will tell me all the functions that
exist in my current directory if you see
here there's this bias function that was
a part of mod 333 module now if I change
this and if I imported mod11 and if I
did the same thing you will see Foo has
now been added as a part of this
direction directory and these are all
functions that are part of these
different modules where I am importing
from and that is what the star function
does what the star function will do is
it will basically tell python okay so
this statement is saying from pkz dot
mod11 so it's saying that okay look into
this directory or this uh package and
find this module and in this module
import everything that exists inside it
up until this point so this is another
another way of basically importing uh
files or functions from a particular
package and a particular specific module
within that package so yeah this was a
very brief video on packages in Python
uh the conclusion being that packages
are basically a an organized way of
storing many different modules that we
might have created in a very large
application and these modules can be
accessed using the familiar.net notation
that we have used in other examples such
as methods when we were working with
classes and objects in this video we
will be taking an introduction into the
concept of generators so python provides
a generator which is like a function
where we can create our own iterator in
a generator function we use the yield
statement instead of the return
statement that we use for standard
functions so let's look at a simple
Generator First of all so out here I
have defined
a generator called my generator where
I'm doing like the three uh like three
functions or three tasks that I'm doing
uh first one is when I'm printing the
first item and I'm yielding a value 10
then I'm printing second item using 20
then I'm printing last item using 30. so
let's see how do we use this
now since we know my generator is the
function it uses the yield keyword every
time we use the next keyword we will
keep getting what is next in this
function so let's store
um the generator in my gen
so now we have stored the iterator in
this function variable called gen or gen
now let's see when we do next
and we use gen
what happens so the first task is
performed or the first iteration is
performed where we get this the first
year command is done all right let's see
what happens when we do next again
next gen
now
as you can see we get second item and we
get 20. let's do it for the next so
let's do it once more since there is one
more task team uh there's one more
iterable inside
you can see this now a very question is
what will happen if we do next gen again
since there is nothing after this
well let's see what happens
we should get an error as you can see
stop iteration error this is another uh
built-in exception
um that happens when we have like
reached the last object of an iterable
so we get a stop iteration error
so now a key difference between a
generator and a function is that when we
execute a function the moment we hit the
return statement in a function or any
execute a function like whatever
variables are stored inside are lost and
they are destroyed unless they were
defined as Global and the function is
completely done executing and we leave
the function completely whereas when it
comes to a generator when we hit the
yield function we don't actually
completely leave this function so the
first time the yield is found we get 10
but the generator remembers its position
inside this function so the next time we
use the next we actually move on to the
next iterable and then we move on to the
next hit Triple so you can think of a
generator as it sort of has memory if
that makes sense it's a way to like
create iterables in python or create
iterators in Python so to understand a
what the difference between the yield
command and the return commanders let's
take the same function all right
and let's put it return over here
after this particular the second yield
okay let's do the same thing we say gen
is equal to my generator
and
let's start uh yeah let's start
doing next gen and seeing what's there
so the first here will be standard first
item 10 the next one is again it's going
to say second item and then 20 but now
if you notice there was a return I put
over here
so technically when I did the second
next it's not only yielded 20 but it's
also executed this return function or
this return statement so let's see what
happens if I do next again
as you see I have gotten the stop
iteration seemingly earlier than I did
before and that's because I have used
the return function and why I'm in
return statement and what that's done is
that um if we've completely left this
function so as to speak and there is
nothing next so as to speak so we get
these top iteration and that's uh the
difference between yield and return
now in the next example I'm going to
show you how we use a generator function
in place of the for Loop or for a for
Loop so let's take this whatever over
here and I have defined a function
called get sequence up to X and what
this will do is basically it will keep
printing the printing numbers up until
whatever we have entered in place of X
over here so if I said say sequence is
equal to
Let's uh
copy this all right and say I want um I
want sequentially I want every number up
until 10 well not including 10 of course
because python starts with 0 right
so let's do this and um
now let's see so the first number will
yield 0
and now if I
did this again
should give me one
two and I can keep going
until I will stop at the value 9. as you
can see here
so 8 9 now I should get the stop
iteration error because that we have
reached the end of our iteration so this
is a way of using generator functions
for for loops
so another neat example where we're
going to use a generator is
um in the case of Fibonacci numbers so
let's use it let's see how we can
generate a Fibonacci series using um
generator so I've defined a Fibonacci
function called Fibonacci where I'm
passing Max so max is basically the max
value that I want
um yeah like up until where I want the
sequence right so this is basically the
code which will uh give return me the
subsequent values of my Fibonacci
Sequence so let's um pass this to fib
and see I want all the Fibonacci numbers
until 10.
so once I will pass 10 over here
let's see what happens when we do next
fib
well it should start with zero then when
we
do this again we get 1 then we do 0 plus
1 it should be one next number should be
one plus one which is 2 then we should
have two plus one three and then three
plus two five then three plus five
should be eight now eight plus five is
thirteen and since 13 is greater than
what we pass for our max value here now
when we try this we should get the stop
iteration error as you can see
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of list comprehension
Now list comprehension is it's a neat
way of creating a new list based on
values that are already there in an
existing list so you can think of it
like creating a new list using a much
shorter and cleaner syntax compared to
what you might traditionally be thinking
so let's go through some examples and
through those examples we will see how
list comprehension makes creating these
new this much simpler and much easier
for us
so in our first example we will be
creating a new list which will contain
fruits that contain the letter a in
their name so we already have a list of
fruits over here as you can see it has
Apple it has banana Cherry kiwi and
mango now we want to create a new list
which has only the fruits that have the
letter A inside them so Apple would be
one of them banana would be one of them
and mango would be one of them so
traditionally
if you look at this piece of code
this would do what we want to do but
this contains a few extra lines but yeah
it does it does do what we want to do
now what if there was a way of doing the
same thing by just writing one simple
line of code and that exists as you can
see here
so I take the same
list now this is where you need to
follow so now my new list is equal to so
I'm creating a list over here as you can
see now within this list you have this
line this is what we call a list
comprehension so as you can see it says
each fruit for each fruit in fruits if
now it's checking for the letter or the
character a inside each fruit and what
this each fruit is that we're checking
each object in this list one by one so
first in the first iteration each fruit
will contain the string Apple then in
the next iteration it will contain
banana and in each each iteration we're
going to check if it contains the
character a and if it does then we store
that each fruit in the new list
as you can see here so if I execute this
line you see my my result is the same I
have my whatever I want it and this was
a much cleaner way of writing uh or
creating this new list let's look at
some other examples now
so my next example what I'm going to do
is I am going to iterate through a
string so I have a string it can be
anything in this case I am using a
string called human
all right so I have a string called
human right now I want to store each
character of this string into a list
that we call H underscore letters so if
I use the for Loop this is how we would
do it if I execute this as you can see
the list contains H and then u m a and
then n now what if I wanted to do the
same thing but uh by using list
comprehension
so what I would do is
let's create
a list over here H underscore letters
and
um so as we know let's come so this
comprehension will uh it's it's a it's
you just basically need one line in this
case it'll just be like this
now this is my string
now let's see when I check what's in h
letters
let's see what is the output so as you
can see I have the output as uh what I
needed so this is a much cleaner way
let's go through some more examples now
now we can do more list comprehensions
um we can even use so we've already seen
uh one case where we checked for the
character a we've seen a case where we
uh went through where we we did a sort
of a loop through a string we can also
use this comprehensions in conditionals
so let's uh look at an example where we
use the uh this comprehension with an if
statement
so what if I wanted to store say the
first 10 even numbers so this would so
this is an example that I'll be using so
in my list I want to store the first 10
even numbers so this would be a way to
do it
so I have in range 20 so what this is
going to do is X is going to take the
value of 1 2 3 4 and so on until 98 that
actually take it from 0 1 2 3 4 until
19. so when we do range 20 we're
creating an iterate in iterable where uh
we're going to look through our iterate
through the value of 0 to 19. so if I if
I do this and this what this statement
does is basically uh it checks if it's
divisible by two
so if this is equal to equal to 0 that
means we have an even number and if this
condition is met if this condition is
met that means we store uh the X into
our number list so let's see what
happens when we execute this
should contain uh 0 2 4 6 until 18. so
this is the first 10 even numbers as you
can see so this is a neat wave using if
statement we can also use an if else
statement
so what if I I'm checking um each okay
so I'm going to create another list and
in this list I'm going to basically see
if um
each of my num numbers either even or
odd the first let's say 10 natural
numbers
so let's write this statement down
so I want it to be even in case
the I that I'm checking I being every
number between so like say the first 10
natural numbers as I said
let's check if um if it is divisible by
because if it is by 2 of course it's
going to be even right else
we say that it is odd
and then we checked for I in say the
first let's say the first 20.
okay
so now when we do this and we check oh
he check what's in the list so as you
can see the list contains like even or
even orders basically saying the number
uh zero is even then the number one is
odd then number two is even and so on
and so forth so this is uh an example
where we used the list comprehension
with if else statements so another neat
thing that we can do with the list
comprehensions is that we can use it
along with functions so let's look at
this function in this example we have a
function called double X where we Define
this double X this double function to
take an input to take an argument X and
what we return is the square of the
argument so let's use this in uh in our
left list comprehension so what we do
over here is that we are we're checking
what we're doing is for every X bit in
range 10. so we're taking the value of 0
1 2 3 until 9 and we're passing it to
this function double X and we're going
to get the square of them and we're
going to store that in a in a list as
you can see here let's call this list X
so just call this list uh let's call it
y so now let's see what's in y and we
check uh it should be 0 1 4 9 and so on
so wait this let's check again does this
Square now this is actually two times so
let's make it square
as you can see
so you can see zero one four nine for
the first 10 numbers 10 natural numbers
now what I've shown you is obviously
less comprehension but we can also do
set and dictionary comprehensions in
fact set comprehensions work exactly the
same way as list comprehensions but the
only difference is the set
comprehensions will make sure that there
are no duplicates inside the set so you
can't have like duplicate items which
you can in the case of list
comprehensions so let's uh let's like
let's take a look at an example so here
in this example what we're doing is
we're going to check so we have this
string that we're storing in the
variable text and the string is
something like live finds a way so
whatever this is now what we're going to
do is we're going to in iterate through
this string character by character and
we're going to check if uh there are
we're going to check for vowels
essentially so uh are going to see if
the character a e i o or U is present in
the string and if it is we will pass it
into our set now if you if you look you
will find there are multiple eyes right
and there are multiple A's as well so if
we did this through a list comprehension
each time that we find found find a
vowel it would be added to our list but
since this is a set and sets do not
allow duplicates so you will only have
one copy or one particular object for
each of the vowels so uh of course now
uh set comprehension is defined using
curly braces so let's keep that in mind
so now if I check what's in this I will
see a e i and U even though there are
multiple A's or multiple E's or I's and
U's since this is a set we don't have
duplicate copies of any copies of any of
these uh so this was just a small
example for uh showing you set
comprehensions similarly we can do the
same thing uh this this comprehension uh
for dictionaries and if we call it
dictionary comprehensions the only thing
that we have to worry about when it
comes to dictionary comprehensions is
that we have to define a key when it
comes to this so let's let's look at an
example
in this what we're doing is again
dictionary comprehensions are also
defined using curly braces just like
sets except in this case we will Define
a key and that separates it from a set
comprehension so in this case what we're
doing is that I'm checking I'm going
through the a list of numbers from 0 to
9 right so what the range 10 function
does and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create a key which is going to
be like 0 1 2 3 and the value of each
key would be H Square as you can see
here I'm doing I times I or just to
make a little more clearer as you can
see I'm doing I squared over here for
every value from 0 to 9. so what I
should get is like a dictionary where
the first key is 0 and the value of that
key should be 0 as well because 0 square
is zero then for one it will be one and
then for 2 4 and then three nine four
sixteen so let's see what happens as you
can see here this is the the result that
I wanted
so just to summarize let's go through
some key points uh to remember when it
comes to list comprehensions
um so it's obviously An Elegant way to
define and create list based on existing
lists uh it's more Compact and faster
than normal functions and Loops but we
should also keep in mind that we
shouldn't write like very complicated uh
list comprehensions because the idea of
a list comprehension is to be user
friendly and also it's important to note
that every list comprehension can be
written in the form of a loop but uh
every Loop cannot be written in the form
of a list comprehension and that is a
probably a very key point to remember in
this video we will be learning about the
concept of regular Expressions now a
regular expression is simply a sequence
of characters that defines a search
pattern for example if you see this
example here you can see a symbol called
the carrot followed by P and then five
periods then an n and a dollar sign and
what this strikex pattern does is it's
searching for a seven letter string that
starts with B ends with n and has five
characters in between
let's look at this example now this is a
regex pattern that is looking for a five
character string that starts with a ends
with s and has three characters in
between now if we had to match this with
this string with these strings as an uh
as I O test strings the first one would
not match because it's a three letter
string and we're looking for a five
character string the second one would
match because it's a five character
string that ends with an s starts with
an A and has three characters in between
this will not match because whatever
pattern would do is it would find the
first s and it would find that the
string itself starts with an A and it
would say okay there are only two
characters between this first s and this
a and it would assume that this is
actually just a four character string to
actually Identify two consecutive s's we
would have to do something special and
what we would have to do is what we will
see later on so again this is the same
example since this is case insensitive
capital a uh is perfectly fine when
we're searching for this and it will
also match this is
um this is obviously two words and it's
not a five character string so this will
not be a match
now the regex pattern or the regular
expression module in Python can be
imported using this statement import re
now once we've done this we can actually
use the our regular expression tools and
methods to do a pattern recognition
character recognitions and to identify a
different sequence of characters in our
strings let's try to understand a bit
more in depth about regular Expressions
now so what you are seeing here is one
variable call pattern which stores
something that looks like a regex and
another variable that stores our test
string called abis now what we're going
to do is we're going to use the match
method of this module re and we're going
to check whether this pattern
um or whatever we are trying to search
using this reg X is in fact does it
match with our test string and what
we're trying to look for is if you see
here very similar to what I just showed
you a 5 character string that starts
with a and ends with s
so if you see our test string it induced
is a match and when we use this uh this
command we should get a perfect match
so we should be basically it should say
that search is successful if I execute
this and this is what it does
now if I change the test string to this
now you will see that now this is no
longer what we're looking for a five
character string with a and starting
with a and ending with s and you will
see that the search will be unsuccessful
as you can see here now let's try to
understand what exactly do we mean by uh
when we use these different cert these
special symbols like for example this
carrot or this dollar symbol
um these are by the way known as meta
characters and now we're going to look
into all the uh or most of the different
meta characters that are used in Rec X
so to put it simply meta characters are
simply characters that are interpreted
in a special way by the regex search
engine now here's a list of meta
characters
let's go through them one by one
now the square brackets square brackets
simply specifies the set of characters
that we wish to match so we want to
match some combination of a b and c it
can be one a two a is Three B's four C's
we are not looking at a specific pattern
we just want to know if a b and c exists
in any form in our string so if we used
it on a the string a simply we would
find one match because the letter a is
found here AC would match twice because
we have a and C present here in this
string Hey Jude we will have no matches
because a b and c none of them are found
here and in this weird string we will
have actually one two three
four and five matches so we would have
five matches for this uh this bigger
string because we have five instances of
a b or c
now let's use re dot match to do to
actually search for this and to uh see
if we have our particular whatever
patterns that we're looking for now in
this input string this is just some
example string
um I'm going to test this I'm going to
match whether my pattern that um a any
of a b and c is it actually found in
this so let's see what happens when I
use re dot match for this
so the the format uh the syntax is
simply the regex pattern and then comma
whatever test string that we have
so
let's see what object gets created when
we try to do this as you can see it's
none even though you might be wondering
like I can see an a over here I can see
a c over here re dot match actually
gives us the result none
now
if I try to do it on this test string
which is slightly different instead of
the film Titanic was at least in 1998
what I'm saying here is all film Titanic
was released in 1998. now let's see if
the r match works or not
as you can see it actually does give a
return When I execute this it returns as
an object called re.match object with a
span 0 1. the span zero one is basically
telling us that we have found a match
between the zeroth and the first
character which is basically this
character a which is what it has found
and it's saying that the match is indeed
the character a uh from amongst these
options
so what this is basically telling us and
what this means actually is that the re
dot match method will only find matches
if they occur at the start of the string
being searched once there is a space in
in our bigger string it will not search
for whatever comes after it so
what happened in the first instance was
it was actually only searching for
matches in this particular word in my
largest string and since it found no
match it basically gave us the result
none which was not the case in the
second example because it found a match
immediately in the first letter A
now if we want to actually check the
whole thing what we would be using is
the re dot search as you can see here
the re dot search method will actually
check the whole string and it will
return us the first instance where it
finds a match now let's see this is a
test string now and we're searching
again for AR we're searching for a b and
c any any of these in our test string
but we're going to use re.search and not
match so now if you see it returns us
when I execute this it returns us a
match object again but this time it's
saying the span of 9 and 10. now the
spine panel 9 and 10 actually exists
over here this is the ninth character
and a itself is the 10th character over
here so what this basically is telling
us that the 10th character is where we
found a match which was the letter A
which was the first instance of either A
or B or C in this whole string and this
is basically how re.search works it will
not only search the beginning of the
string but it will search the whole
string and return us the first instance
our wherever we find now what if we
wanted to find out all the instances
wherever a b and c were found and not
just the first instance well in that
case we would be using the method find
all over here so when we use find all it
will actually return us each and every
case where it found a b or c and you
might not it won't tell you the exact
position but it will tell you like
um so if I execute this you can see it
gives us a a list with AAC a and a and
what this basically means is it was
looking for the characters A or B or C
and it found a first and hence this for
the first item in the list then it found
a c and then it found two is
successfully so this is exact this is
actually how find all works where it
will actually find all the instances of
our regex pattern now that you've seen
how the square brackets work and how the
re dot search and re dot uh match and re
dot find all methods work now we're
going to go through all the other meta
characters that we saw above so the
period now period matches any single
character except the new line new line
is basically slash n or a break now if
you look at this picture what it's going
to do is
um a this expression basically saying
that uh do we have
um two characters like sets of two
characters in our string so this is a
single character string and obviously a
single character string is not a double
character string and this expression
this double dot is basically asking us
do we have two characters present in our
string so if I had to match it with this
a it will obviously be a no match
because a is one character if we checked
it with AC it is a match because A and C
are two characters a c and d will also
give us only one match because it will
find AAC and then it will leave d as a
single character but when we check a c d
and e or this string in particular it
will find two matches because it will
consider a and C as one of the matches
and d and e as one of the matches So
Below is basically what we are doing
basically the same thing which is using
Rd dot search for each of these
different examples so if I if you see
when I use find all on acde and when I'm
searching for a two character match you
will see that it will return me a c and
d e as you can see here and similarly
for something like this it will return
me again uh whatever like two character
patterns it finds successively
so the next symbol the next meta
character is the carrot symbol that
you've seen earlier now in the Carrick
symbol is basically used to check if a
string starts with a certain character
so if you look at these two this picture
if you have two two expressions that
we're going to check over here one is
the one is checking if a is the
beginning of a string and the other one
will check if a
is the beginning of the string but is it
followed by b or not
so when we check this what you can see
is the first string will be a match
because it's the only the character a
and it will match here as well because
this string starts with a but it will
not match here because this string
starts with B now if I look at this
particular expression you can see that
this is going to search for if the
string starts with a and is followed by
a b so it will match in this case
because a does start with a and is
followed by a b but it will not match in
this case even though it starts with an
A because it's not followed by a b so
out here is basically us using the ID
dot search to basically find these
patterns
the next symbol that we will come across
is the dollar symbol so the dollar
symbol that you can see here is used to
check if a string ends with a certain
character and we've already seen how
this is used in one of the uh one of the
earlier examples so this is going to
check basically if so this expression
will check if the string ends with a so
this uh this string is basically the
character a so it will match this also
ends with a so it will match and this
particular string does not end with a so
it will not match and we are going to do
that using the re dot search over here
so as you can see it finds a match in
the first character itself here in this
case it finds a match in the last
character but in cab there is no match
so it returns I say none another example
is of the meta characters is star so
this is the symbol for star and this
what the star basically is used is for
checking if there are zero or more
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it so now if you see here what this
will check for is is there any form of M
and A
that occurs before n and it's very
important to note that the N has to
follow the a in this case so let's look
at these examples and what will happen
so if I checked it with M and N this is
actually a match because n is followed
by zero occurrences of M and A which is
if it might seem a little weird but it
is technically the truth because uh the
the star symbol checks for not doesn't
check for the Existence it just checks
for with n occurs it must occur after an
A or the a should not be there itself in
this particular string so as you can see
here the N occurs after an m and it's
fine because there is no a now you will
see when it will not work so M A and N
is obviously fine m a uh M Triple A N is
also fine because n follows an A and
there's an M here
this however main will not match now why
even though we have M and A and we have
an N you see the N is immediately
followed by an i is n follows an I
immediately or the N is preceded by an I
immediately and this is a no match
because our the strict condition in the
search is that n must uh proceed in a if
the a exists
again in women it will match because n
follows an a over here we're just going
to use the re dot search for these
examples that we saw over here in terms
of code using the Rd dot search as you
can see here finally we have the next
meta character which is the plus symbol
yes so the plus symbol matches one or
more occurrences of the pattern left to
it now this is very similar to what we
saw earlier in terms of the star except
now in the plus the key difference is
we're looking for one or more
occurrences instead of zero or more
occurrences that we were looking for in
the case of star
so when we say one or more occurrences
now we need what is there to the left of
the plus sign a zero uh no occurrence of
it will not be allowed or will not cause
a match so let's see now what we're
going to do here we're going to use the
same expression except we're going to
replace the star with the plus sign so
now what we're going to say is okay we
need M and A at least one occurrence
followed by an N the all of these
conditions have to be met so again if we
took the first example M and N this time
it will be a no match because there is
no occurrence of an a over here for
preceding the N so it's a no match M A
and N is a match because well this is
per this is perfectly fine M Triple A
and N is also perfectly fine but if you
look at m a i and N much like earlier
the N is uh preceded by an i and not an
A so there is no match and again woman
is perfectly fine and we basically
execute the same thing through the
search function in this piece of code
the next meta character is the question
mark the question mark symbol matches 0
or 1 occurrences of the the pattern to
the left of it so let's see what this
does so now we saw the star the star
which was zero or more occurrences of
the pattern to the left of it we saw the
plus which is one or more occurrences of
the pattern to the left of it now we
will see the question mark which is 0 or
1 only 0 or only one and not zero or
more of one or more which was the
previous cases only zero and one or one
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it again we're going to see the same
expression except we're going to replace
the meta character with the question
mark So now let's see what what happens
when we match so if you see here M and N
is a match because there is zero
occurrence of a and one occurrence of M
preceding n so this is fine
this is also fine because there is one
occurrence of A and M and then it's
followed by an n this will not be fine
because now we have three occurrences of
a
which is followed by an N we're only
looking for 0 or 1. this again main will
be a no match for the same reasons that
we have already gone through and women
will be a match again for the same
reasons
and we read through the same things
using the search function in this piece
of code the next meta character is the
braces character now the braces
character is interesting because what
we're going to do is we're going to see
if there are so uh this is the typical
Syntax for abrasives is an uh brace
followed by some integer n comma integer
M and then close braces so what this
means is we're looking for at least n
and at most M repetitions of the pattern
left of the braces let's see through an
example if you see this expression we're
looking for at least two and at most
three occurrences of this the character
a in our test strings so let's see what
happens in the first case we have no
matches in this case because this part
of the string contains only one a and
even this part of the string only
contains one a we're looking for at
least two and at most three this part
will contain one match the second the
second example because the second part
of the string actually contains two is
for one two repetition is consecutively
but this uh in the end and in the third
example you can see both the strings
actually contain matches so we get two
matches because as you can see here
there's two A's here followed by Three
A's here
now when we look at this particular
string let's look at what happens now so
what we're going to find is that this
thing is perfectly fine so we have two
occurrences of a but now we have four
occurrences of a but what the search
engine is going to recognize is these
first three is and it's going to see
okay so there are three occurrences of a
and I already have a match it's not
going to consider this fourth a in the
search it will just look at the first
three and say okay there are uh Three
A's and my my match is fine so again
there are two matches in this case again
if you're going to use the search
function initially and you can see each
in each of the cases there is a match
except for the first case which is this
case now let's see the find all option
and see what happens when we do the same
thing using find all
so when we use find all it basically
gives us each of the instances where the
match has occurred in each of these
lists
now let's try to use a slightly more
complicated example where we combine
different let's say different meta
characters and we create a a more
sophisticated expression that we want to
search in our test strings so if you
look at this expression what we're
looking for is 0-9 now a dash symbol is
valid in Python using regex because what
this basically tells it is that it's
looking for either 0 1 2 3 4 so on until
nine basically any of the digits you're
looking for any of the digits from 0 to
9 and we are going to check if at least
2 and at most four occurrences of digits
if they are there or not in our
particular code so let's see what are
the matches that happens when we use it
on test strings so if you use it on this
string you can see it will find one
match this basically this particular
part of the string where it says one two
three so this is uh three occurrences of
Digit so it's fine now when we look at
this whole string 12 and whatever this
is you will see this will not find a
match here this obviously will not
because these are characters but if you
look at over this part it will find
matches in the in terms of the first
four and then seven and three the next
two one and two again there are no
matches because there's only single
occurrences of digits we're looking for
at least two and at most four so if I
use a find all
you will see like whatever it will
return so for the first test string what
is going to return me is it's going to
return me one two and three as you can
see here but now if you look at this
test string it's going to return me 12
it's going to return Me 3 4 5 and 6.
it's going to return me three four one
and two but not seven because we are
looking for at least two and then it's
going to return me four five six and
seven followed by eight and eight as you
can see in this list over here now if we
use curly braces with only one digit
it's basically telling the search engine
that we want exactly so many repetitions
of the preceding uh whatever expression
that we have so when we do this example
for uh for example we're basically
saying that we want uh X
followed by a dash and the dash has to
occur at least three times in our
particular expression and then it should
be followed by an X again which will not
match in this case because there are
only two dashes and it will match in
this case because there are exactly
three dashes and it will again not not
match in this case because there are
four dashes
as you can see here none followed by an
object Maps followed by none
next we move on to the alternation
um the alternation meta character and as
the word suggests alternation is
basically looking for some alternate
form of A and B so a should be followed
by a b and basically this pattern has to
keep going on so in the first string
over here this pattern will not match in
the second string over here we will have
a match because we at least find an a
even though there is no B but this is
still considered Mass because we did
find an a at least over here we'll have
three matches because we have a followed
by a b followed by an a again so uh if
we did a regular expression for this we
would basically find these many matches
for each of these examples
the next meta character is the group now
a parenthesis is basically used to group
sub patterns so let's look at an example
to understand what we mean now if you
look at this complicated expression what
this means is that I want some form of x
and z the x and z have to occur together
but before that what I want is some form
of a following B following C some sort
of alternation between a b and c so this
part as you can see here is kept in a
parenthesis because I want this whole
condition to basically occur before I
find an x and z so let's look at what
happens here in the first case we don't
have a match because uh the this
basically this parenthesis condition is
not being met we x and z is preceded by
a space or basically the A and B is
preceded is followed by a space so there
is this space didn't occur we would
actually find a match as you can see in
the next example here you can see A and
B occur basically this uh initial
condition is met followed by x and z so
then this way a one match so it's fine
for us now if you look at this Society
mode a trickier one what you can see is
we have two matches in this case first
in a followed by x and z and then we
have C A and B now this is perfectly
fine because we we are looking for a b
followed by an x and z we're looking for
either of these things we're looking for
some form of alternation of these things
followed by an x and z and we can get
that over here we get B followed by an x
and z so you will get two matches in
this case now let's go through the
concept of grouping constructs now that
we've seen many meta characters you've
seen how parenthesis Works let's look at
grouping constructs so grouping
constructs break up a regex in Python
into sub expressions or groups and this
serves two purposes one is a grouping
part which basically says that a group
represents a single syntactic entity and
any additional meta characters apply to
the entire group as a unit and then
there's the capturing part which
basically tells us that some grouping
constructs also capture the portion of
the search string that matches the sub
expression in the group you can retrieve
captured matches later through several
different mechanisms so let's look at
basically what we mean by this example
over here so if you see this this
expression has a plus sign so we're
looking for uh as you know a plus looks
for one or more occurrence so this will
basically check for one or more
occurrence of the the character are only
because there's no parenthesis as in
this example so this plus is next to an
r and it's going to check for basically
whether one or more occurrence of R
happens uh preceding b and a but if we
actually put B A and R in a parenthesis
followed by plus it will actually check
for the entire string bar and it will
check one or more occurrences of bar
together so if you look at the these two
examples when we use this uh on these
examples you can see that these are fine
like these matches are fine but if I
used this parenthesis then these would
be the acceptable matches and like b a
triple R would not be a match if I use
parenthesis as you can see here
so this is how grouping constructs work
and how parent thesis work so let's look
at some other examples so what this will
do is Foo has to be optionally followed
by bar and bar must exist over together
and
um this is because we have a question
mark here this question mark symbol
tells us that it should be zero or one
occurrences
similarly this particular completed
expression is checking for one or more
occurrences or whatever we saw earlier
basically this whole thing is followed
by a plus so we're looking for this
whole sequence for one or more
occurrences of it c o w is simply just
cow we're looking for this pattern and
this is going to check for 0 or 1
occurrence of cow because of the
existence of the question mark for
preceded by the parenthesis
in this video we're going to continue
our discussion on regular Expressions
now that you know the basics of regular
Expressions let's continue our
discussion with special sequences now in
an earlier video on strings you might
have encountered what is an escape
sequence and how we use the backslash
character to generate these Escape
sequences and an escape sequence is
basically if you remember
something that we use to either
gives a certain special meaning to
characters that are otherwise ordinary
or it is used to remove the special
meaning that are inherently present in
certain characters that we call Meta
characters so let's look at what special
sequences are in relation to regular
expressions
so the first one we're going to look at
is the backslash capital A which is used
to match if specified characters are at
the present are present at the start of
a string so out here if you can see we
are checking if the word d is present in
these two strings so we would get a
match in the first case over here
because this starts with the word the
but in the second case we won't get a
match and this is how we're going to
check it for the same thing using the
find all function
so if you see in the first case it gives
us it returns us an object because we do
find the in the beginning of the string
in the second case we get us empties
list because this string does not start
with the word t
now the next one that we'll look at is
backslash B small B now this is used to
match if specified characters at the
beginning or at the end of a word so
when you use backslash small B and then
you follow it up with whatever you're
looking for it would look for the that
particular those particular characters
or that pattern if it exists in the
beginning of a word in a string so if
you look at the first example it starts
with f double O and in the second
example you see this portion of the
string or this word is actually also
starting with f double O so it will also
match however in this string which is
very similar to the second one we don't
have a space between a and F and it's
basically one word so this does not
start with f double O but it actually
starts with afo and it won't match as
you can see here now similarly if we
wanted to check if something exists in
the back of a string at the end of a
string we type what we want to search
for first and then we follow it with a
backslash small B and then if you see
here it will match in this first case it
will match in the second case because
this part of the string ends with f
double O but it will not match in this
case because well we remove the space so
now this whole thing becomes a uh the
string that we're looking for and it
does not end with FW anymore this is
basically us just checking in through
the find all function now the next SK
the next special sequence that we will
be looking at is the slash capital B
which is basically the opposite of what
we just saw this matches only if the
specified characters are not at the
beginning or the end of a word so if you
see here this is checking if F double O
is not at the beginning of these strings
so in this case there will be a no match
in this case also it will be a no match
and this third case there will be a
match similarly if we wanted to see if
something does not end with a particular
string we would type type that whatever
pattern we're looking for followed by a
backslash capital B and then we can use
the find all function to generate as
lists wherever we find such objects find
such matches in our particular test
strings like we have done over here so
the next one that we're going to look at
is the backslash small D and this
matches any decimal digit which is
equivalent to doing a square brackets
0-9
as you've seen you must have seen
earlier so if we did a square bracket
0-9 and we did a search or a find all or
a match it would look for any of the
digits between 0 and 9. so a similar
thing can be done using a special
sequence backslash small D so as you can
see there will be three matches in this
case because one two and three digits
exist whereas in this case for the word
python there will be no matches
so these are certain examples where we
are doing the same thing using the
backslash d
now we have another one which is the
backslash capital D and this is just
basically the opposite it matches for
any non-decimal digits it's also
equivalent to typing a carrot inside uh
square brackets with 0-9 which if you
remember from the previous video is
basically asking us to check for
anything that is not the digit 0 to 9.
so this is basically we're going to
check these two strings if there is no
digits no non-decimal digits so if you
see here we will we will find three
matches a b and the uh double double
inverted commas and in the second string
we will find no matches because this is
fully just did this next we have
backslash small s now this matches where
a string contains any white space
character so this is equal to doing a
check for all of these so this is like
backslash small T is a check for tab
space backslash small N is a check for
break line and then backslash R
backslash F backslash V uh are their own
uh checks for different sorts of white
space characters that you can see by
just looking it up honestly but yeah so
if you simply do a backslash s it would
actually be the equivalent of searching
for any of these uh whites Place White
space characters that we generate
so if you see here when we do a
backslash s on this string you can see
that there is one space over here so it
will match it will give us one match
because there is one white space which
is just the normal space here and in the
second example there is no match because
there is no white space here
similarly slash capital S now as you
might have noticed is basically checking
for a string which does not matches in a
string wherever there is no white space
characters so it's basically the same as
doing carrot slash T slash n slash r
slash F slash V in a square brackets so
this is basically a simpler way of doing
uh the same thing using square brackets
and a carrot symbol so if you see this
expression backslash capital S now we're
looking at a space b so over here if you
see it will match for all the non-spaces
so it's going to match for a and b so
we're going to get two matches here
whereas an empty string does not contain
well it does not contain any non-white
space character since an empty string is
basically a white space character on its
own so this would be this will give us a
no match so the next special sequence
that we're going to look at is the
backslash small W uh this matches any
alphanumeric character which is the
equivalent of doing a to z in small and
then capital A to Z and 0 to 9 for and
also an underscore check in square
bracket it's it's important to note that
the underscore is considered an alpha
memory character hence why we included
over here but yeah this is this uh
backslash W uh small W which basically
checks for uh any alphanumeric character
and matches it in a string so if you see
in this first case
um it will find three matches at one two
and also at the letter c these others
are not alphanumeric characters whereas
in this string none of these are
alphanumic characters we will get no
match again much like the other examples
there is a capital there's a backslash
capital W which will check for any
non-alphanumeric character and it's the
equivalent of doing whatever we did
before in uh in the square brackets just
with a preceded by a carrot sign so if
you see here we have the string where we
have a bunch of characters well yeah
only one of them this uh this percentage
symbol is a non-alphanumeric character
so we will get much one match over here
but in this case in the string python we
will get no matches because they are all
alphanumeric characters which is doing
the same thing here with a bunch of
different examples using the find all
function now the backslash capital Z
matches if the specified characters are
at the end of a string now don't confuse
this with the backslash small B because
the back is a small B checks for a
string and it checks each and every word
in the string individually and checks if
so if any of the words ends with a
particular thing or or starts with a
particular thing but it checks each word
individually but in this case the
backslash capital Z will check the
string only and not each word so if you
see the difference here in an um when
you use Capital backslash capital Z it
will match in this first example but it
won't match for the next two but if you
use the backslash small B over here it
would actually match and not only in the
first example here but it will also
match in the second example because it
would check this word individually and
it will find out that yeah there is a
match here as well so it would actually
match in the second example as well in
this video we will be covering the topic
of closures now before we understand
what a closure is we have to understand
what is a nested function and non-local
variables now a function which is inside
another function is known as a nested
function nested functions are able to
access variables of the enclosing scope
so if I Define this function called
outer function where I pass some
argument called text and I store that in
a variable called text again and if I
create a function within this collinear
function and I want to print whatever
this variable is in text when I execute
this it will be able to access this
variable because it's within the
enclosing scope so if I set out a
function here this gets stored in the
variable text and then the inner
function will print that variable which
is basically the string here as you can
see here
now inner function can easily be
accessed inside the outer function body
but not outside of its body so here
inner function is treated as a nested
function which uses text this this
variable text as the non-local variable
now a closure is a function object that
remembers values in enclosing Scopes
even if they are not present in memory
it is a record that stores a function
together with an environment it's a
mapping basically that Associates each
free variable of the function which are
basically variables that are used
locally but are defined in enclosing
scope with the value or reference to
which the name was bound when the
closure is created a closure which is uh
which unlike a plane function allows the
function to access those captured
variables through the closures copies of
their values or references even when the
function is invoked outside the scope so
let's look at an example to emphasize on
what what was just said so again I've
created amplify this function out of
function where I'm doing the same thing
now I've defined the same inner function
where I'm going to print the same thing
now it's very important that when I
return over here what I'm going to
return is inert function but it's not
going to be a function call this is
important to create our closure so we
return in our function but with without
um using the call as we do over here
now what this return will do is
basically to create the enclosure sorry
the closure where the inner function
will remember the values of the
variables stored in the enclosing scope
so now I'm going to store this outer
function in an object called my in a
variable called my function now when I
call this my function you can see there
there'll be two things that are
happening here so once I've defined this
and I've executed this
what happens out here is this function
has already executed and then I'm
storing it to this but because I've done
return inner function without
parenthesis I've created a closure
basically and this closure allows the
inner function to remember the values
that were stored in text at any point at
and at every Point even after the
execution of this fun time so when I
execute this again for the second time
over here it will remember the value
that was stored in the variable text
which is hey which was which was given
over here that's why you see when I
execute it for the second time over here
the first time being in this line when
I'm storing it in my function when I
execute in the second time again it will
give me the result of hey
as you can see the closures have to
invoke functions outside the scope the
functional function has a scope only
inside the outer function but with the
user closures we can extend its scope to
invoke a function outside the scope so
now let's look at this code so this code
don't worry about what's going on here
just know that what we are doing here is
we have two functions which we Define
called add X and Y which will return X
Plus Y and the subtract function which
will subtract X and Y so now we're going
to execute these once we are going to
execute the add over here and add logger
and we're going to execute the subtract
function and we're going to store it in
sublogger so technically we have already
executed these two functions but now
since I've created an X an enclosure
basically uh if you see here this is the
enclosure that I have created now what
happens is
when I access this function from outside
its initial scope which is basically
over here this was the initial Scope
when I access it outside you will see
that it it is it still has access to
these variables X and Y so if you see
here I I first of all I've allowed this
uh this the enclosing function to accept
uh arguments of any numbers so I can
pass X Y I can pass x y z also but if
you see here I won't I only have a thing
for X and Y so
when I want to access any value of X and
Y even after the execution of this code
initially I have access to these
variables X and Y and that is because
I've created a closure out of that so if
you see if I do add logger 3 and 3 over
here I am able to get the result 6. if I
do add logger 4 and 5 I'm able to get
the result nine similarly for
subtraction logger 10 and 5 I will get 5
here and 20 and 10 I'll get 10 here and
I can keep doing this I can keep saying
ad logger in fact if I say 4 and 7 so if
I executed this and now I'm going to say
let's say for example add logger if I
set 4 and 7 here
so this still has access to my variables
X and Y because I've created the closure
and it should give me 11. similarly if I
did sublogger say 30 and 15 it should
give me 15 because 30 minus 15. so let's
say 30 minus 16 right so it should give
me 14 because again I have created the
closure and it has access to these
variables already in this video we will
be learning about the concept of Lambda
functions now a Lambda function in
Python is an anonymous function without
a name we usually use Lambda functions
whenever we want to create a a function
type object for for a short period of
time a Lambda function is defined using
the Lambda keyword like a normal
function is defined using the def
keyword we Define a Lambda function
using the Lambda keyword also the Lambda
function can take any number of
arguments but it can only accept one
expression as a part of it so think of a
Lambda function like a sort of a a
temporary function object that you
create whenever you want to perform a
particular task or object but you don't
want to give it a name or you don't want
to define a full a full-blown function
and give it a name like that so over
here I'm going to give you an example of
a Lambda function let's say that this
Lambda function takes in let's call it X
and so you define the function let's
call it X let's call it a Lambda
function using this keyword now we want
say two parameters right
by saying say A and B or two arguments A
and B so we're going to pass two
arguments A and B whenever we call use
this function and we're going to perform
some sort of an expression now let's
write down a simple arithmetic
expression for this once you've defined
your arguments
you just use the colon now over here we
have our expression so let's call it a
plus b so now we've created a Lambda
function called X where uh we will pass
two arguments and the result will be the
expression a plus B A Plus A and B being
the arguments we pass
so now let's print the result of
um let's say we pass one and three so
now we should get the result 4 right
because a plus b is equal to 4 so we
passed a as 1 bs3 now let's execute this
as you can see the result is for
similarly you can pass any number of
arguments so we want to call some
function X
um let's say Lambda function maybe say
um a
B and C the same and we want to do the
product of these three arguments
so now when we do uh when we check the
result let's say we're doing the product
of two four and six so this should be 48
and when you execute this you get 48 as
you can see here so these are two simple
examples of a Lambda function
now I could have done this um in a
different way where I could have defined
some function X and over here I Define
that it takes in three parameters and
then you can Define
um some say return the function
basically returns you a product B
product C but many a times you don't
need to define a full function called X
you don't you don't want to assign some
function with this name you just want to
create a temporary or a short time
Anonymous function with some name just
to perform a simple expression and in
that case we can use Lambda functions
that's an example by the way you can use
Lambda functions in multiple places so
let's uh move on now
now uh for the sake of this video what
I'm going to do is I'm going to show you
how the sorted function works and we're
going to learn how the Lambda function
uses this sorted function how they work
together so this will give you a clearer
understanding of how we use the Lambda
function in our code so to start off
sorted function returns a sorted list
from the items in an interval so you can
have a bunch of for example numbers and
the sorted function by default will give
you will return you the list of numbers
in an ascending order of course you can
also using a parameter called reverse
you can you can you can return a list of
numbers in the descending order you can
also do this for Strings uh I mean
characters so if you give it a bunch of
characters say a e f g in the uh in the
alphabet it will give you if you use a
sorted function it'll give you the
characters it will return it in an
ascending or descending order depending
on the parameter you give so basically
this uh the sorted function the syntax
is you use the keyword sorted then you
pass the iterable which is basically
some some list or some Tuple then you
give it a key so this key sometimes we
don't need to give by default if the
iterable is does not contain um multiple
uh multiple items per object for like if
it's not a tuple of multiple objects if
it's not a list of tuples for example
you don't need to give it a key if it's
a simple list of numbers you don't
necessarily need to give a key if you
want to sort it but yeah a key is
basically the parameter which we use to
tell the sorted function that we want to
sort based on something which is going
to be the key in this case finally the
third parameter is reverse which
basically just tells us that if we want
to sort in the default ascending order
or if we say reverse true then we will
sort in the descending order now let's
look at some examples so I have this
list over here
and I'm going to print this list
so uh this list is obviously a bunch of
vowels
e-a-u-o-i and this is not in the
ascending order of the the alphabet
right like we we know it as a e i o u if
I print the sorted form of this list it
should give me a e i o u a list with
aeio in the ascending order
sorry yeah so now as you can see
um it's given me this list as you can
see here similarly if um I gave it a
string a string as you know is an
iterable it's a collection of characters
so if I use a sorted function on this
interestingly it will give me a list of
these
um individual characters like p y t h o
and n but in the order that we want it
to be in which is the ascending order of
course so if I print this you can see it
returns me the list with each character
in the order that we wanted it to be in
now you might notice why does p come
before H that's because this is in
uppercase so what this does is first it
uh sorts all the uppercase characters uh
since there's only one so it just places
in the first uh object of this list and
then it sorts all the lowercase
characters that you see here so yeah
moving on now now what if we wanted to
say um sort this in descending order so
we have this list and now we want to
sort this in a descending order so in
that case we have to give the parameter
reverse and we have to assign the value
true so once we do this now when we
execute this you can see we have the
return as the same list but in the
opposite order so that's how the reverse
parameter works now let's uh try to
understand how we use the key function
or the key parameter in the sorted
function now of course if you if you
want to sort something based on some key
that we want to Define we use the key
parameter so let's take an example now
so in this example what we have done is
I've defined this function called take
second so what this does is it it simply
it takes the second element of a list of
tuples so what is this list of tupus
well this is random you can see this
random this is a list of tuples so this
is one Tuple this is the next Tuple and
what I'm going to do is in this example
I'm going to create a key out of every
second element in each Tuple so I'm
going to create a key out of 20 40 10
and 13 and based on these in an
ascending order I will sort this whole
list so my what my result should be is
that since the smallest of the uh every
second object in these tuples is 10 so
this will be my first object in the my
sorted list then it should be the one
with 13 because this is the next highest
number so then this will be the next
object similarly this will be the next
object then this will be the whole next
object so you see I'm using every second
element of the Tuple as my key and for
that to create a key basically
um I'm creating this function which will
basically return every
um it will iterate through all of these
and it will return uh each of these
second elements so
um let's actually uh let's actually do
this now so what I have here is I am
going to create a sorted list which is
going to use a sorted function on this
iterable which is a bunch which is a
list of tuples it's called random now my
key is going to be take second so this
sorted function is actually very dynamic
in the sense
um I don't I don't exactly have to
create a list directly each of these
objects present in the tuples I just
have to Define if I can even pass a
function in the parameter for key and it
will apply this function on the interval
that we pass over here which is random
namely and it will use this function to
generate Keys uh generate a key out of
each second element and based on that it
will do the sorted it will perform the
sorted function so now
if I check
what's my sorted list
you will see
that as I had mentioned now it's using
the second object so the second uh each
each second object of the Tuple as the
key so since 10 is the smallest this
whole object is the first object then 13
so we have this object here and then so
on and so forth so this is how we've
used a key to do the Sorting function a
key that we've defined on our on our own
now similarly we can use multiple Keys
as well so just to quickly go over
through this uh we have this
um some some list where a bunch of names
a bunch of tuples you can see right
tuples with three objects each within it
each first one is always always a string
denoting someone's name some students
name
um the second is the marks out of 100
and the third is their age so what we
have here is what we want to do is we
want to sort this uh these tuples uh in
the order of first marks and in case the
marks are clashing or they are the same
basically we will sort by the age so
what we want to do is we want to First
sort by these marks as you can see here
but in case the Clash for example like
say this 75 and 75 they're the same
marks in that case we want to sort it by
the age which is 12 and 20 which is
different so in this case we're going to
use two keys one the first key will be
given the highest priority and then if
there is a clash then we use the second
key so how do we do this now let's
define some function like uh how we
Define this take second function here
this will be our function that we will
pass to the key this function basically
what it does is it gives us uh who has
the highest marks now since we are
creating and since the key works in an
ascending order so um the smallest
object in a key is the first object that
gets returned right so what we're going
to do is we're going to return the error
which is basically the difference
between
um 100 which is the total marks and the
marks that student gets so this is how
we obtain a ascending order in our list
which is what we which which basically
is what we want because we want the
highest marks to be first so we do 100
minus item one item one is basically the
first object or whatever it triple we
pass in this case it would be the the
first objects of each Tuple which is the
marks secondly We performed age age is
the item two which is yeah each second
object of each Tuple now what we return
in this function is uh like this is
going to be our key now a list of errors
and the list of age error being the
marks error the difference between 100
and the marks you obtain so now what
it's going to do is it's going to take
the marks as the first key and the age
as the second key when we pass this to a
sorting function
so uh if you skip this you don't have to
look at this but if you look at this now
we have the sorted list which is going
to be the result of the sorted function
on top of what we pass which is the
participant list now we're going to use
the key we're going to use the key as
the sorter function so we're going to
use this order function as a key and
when we print if you see
we get let me just execute all of this
so if you see here in this section what
you can see is we have the highest marks
first then the second then the third but
if you see here there's a clash this guy
and this guy have the same Mark 75 so
now what you want to do is the guy who
has a younger age should be in the first
in the object so that is how this has
happened because we've passed two keys
error and the age so when The Clash in
error key happened we went to the ah key
and then we did ascending order on that
and then finally the rest of the objects
that you can see here so now that we
have seen how the sorted function works
now let's look at how the Lambda
function Works using this sorted
function which was the main goal of this
video right so let's see
so now some of you might have figured
out where this Lambda function will be
used right so whenever we were using the
key in the sorted function we had to
define a function and then we would pass
that function as the key so as some of
you may have figured this out what we're
going to do using the Lambda function is
we're going to skip that process of
defining a function with a new name and
all that and we're going to pass a
Lambda function we're going to use a
Lambda function as the key so let's see
how we do it so initially what we've
done is we've created this list this
list is a list of dictionaries that you
can see so this first object is a
dictionary second object is a dictionary
each dictionary contains two keys the
name and the age and the values are
something like nandini the values for
age is like 20 20 and 19. so we have
three dictionaries in a list so what
we're going to do is we want to print
what we what we want to do with this we
want to print the these objects or these
dictionaries
in an ascending order of age so we want
obviously we want this to be first and
then this and this because 19 is smaller
than 20. so let's see how we do this
so if you go here
what we're going to do is we're going to
print the sorted the sorted function or
the uh the result of the sorted function
being applied on this list so this is
awaitable now if you see here in the key
the key parameter we don't we don't
predefine a function and pass it over
here instead we use the Lambda and this
Lambda function is defined in such a way
so we say Lambda it will take one
argument I and then it will return
basically the age index for some I and
this I is we we're going to presume an i
to be some sort of an iterable which has
an index called age and which is uh
which is the case in our case right we
have a bunch of dictionaries where there
is a key in each of these dictionaries
called age so we're going to use that
and now you're going to ask like what is
I well when we use the Lambda function
in the sorted function this I will
basically be each object that we get
when we iterate upon this list so we are
going to iterate first on this so it's
going to take this dictionary and is
going to search for the age then it's
going to take this it's going to search
for the age then it's going to take this
and it's going to search for the age and
each of the time it will pull out what
is the value for each of these age
keywords or these age indexes or age
keys and out of these objects so 20 20
and 19 or these values we're going to
create a key with which we're going to
sort each object in this whole list okay
so this is how the Lambda function will
work here so let's do this so as you can
see our sorted list now contains this
object first because a 19 is small stage
and then this and this now you might see
that there are two twenties so how do we
control which one comes first well by
default it will um that it will just uh
give us the result in the way we passed
it in the original list so since nandini
came before manjit in the result also
nandini will come before majeed but what
if he wanted to sort it even more what
if we want to sort it in such a way that
first we go by age and the second key
will tell us that if there is a clash in
ages we have to go alphabetically by the
name so in this case we will create a
second key and how we do that
well if you go to this step
over here what we're doing is we're
doing the same sorted function but now
the Lambda will again take one parameter
which is I which is going to be each Ito
which which is going to be each object
in this iterable list and we're going to
take two keys so the first key will be
the ah key and the second key will be
the name so it will first sort on age
and then on name so now if you see
um the result should be that manjeet
will come before nandini even though the
ages are 20 because M comes before n in
the alphabet as you can see this is the
result
now if we wanted to do the same thing
but in a descending order all we have to
do is after this key parameter we have
to give another parameter called reverse
and we have to give it true
so if we did this now you see this this
uh or if we do it on this one
to be more clear
now if I execute this basically this
whole uh whatever result we get will be
backwards now
oh wait I did not enter it in the sorted
function
so this should come within the sorted
function over here
so now if we execute this you will see
nandini comes first manjit comes second
and then nickel comes third because
we've done the reverse I will use the
reverse keyword as true reverse
parameter is true in this video we will
be covering the topics of map filter and
reduce functions in Python now python
provides several functions that enable
functional approach to programming and
since functional programming is all
about Expressions some of these
expression oriented functions of python
are Lambda functions list comprehensions
map filter map filter and reduce now
we've already covered the topic of
Lambda and list comprehensions now let's
cover the topics of map filter and
reduce
so to start off let's look at the map
function the map function takes in two
attributes a function and a sequence a
function is basically some defined some
user defined function or any function a
sequence is basically an iterable object
like a list or a tuple for example or a
bunch of lists and tupacles as well so
let's look at an example so one of the
most common operations that we do with
something like a list is doing an
operation on each of the elements in the
list and then outputting a new list with
the the values as whatever we have
modified to the original items of the uh
list so we what if we did the square of
all of these items in this list and we
we want to create a list based on that
so we can basically iterate through it
and we can do a square function and then
append those values to a new list called
squared and when we do this for example
over here you can see when we print
squared
we should get the list of whatever
Square values we have for the original
list but this is uh slightly a bit
tedious and what if we had a method that
or a
what if we had a a technique wherein we
could um
basically pass a function that we have
that we want to do and a sequence on
which we want to apply this and we pass
it to a function and this function
basically takes care of applying
whatever operations we want to do on
each element of a sequence so as this is
where the map function comes in use so
let's look at how we use the map
function over here so if you look at
this I have defined a square function so
the square function basically returns or
takes an argument X and Returns the
square of it and I have a map function
which takes the square function as one
of the arguments and the I the list or
an iterable as the second argument so
this map function creates a map object
if you see here so let's just do it one
by one so I'm creating my list and I'm
going to create my function called
Square and I'm going to
send this to the map function so I'm
sending this uh the first argument as
the function that I want to do and the
second argument as the list that I want
to apply it on now let's list out all
the items that are in this map object
so if you see it creates me a list with
basically the squared items and this is
exactly what we needed and another way
of doing the same thing would be just
going through a for Loop in each of the
map objects and printing each which
would give me the same results so if you
see here I found a very neat way of
passing a function at an iterable and
using the map function to apply each
operation that is part of the function
or applying the function on each item in
the iterable so as you've seen we
basically passed in a user defined
function and we applied it to each item
in the list then the map calls the
square function on each list item and
collects all the return values into a
new list and because map expects a
function to be passed in it also happens
to be one of the places where Lambda
functions are appearing a lot so let's
look at the an example where we do the
same operation using a Lambda function
so if you see here I have a Lambda
function where I am passing it as the
function argument and what this Lambda
function takes is some variable X or
some argument X it does its square and
it returns at X and this x is basically
going to come from each element that is
present in this list called items and
when we list down these you will see it
basically does the same thing for us it
creates this list with squared items now
we can also pass instead of passing an
interval itself we can actually pass a
sequence of functions and use the Lambda
function to perform a sequence of
functions on particular items so let's
look at a new example a slightly
different one so we're going to use a
numpy module for this don't worry we're
just using it to use the square root
function that is present in the numpy
parameter module
um we will be learning about number in a
later section so we're going to import
this first and now I'm going to Define
three functions cos Square Cube and
square root so once I've defined this
basically they are returning the square
the cube root uh the cube and the square
root of some integer X and now I'm going
to create a list of these functions that
you've just seen and we're going to use
the for Loop and we're going to iterate
through a range from 0 to 4. so and
we're going to pass this
and we're going to say that we're going
to apply
some sum function we want to apply some
function X and we want to return that
using the snapdraw function now what
values this x will take is based on
whatever functions we've stored in this
variable called f u n c s or funks and
in funcs we have a bunch of functions
called Square Cube and square root that
we have defined earlier so what we're
going to do is we're going to apply each
of these functions to R and R will take
the value 0 to 4 and now let's see when
we print this what values we get so if
you see here we get a list of square
root squares cubes and square roots for
integer 0 1 2 3 and 4. so this is
another way of using the map function
and Lambda functions together to apply
multiple different operations to a bunch
of iterables
now for our next example what we're
going to do is we're going to create a
function that basically what it does is
it creates the uppercase of some string
that we pass to it right so that's what
we've done here in this function called
two uppercase so if let's first Define
this function now we have a print
function basically which is going to
print each object in a particular which
is going to prevent each element of a
particular object and it's going to at
the end of it and the end of printing
we're going to give a small space for
printing a new line basically so let's
create this also this print it editor
object now what we're going to do is
we're going to pass a string with the
letters a b and c to this function and
we're going to map and we're going to
apply the uppercase function to this
string now if you remember string is
also an iterable where it's a sequence
of one character strings so this whole
string is basically a sequence of one
character string a one character string
B and C so we're going to so we can pass
a string as a as an iterable to the map
function because it will apply the
operations on each of these characters
so let's see what happens when we do the
uppercase function uh we apply the upper
uppercase function using the map using
mapping to this string a b and c
so if you see it's created me a list
with a capital a capital B and capital c
as we had expected because we have
applied the list function to the map
object now in The Next Step what we're
going to do is we're going to do a very
similar thing we're just going to
instead of Simply mapping and creating a
list out of it we're going to store the
map object in a variable called map
iterator we're going to print what type
of object it is and then we're going to
print out each of the elements using the
print iterator function that we defined
here so let's do this now if you see the
class the type of object is of class map
and the objects elements inside the
object are a b and c Moving On Let's uh
let's look at now an example where we're
going to pass multiple arguments so
instead of one iterable we're going to
pass multiple iterables now and we're
going to apply some sort of an operation
so if you see here what we have done is
we've created Tool uh two two sequences
one is a list of some numbers and
another is a tuple of some numbers so
just to show you let me first copy this
here
um yeah so if you see here I have a list
and a tuple and I'm passing both of
these if you see to this map function
and before that I have defined a Lambda
function as the operation that I'm going
to apply and what this does is it takes
two arguments X and Y and it Returns the
product of both of these uh where does
it get X and Y from so the X it gets
from this uh this sequence which is a
list and it takes y from this sequence
which is a tuple so what it's going to
do is going to take X as 1 and then Y is
5 in the first step and it's going to
return the product S5 and then the next
step is going to take 2 as X and then y
as 6 and it's going to return the
product of that and we're going to get
12 and so on we're going to get 21 and
then 32.
um when we did and this is these values
are going to be stored in the map
iterator which is a map type object and
when we use the print data function it's
basically going to print out whatever
results we got through this mapping so
let's execute this and as you can see
this is the result we got 5 12 21 and 32
which is what we wanted so the next part
the next function that we're going to
discuss is the filter function now now
my filter function is basically again it
takes two two arguments a function and a
sequence and a function basically tests
if each element of a sequence is true or
not now a sequence the sequence so this
filter function will basically take two
arguments so one is the function and
this function is basically going to test
if each element of a sequence is true or
not and it's going to take another
argument called sequence and this
argument sequence is the list or the
Tuple or basically any sequence and or
iterable that needs to be filtered and
it can be as I mentioned it can be sets
less tuples or containers of more
iterators and what this function will
return is an iterator that is already
filtered um so let's look at an example
now so we have this list R which you
generated which is basically numbers
from -5 to 4. so if I create this list
here you can see it will create a list
of minus five to four now if I wanted to
extract only the values that are lesser
than 0 well I can use a for Loop and use
a if condition to check this right so if
I did this over here you can see it
gives me it returns me some list called
result which contains only the values
lesser than zero which is basically
check through this condition what if
there was a
neat or a more convenient or a more
organized approach to doing the same
thing instead of creating a loop
ourselves what if we defined a function
where we are going to do the test or if
we are going to create the condition and
we're going to pass this to a particular
function and then apply that particular
operation on every object of some
sequence well just like mapping we have
a filter function to do this and in this
example what we're going to use is the
Lambda function which takes an argument
X and it checks for some condition X
lesser than 0 and where it's going to
get the X from if some sequence R which
which in our case is the numbers from
minus five to four and the filter will
basically create a filter object type
which contains only the objects from r
that meet this condition that is X is
lesser than 0 and when we use the list
operation on top of it it you will see
it creates it results in a list with the
values that have met my condition so for
a second example what we're going to do
is we're going to create a list which
contains a bunch of letters and we're
going to only extract the vowels from
these bunch of letters so let's look at
what we have here we have some letters d
a t j k o p l and we only want the
vowels from this so we want to filter
only the vowels so we can use that using
the filter function by first of all
defining a function that returns true if
a check is met that um
one of uh the letter matches one of
these letters in this list called
letters and if it doesn't it returns
false so this is an urban condition that
we've created once we create this
condition uh this function that checks
this we can pass this function and the
sequence into the filter function and
then we can list out whatever we get so
you can see our filtered list contains
only a and o which is basically the only
vowels that are present in our original
list
finally we have the reduce function this
reduce function is basically a func
tools it's in the func tools module of
python 3.0 and what the reduce function
does is it applies a function of two
arguments cumulatively to the elements
of an iterable and it optionally it
starts with an initial argument and it
returns a single result so let's first
import this function
and once we've imported it let's use it
in this example that we have here so in
this example what we're going to do is
we have some list called numbers right
what if we wanted to get the sum of each
element in this list well we can iterate
over it and store it in some variable
called total in each step right
um this is what we would typically
typically do and in this step what you
can see is the loop basically iterates
over every valuable in numbers and
accumulates them in total the final
result is the sum of all the values
which is the value of 10 over here in
this example the variable total is what
we call an accumulator and we can apply
the reduce function to do the same task
so how do we do it let's first of all
create a function called my ad where
we're going to take two variables uh two
arguments and we're going to return the
sum of it okay so let's define this
function and now we have we have our
list called numbers right which contains
one two three and four now let's do
reduce my add to numbers
now when I do this when I use this
function what it will do is it will
apply the function of my ad it will take
basically each and every element uh in a
sequence so it will take one and two
then add them together and then it will
create basically what it will do is it
will take one and two add them together
then we'll have three so it'll take
three and then the next element which is
3 again so it will create the sum which
is 6 and then it will take six and then
it will take the value 4 and it will
give us the result 10. so this is how
the reduce function would work so this
is how it will give us the result of 10.
as you can see here I've simply used
I've passed this function where I've
defined that I want two argument to be
passed to a function and then the return
should be basically the sum and then a
past a whole list of like four numbers
and I've used a reduced function to
basically do this process for four
numbers in a step-by-step manner by
taking two at a time subsequently and my
result is as you can see is correct as
you can see here
so let's use the Lambda function now to
do the same topic just do the same task
so what I'm doing now is I'm going to
define a Lambda function and that's the
function I'm going to pass to this
reduce so when I pass this Lambda
function which basically takes two two
arguments X and Y and it's going to
return the sum of that as X Plus y now
where it's going to get X and Y from is
in a very in a very neat manner so it
will take first the first two elements
one and two it will then do the sum and
we get three then it will take the same
three and then take the next object
which is 3 again and then give us 6 then
it will take six and then the next
element which is 4 and then give us 10
and then the reduce function will output
the the single result which is 10 to us
as you can see here
in this video we will be covering a sort
of a project side type of scenario which
is basically going to be a problem case
for you and it's going to be slightly
slightly difficult slightly tricky but
what we're going to do is we're going to
tackle a particular problem and we're
going to what I'm going to do is also
show you a solution to that problem
so let's start with this so this
question that we have is we have this
program that we have to write where we
compute the frequency of words that
exist in some input okay the program
should output after sorting the key
alphanumerically now this input can be
and it's basically a block of text right
so in our example we have for example if
this was our input right what we want to
see is an output which is basically
saying that the word python has appeared
say well in this example it's appeared
five times and then the word read has
appeared one time and so on and so forth
like for each of these words we want to
see um how many times have they appeared
in this project particular block of text
so let's look at a particular example
now where we have done this so let's um
let's see here
so first of all I'm going to create a
dictionary so why am I creating a
dictionary is because I'm going to use
each unique word as a key and the number
of times they have appeared in a block
of text as the value to that key so um
I'm going to use a sample string which
is basically this long string that you
can see here which is stored in line so
this large chunk of text is what we're
going to be analyzing so how are we
going to do this it's pretty simple so
we have this now what we want to do is
um when we find what we one way of
tackling this problem that we're going
to do here is we want to
um check word by word first of all you
want to see if it's a unique word and if
this word is before I encountered it for
the first time then we need to store a
new key here in our dictionary called
frequent table or frequency table and if
it has already if there is a key already
with that particular name then we just
want to increment the count or the value
by one so let's see how we do this over
here so if you can see in my this the
solution is as simple as this but if you
see what's happening it's basically what
uh what it's doing is we're splitting up
this string uh using the split function
what this will do is it will split up
the string at every white space so it
will take this as one part I'll take
this part as another part it will create
an iterable with each word as the um
each iterable object in that container
so it's going to be a list of words like
python is one so on and so forth and
we're going to go one by one so we're
going to say forward in line dot split
now if this word is if it exists in
frequency table as a key then what we're
going to do is we're just going to
increase the count of the value of that
key by 1 but if it does not exist then
we're going to actually create a key
with the word as that unique word and
we're going to create its value
initialize its value to 1
so let me execute this
now if we want to once you've done this
we can sort it by the count of the words
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a another Tuple called sorted
tuples where we're going to use the
Lambda function out here uh to sort the
dictionary in terms of its values so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the key the key being the Lambda
item item with index one index one is
basically the value
um so a particular key has a value so
the word python appears so many times
the word say scientist appears so many
times so we're going to check which
words have the highest number of
occurrences and we're going to sort it
in a descending order so that that is
basically what the reverse is equal to
True does so when we're going to sort
this when we are going to use the sorted
function when we say reverse true it
tells the Sorting function to sort this
dictionary this dictionary frequency
table uh in terms of value
by the the descending order so whichever
word appears highest that would be the
first word in our uh sorted Tuple so
that's what we do in this slide and once
we execute this we're also going to
print so if you see the result of this
activity that we've done you can see
that the word machine appears six times
learning appears six times then python
appears 510 and so on and so forth so
we've created a sorted Tuple where the
first object of the Tuple we've created
a list of sorted tuples where the first
object of the two each Tuple is the
unique word the second one is the number
of times it has appeared in this
particular example or this particular
string so yeah this was the first basic
project that we have tackled in this you
might have seen some examples of how we
do list operations and how we use the
Lambda function in sorting the
dictionary by the values of the key in
this video we will continue with what we
started in in terms of our project
number one what we're going to do is
we're going to tackle another slightly
complicated
um
a question or a situation we're going to
try to arrive at a solution so in this
what we have is some sort of a robot a
moving robot which moves on a Cartesian
plane a two coordinate plane
um is going to move in terms of up down
left and right okay and each each time
it moves up or down or left or right it
takes a certain number of steps in that
direction
um integral steps of course so what we
need to do is from a starting position
whatever its starting position is which
we are going to take as 0 comma 0 in
this example we're going to make it move
to a particular location with the
commands up down left and right followed
by certain steps and we're going to ask
what we're going to do is we're going to
calculate the distance between these two
points
um and we're going to calculate
different types of distances so you
might be introduced to New Concepts
um you know distance Concepts in this
video as well so what we're going to be
using for distance calculation is the
minkowski distance and that is we're
going to take so the minkowski distance
between two variables is basically the
absolute difference between these two
variables so these two points and we
take it to the power of something so if
we want to say uh calculate the
minkowski distance with in terms the
quadratic main cause citizens with
basically P2 so we are going to do x i
minus y i absolute difference to the
power 2 and then we're going to take the
second root of it after summing each and
every point so when we take p is equal
to 2 we we say the minkowski distance
behaves like the euclidean distance so
this is probably one of the most common
distances uh in case you've done basic
uh Cartesian geometry when you are asked
to find the distance between two points
on a plane
um we can also take the absolute
distance where we take p is equal to one
so in this case we're just basically
summing the absolute distances between
each point no roots no power is nothing
basically p is equal to one and because
that the Manhattan distance so we're
going to take p is equal to 1 to 1 3 in
each case and we're going to find the
distance between two points based on
these
measures so
this is just a visual representation
this is basically the Euclid resistance
basically the estimate of the value
between these two points if um since
this is a two coordinate system whereas
the Manhattan distance would be the
absolute distance in terms of if we go
up and then we go right between these
two like save this first and this was
another point so yeah let's move on to
the problem in this particular example
we are going to start from the static
position 0 and 0 on a on a graph and we
are going to give the commands of up
five down three left three and right two
so first of all what we want to do is we
initialize the starting position as 0
and 0 and we also just for the sake of
this example we initialize the end
position as 0 and 0. so what we're going
to do first of all is let's execute this
much now we have this list list of
tuples
um it's we're going to call this actions
and this is the actions that we're
performing so this the each Tuple
contains an action and the number of
steps in that direction so it contains
four actions up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps right by
two steps so now we're going to iterate
over this each Tuple and we're going to
get the direction first of all in this
line for each step uh and we're going to
calculate the number of steps it takes
so for each action it's going to first
tell
um it's going to check what is the
direction which is done by this line and
we're going to find out the number of
steps in that direction which is stored
in this line so
once you've gotten this for each action
we have to update the end position right
so what happens is if you go up by a
particular direction so you are
basically changing the y y axis right
the the y-axis so we're going to change
end position and the first index which
is basically this part of the end
position coordinate point so we're going
to say if it's moving by up then we're
going to uh update by adding uh the
y-axis by the number of steps so
um and and if the direction is down
we're going to do the same thing for the
y axis but we're going to decrement it
similarly if we move left or right we're
moving the x axis right so we take n
position in the first index so we take
the x axis and if we're moving left it's
a negative uh it's a decrement and if
you're moving right it's an increment so
if there's any other like action like
any other action for example that was
given here we say pass so basically the
only valid actions that we can pass is
um up down left and right otherwise we
we just skip that particular action so
this is what the this particular Loop
will do it will update our final
position
so once we've done this if we if I
execute this what will get stored in the
end position is basically my end
position so now that I have my starting
position and my end position
um just to show you what the end
Position will look like right now let's
just do this so if you see here after
I've moved up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps and then
right by two steps my final end position
is minus one and two
um my start position on the other hand
was
as you remember it should be 0 and 0. it
is 0 and 0. so now we're going to find
the distance between 0 and 0 and -1 and
2. so we're going to first of all create
a function called minkowski distance
which which does the basic function of
just calculate the uh the difference
between the what do you say the N
position x coordinate and the N position
y coordinate times or to the power of a
root and we're basically going to do
this operation that you saw here we're
going to do this and um we're going to
use this root variable to specify it to
like P is equal to one two or three like
what P value we want to take for this
minkowski distance so once we've done
this what this function will do is
basically store uh this much and it will
wait for us to uh it will basically wait
for us to give us a root so when we give
root 1 it will create these it will
check the distance between the end and
starting points
um with the p-value of one if you gave
it 2 it will calculate euclidean
distance with p-value 2 similarly for 3
and we can calculate for any Roots so
we're going to calculate for one two and
three roads and we're going to see what
values we get in each case
so when root is equal to 1 I print the
statement saying minkowski distance with
root 1 is something and then root 2 it's
something root 3 is something let's see
what results we get
so if you see here the minkowski
distance with root 1 is actually 1.0 but
the euclidean distance between these two
points is 2.23 whereas the uh the cubic
menkowski distance with basically the
with root 3 is 1.91 so you see these
three different uh distance measures for
the same distance between two coins so
in this video you basically so in this
basically by doing this activity you
might must have you will learn how to um
basically how to iterate through loops
and perform these distance calculations
which you'll find pretty handy in many
activities related to data science and
machine learning in this video we will
be continuing tackling different
problems and problem cases in terms of a
project called project three where we're
going to be using regular Expressions to
validate whether certain passwords that
have been entered do they match certain
criterias or not so let's look into our
particular question we have a website
that requires users to input username
and password to register now we have to
write a program to check the validity of
passwords input by the users now the
criterias that the passwords have to
follow are that there is at least one
letter between a and z and one number
between zero and nine uh the third
criteria is that uh there's at least one
letter between capital A and capital c
so this first and third Point basically
is saying that there should be one
lowercase letter and there should be one
uppercase letter now there should be at
least one character from dollar sign
hash or the at simple it should have a
minimum length of 6 and the maximum
length of 12. so when we whatever
passwords we enter into our example they
must be comma separated so if we're
going to have an input they're going to
ask us for an input where we're going to
have to input the different passwords in
a comma separated way so let's look
let's look at how do we tackle this so
for my example I'm going to use these
examples in terms of these are my
password examples if you're going to
check if these are valid passwords or
not so let's copy this first of all and
now let's import the re which import re
is basically the regular expression
module now in this step is going to ask
us to input the passwords as you can see
here so I will just Ctrl V so since this
is comma separated what it will do is it
will split up each of these uh by the
comma and it will store them in a list
so it will take this as one password
this has another password this has
another password and this has another
password once I press enter
now if I want to check what's in list I
mean what's in items what I can do is
just check over here what's the items
it's a list of whatever passwords I had
entered uh each object is separately
treated now in this list now I'm going
to create a an empty list called value
first of all once I've done that I'm
going to move on to the next step
so once I've created my list called
value what I'm going to do is now I'm
going to search and I'm going to check
for each condition using regular
expressions for whatever criteria that
we have initially so if you see here
what I'm going to do is first iterate by
each item in this to check for each
password now my first check will be a
basic check for the length of the
password if it's lesser than 6 or
greater than 12 then our basically our
password is illegal so we can't be using
this and we will just continue and we
won't check for anything else but if it
is within 6 and 12 the length 6 and 12
then we can continue with our check so
we can do we'll do an else statement for
pass which basically moves on to this
next block
now once you've done this what we will
do is this this first statement what
this is going to do is it's going to do
an re.search and re.search as you know
is going to look for at least one
instance of um
a letter occurring between
um A and Z so this re dot search
followed by this now this is the regular
expression that we have passed and what
this does us is basically the square in
the square brackets we're looking for
anything between uh A and Z in terms of
small letters so if this condition is
not met then again we continue and we
leave this particular search because one
of our criterias is not met all right
but if it is met then this if not
statement will not uh like we won't
enter this block and we can move on to
the next check so now now we move to L
if not now again we're using if not
statement so this is basically checking
for a negative case so anytime one of
these cases have been met it basically
means that our password has been invalid
because these conditions are not being
met so when we're trying to eliminate
all conditions all of these conditions
so that we get a valid password so again
we move on to the next statement which
is basically going to do the search for
numbers
once again if we find a case a password
without any numbers we continue and we
don't
um check this password no more because
we already know it's a it's a an illegal
password now next check will be for
capital letters a to z and the next
check again will be for these particular
symbols the dollar the hash and the at
one of these three symbols uh we're
going to search for a white space
character so if we actually do find a
white space character in our password
um that's an illegal password and we're
not going to continue checking for those
cases
so um so this is basically all our cases
lowercase letters numbers capital
letters these one of these three symbols
and the existence of a white space so
once you've done all these checks if
none of these have been passed we move
on to this else statement where we just
pass and what we can do is we append the
value P to the uh the list called value
so basically what happens is
um just to go through it again if this
condition is not met and this condition
is not met this is not met this is not
met this is not met and this is also not
met then we're fine so basically as long
as we have small letters as long as we
have a number as long as we have a
capital letter as long as we have one of
these three symbols and as long as we
don't have any uh White space characters
we can append e to this otherwise it
would continue and it will break out of
this for Loop completely that's what the
continued thing the continue statement
at the end of each of these blocks
checks any time this condition is met
this if not condition is met then we
break through we break through this
whole for Loop and we don't append t to
the value but uh if you actually get to
this stage then what we can do is simply
append uh P to value now finally what we
are going to do is we're going to print
out all the valid passwords so just by a
quick look you can see here this is a
valid password right so let's execute
this and let's see uh what we get if you
see here we only get one valid password
and let's look at why some of these do
not turn out to be valid so if you look
here all of the conditions are met it
has a capital letter it has a small
letter it has at least one number and it
has one of the symbols either dollar
sign or the hash sign or the add sign in
this case we have two white spaces one
over here and one over here so this is
an illegal password similarly in this
case also we have an illegal password
because it begins with a space in this
case it's the same thing we begin with
the space and also it does not have any
of those symbols that we were looking
for the dollar or the hash or the ad so
again so these three are illegal
passwords and they do not get appended
to Value however this does get appended
to Value and that's why we get the
result for only one password which is
the only legal password welcome to web
scraping with python my name is Richard
kirschner with the simply learned team
certainly there are many reasons to be
able to go online and scrape different
websites they range everything from
pulling out different links to pulling
data off of website it's a data
scientist you might need to get some
information off a website that doesn't
have a direct API to pull that
information and in Python we have a
wonderful tool when you talk Python and
you talk web scraping we're talking
beautiful suit which is a package you
add into your python that you're running
and we can come over here to the website
www.crumi.com software beautiful soup
you can actually read a little bit about
it currently beautiful soup 4 is the
current version if you don't remember
the full website for you can always do
what I do which just go over and do a
search for beautiful soup official site
it almost always comes up right at the
top and you click on there and it'll
take you to the crummy.com software site
for beautiful soup now we're going to
use our whatever python interface you
want IDE I'm going to use Jupiter lab
which is built on Jupiter notebook
through Anaconda so when I open up my
anaconda Navigator you'll see that I
have my different tools available again
you might be using a different editor
and that's okay you might be in pie
charm or something like that we don't
need to do this and Jupiter lab is
Jupiter notebook with added tabs and
some added features it's basically in
beta testing so it's got a few little
glitches when you're saving things and
moving between projects but for the most
part it's a great upgrade to the jupyter
notebook and you can use them together
so you don't have to I mean it's built
on jupyter notebooks anything you do in
Jupiter notebook you can open up in
Jupiter lab and the first thing we need
to do is we need to go ahead in this
case I'm going under my environments
since it partitions the environments out
and I'm going to open up a terminal when
we have to install some packages in here
to work with now there's a lot of
choices on this I because of the
Simplicity we'll be using conda install
now you can use pip install for the same
thing and we're going to install our
beautiful soup 4. you have to type out
the whole thing beautiful soup four and
you can use a pip install if you're
using a different environment and I am
using python version
3.6 although according to beautiful soup
they also work on three seven all the
way from two seven through all of 3x now
according to the beautiful suit website
the beautiful soup 4 works on anything
you can install anything from python 2 7
all the way through any of the Python 3
versions this just happens to be
python36 because they do it there's a
lot of other packages that don't work on
three seven yet and we'll go ahead and
run this install on here and let it go
through its environmental setup and of
course with conduct it goes in there and
finds all the dependencies PIP doesn't
do as much as far as finding
dependencies but you know exactly what's
on there with Pip so if you're doing a
huge distribution you probably want to
use your pip install so you can track
what's going on there with the conda I
like to just let it take over since this
isn't a major distributed package going
out another quick note between pip and
conda is that if you start on a project
in one of these environments and you're
using pip in there stick with Pip if
you're using conda stick with conda they
track the packages and you can run into
some issues where they're not tracking
the same packages and something gets
overwritten so it's important to stay
very consistent with your install on
your environments and we'll also need to
go ahead and install our numpy
environment and our pandas on here so go
ahead and do that if you haven't added
those packages in go ahead and install
those into your environment that you're
working in and of course pandas is just
simply install pandas and let's just
install a couple more packages in this
case let's get our install our map plot
library because we're going to plot at
the end since we're going to be
collecting data and for this project
that will be all the packages we'll need
so we can go ahead and close out of our
ends dollar or whatever setup you have
and we'll go back to home and we'll just
launch our Jupiter lab and that will
open up in our browser window now if
you're coming from Jupiter notebooks and
first time in lab we can go ahead and
just create our first notebook python3
you can also do it under a file launcher
and you'll see new notebook it
automatically opens up and we can just
click right on there it'll pop open on
the left and I'll right click this and
we'll rename this we'll rename it just
beautiful and it is a i Pi NB file on
there so that should look familiar
because that's a jupyter notebook file
this is a new one now I have multiple
tabs and in the past I usually hid this
on the other computer all my notes for
the lesson today but this is my notes
going down and we'll go ahead and just
start going through this and see what it
looks like to do a data pull from front
to end and see how that works as a data
scientist pulling that information in
from the website and the first thing I
want to do is I want to go ahead and
close the side window that way it looks
get the nice full screen and we can also
up the size a little bit one of the
wonderful things about working in a
browser window just do that control plus
thing the packages we talked about is
pandas so we imported our pandas if you
haven't already that's our data frame if
you haven't done our pandas tutorial
definitely worthy of the time to go
through there and understand pandas
because it's such a powerful tool this
basically turns your data into a
spreadsheet data frame our numpy is our
number array so it kind of works with
pandas very closely as far as
manipulating data in arrays matte plot
we want to go ahead and bring that in
our PLT so that we can plot the data at
the end and this line right here that
says matplot Library inline is for the
Jupiter notebook specifically it tells
it to print that on this page a lot of
the newer versions don't actually
require to have that line they'll still
print it on the page we should still
include that if you're in the Jupiter
lab setup and then we have our URL
Library dot request we're going to
import URL open for opening up the
website and then we have our bs4 that's
your beautiful soup four we're going to
import beautiful suit and then our last
one is our re that is for manipulating
our regular Expressions so when you get
to that part of importing our data we
have to do a lot of reformatting so it's
something we can use and the re is one
of those tools we'll go ahead and run
this and just bring all that in so this
is all imported all these packages are
now into our web scraping program we're
going to run now if we're going to dive
in and pull data we should have a nice
website to pull from and let's go ahead
and we'll use the uppertiming.com
results for the 2018 Martin Luther King
race and if we take this you can
actually just take this where did we get
this from well you can go in here and
find the website you're going to scrape
from and you'll see right here it says
you just copy that link right in there
that HTTP and this is the website that
we're looking at you can see right here
all the information that we're looking
at let's say we wanted to run some
statistics on this it sure would be nice
to be able to pull it off of here and if
they don't have a direct API that means
we need to pull it from their website
some of these will have a download
although if you've ever done it we have
a download click and maybe you're paging
through 100 websites in one case I was
pulling all the different United States
bills that are passed to track who voted
on them for a project and you can
imagine that there's you know hundreds
and hundreds of those thousands of these
documents that they voted on who voted
on and it goes to the Senate goes back
to the Congress so I opened up a website
pull all the links off of there that
match the certain criteria and we'll
look at that in just a minute how we go
through the HTML and then I had to
reformat them or I could hand download
each one one at a time which would just
be a nightmare so it's nice to automate
it in this case we're going to be
pulling up this chart we want to figure
out how to pull this chart off of this
website and so we go back into our
Jupiter notebook I've got my URL just um
our name for it and it's just a string
that's all this is nothing fancy there
you'll notice that on the slashes so we
now have forward forward slash you can
do a single forward and HTTP is a double
forward this is just how you have to
switch it to match setup in there and
then it's going to go ahead and use the
HTML equals URL open URL and that's from
our URL Library request so it's opening
a link to that website or at least
pointing to it and if we run this this
just sets it up so this is all set up
and then once we've done our setup let's
go ahead and create an object called
soup this will be and if you remember up
here here's our beautiful soup that we
imported from the bs4 and this is the
package that we're working with and so
we're going to do our beautiful soup on
here and on this we need to go ahead and
send it our HTML so it knows what it's
opening and then the second part is we
have to tell it how the format is coming
in and the most common one for your HTML
polls is an L XML setup and so almost
all of them you'll end up using the lxml
there's a few other options and because
this is so common in the newer versions
a lot of time they just leave it out
just because it's already on the default
we'll go ahead and leave it in here just
to remind us that it's there and we'll
go ahead and run that and on the newer
versions uh they actually default it to
the XML setup and the HTML we'll just
leave it out and call it HTML so it's
just going to pull from this URL and
when we run that on here we've now
created an object soup that has pulled
the website into it so soup contains the
information along with information on
that website and what's going on so
let's just go over what we did real
quick before we start digging into the
actual suit before we start scooping out
stuff we imported our different modules
that we're going to use with our package
specifically the beautiful soup we did
install the beautiful soup if remember
correctly you have to call it beautiful
soup four specifically so it knows what
you're bringing in and this line right
here is very key from bs4 because that's
how it installs the module we're
importing our beautiful soup and then we
found our URL in this case we're going
to go pull information from the mark
Luther King dream run and then we set
our HTML to our URL open URL and you can
see right here we imported that so
here's our url.request import URL open
so we're requesting a connection and
once we send that connection into the
beautiful soup it creates an object
called suit and then this one of course
we chose soup just because it goes with
beautiful soup I guess we could have
chosen beautiful and now we can start
extracting information from our website
because we've pulled it down onto our
computer under soup now we can start by
looking at the title of the website
soup.title and if we print title dot
text you'll see this a lot in beautiful
soup because title contains all kinds of
information and if we want just the text
from that title you add the dot text on
the end and you can see right here we
have our 2018 MLK dream Run 5K race
results if you look at the tab that's
the actual title up here 2018 MLK dream
Run 5K race that's what the title is on
the website and then you might be
curious what's in title what's the whole
title that it's storing up there well
let's go ahead and print it out here's
print title and print title.txt and when
we run that you can see it has the HTML
tags title on it and then the forward
slash title to end it and so we're
really just pulling off this piece of
the HTML code and then we look at the
text inside that particular part of the
HTML and earlier I mentioned links what
if you want to get all the links off
this page oh that would be fun uh we
could do soup Dot and we'll do find
underscore all put this in bracket and
then quotation marks we're going to put
a a is the key find and you'll start
seeing a div and all the different
options you have for finding these
entities in a website and then let's go
ahead and just print our links and you
can see here that it now shows all the
different links in here that are marked
by eggs we did a find all a and then we
can also because this is a little bit
hard to pull off the H reference so we
can also add in our find all fine tune
that in this case the H reference equal
true we'll actually filter that out and
then finally we might do a four link in
links and we can simply do something
like this for each link we want to
actually find the H reference because we
know there's an H reference in it and if
I run this you can see it just comes
through and prints them out one at a
time some of these are really useful so
you might be looking for something that
has https in it and you know that's a
link running to something else or you
might be looking for the mail to tags
you know that's all the mail addresses
but either way you can easily find all
the links in your HTML document that
you're paging through and of course any
packages that have evolved over time you
can also do
link.geth reference which should do the
same thing as our other format and you
can see it certainly does we get the
same printout up here in this particular
case we really want to get the data off
the page so let's go ahead and do that
let's see what that looks like and in
data let's call it all rows there we go
equals and then we have our soup dot
find underscore score all there's our
brackets and then if we're looking for
each row in a database you'll remember
your HTML code we're looking for the tag
TR so we want to find all TR and we can
take this let's go and just take all our
rows and do a print all rows and about
this time you're going to guess that
we're going to get a huge amount of
information just dumped onto our page
and sure enough we do if you look at
this it just kind of goes on forever but
this is an array each row is considered
an array so because of that we can do
something simply as putting brackets and
just print the first let's do the first
five rows so from beginning to five and
you can see here's our first five rows
on here I sometimes like to just do
let's just do row zero and we see that
row 0 is finishers finishers 191 and
just out of curiosity which if that's
zero what's Row one male okay so we're
starting to see titles going across here
so if we come up here and we do rows we
did what up to 10 let's just take a look
and see what 10 does again and just take
a look at that information that comes
across Place bib name gender age city
state chip chip Pace gender and so on so
it comes all the way down here we kind
of have an ending right here and then we
have one and then we actually it looks
like we start to have information so we
have our 1 our 1 1191 Max Randolph that
must be the name male 29 and so on you
start seeing how the information starts
getting displayed going down so the next
thing we want to do with this I'll go
back up here and just edit the space
we're in so it starts to make a little
bit more sense keep it all together and
so we want to do for each row in all
rows we're looking at what information
are we looking at well we have our th up
here that's the header our TD down here
which looks like the individual
information and we really are looking
for the actual data so we're looking for
our TD tags in the rows and we can do
that because when remember when it
stores the row it also stores the tags
underneath that so all have all the
different tags in it and you can see
right here as you print each one of
those out and so we look at each row we
can create another variable and we'll
call it row list and set this equal to
in this case row because we've already
pulled all the rows out of soup so now
we want to find
for each row and in there we want to
find our TD and if we go ahead and just
print I'm going to do it if you notice I
changed the indent so I'm just going to
print row list what this does is the
last value to go into row list our last
row is going to print now and of course
make sure you have an underscore instead
of a period when you're typing so row
dot find underscore all TD and if we
print the last row you can see I have
all the data coming across here we have
our 191 our 1216 Zuma Oak choa I hope I
said that right female I believe that's
age 40 and so on and then we can take
our row list and there's a lot of things
we can do with the row list what we'll
do for let's do object or let's just do
cell in row list and so we're going to
look at each cell because this is if you
look at this they have commas separated
between the different objects and then
we're going to go ahead and print cell
dot text let's just take a look and see
what that looks like and we can see here
for each row we get 191 there's our 191
there's our 12 16 12 16 our individual
who's in the race and so forth all the
way down for those different settings
let's go ahead and create a new variable
up here we'll call this all let's just
call it data we'll keep it simple so
here's our data and then we have our row
we take our row we break it up into
individual cells so we'll call this data
row we'll set this empty to an empty row
and we're going to take our cells to
have this we know that each cell
generates a text and so what we want to
do is I want to take my data row let's
just replace that let's take our data
row and let's append our cell dot text
so I'm going to add the each row is
going to be a row of the different text
on here and then once I create each row
I want my data which is going to be
everything to append each row and here's
our data row and then if we go ahead and
come down here and let's just print data
now if we were working with large data
we'd be very careful about just throwing
all our data on the page but you can see
here we throw the data on the page and
we get finishers 199 male 78 female 113
1 and so on and if you look at this this
is the headers on the file we have
finishers uh male females just like some
general statistics on the first one and
then we have actually
an empty data set and then we have our
data that continues which actual the
actual information we're looking for so
we have 1 1191 Max Randolph Mill 29
Washington DC runtime one of 78 and so
on on here so we could really quickly
get rid of that a number of different
ways to do that one of them is just to
do we're going to set if we do data 2 on
we should get rid of everything but we
want to keep Randolph so make sure
Randolph is in there we lost Randolph
let's try one on there we go there's Max
Randolph on there so we can just simply
do redo our data on here and we can do
data probably want to do it in all rows
from one on but I'm just going to do my
data equals data one on down here and
there's reasons to split it this way in
data science sometimes you don't want to
touch the original data in case you need
it in case we do need the first row so
we'll put it down here and maybe we'll
just call this titles titles equals data
of zero and so we could do something
here where we print we'll print up our
titles and we'll print our data in this
case instead of one on let's go minus
two let's look at the last two rows of
data so here we have our titles and for
some reason just put in finishers of 191
I was expecting a little bit more up
there and we have our last couple people
and they look like the data on these
looks just fine on here turns out this
is just some generic statistics up here
so we'll get rid of titles completely
doesn't really do us any good but we
know that data comes in here and we can
look at our data and look at the very
end of the data too the minus 2 to the
end and we can see it pulls the data in
pretty good we don't have anything too
funky in here we're looking at it looks
pretty clean now you got to be a little
careful because at some point we might
have to come back here and clean up the
data if we get an error if we're running
a data analysis we might find out
there's some unusual characters or
something is missed set in the data
itself and you also notice that
everything is a string so when we're
bringing it in we might have to do some
conversions to test it out and convert
them to whatever kind of data format
we're working with so at this time we
want to go ahead and bring in our pandas
and let's go ahead and call this idea
for data frame we'll set it equal to and
if you remember correctly we imported
pandas as PD and that's standard you'll
see that in most code examples where
they call it the import pandas is PD and
it is capital D capital F for data frame
and we're just going to bring in our
data that's what
and let's take this and we'll print now
when you're working with data frames
you're usually talking large amounts of
data and so you almost never want to
print the whole data frame out we're
going to go ahead and do that anyway
just so we can see what that looks like
and you can see in here brings in our
data frame coming in here and we just
have a mess of information this is our
data let's go ahead and print DF and see
what that looks like in the data frame
and this is nice because it organizes it
into a very easy to read table and we
have they set the label 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
and so on and then we have each row we
have Mel 78 none none going across when
we get all the way down here we'll see
Max Randall about number three and the
first thing this does is this Flags me
that I brought in a bunch of information
up here that we really didn't want it's
from 3 on that we want and we can clean
this up in one of two ways we can try to
clean it up under the data or we can
clean it up under the data frame
depending on what it is we're trying to
do and so to fix this
um I want to go ahead and just change it
up here in the actual data poll in we
don't need that information so I'll
rerun it reload our data from 4 on and
then when I run this we see we have Max
Randolph is right at the top of the list
like he should be and we have all the
data going down now with the data frame
remember I said we don't usually print
the whole data frame we'll go ahead and
do df.head and this prints the first
five rows and you can see that we have
13 columns here's Max Randall all the
way to Theo kinman and I use the also
print DF tell and the reason I like to
do these particular two setups I'm going
to change it just to two rows because
you can do that you can put as many rows
as you want is this good to look at the
first part and the end because those are
usually where you have extra data
brought in something's messed up and you
can also see that we have 190 rows in
here and it comes in with our Zuma
Alicia and they're both on here on the
list so now we have a nice data frame
columns and rows we can easily look at
it we can see the setup on here and we
can look at the names and everything now
at some point you might be looking at
these individual columns and find
different information that needs to be
re-edited if you can you try to do it
with the whole column under pandas you
can up in the upper part of the code
where you went from cell to cell or row
to row you could look at individual
cells maybe find a marker in that cell
that's something specific like remove
all colons or semicolons or something in
there are brackets so there's a lot of
options in there but you'll find that
this one actually comes in pretty clean
on here all the way down and the next
thing we really want to do is we want to
look at the headers I don't know about
you but does it make any sense to me
when I have column one I don't know what
1191 is or 1080 need name Kaiser Runner
I'm guessing that's column two is names
third one it looks like male or female
probably age but I don't want to guess I
want this to bring in my column so I
know exactly what I'm looking at so how
can we make beautiful soup do that for
us well let's take our column headers
and we're going to set that equal to our
soup find underscore all and then we're
going to look for our headers our th
files and since we're in Jupiter lab in
this case Jupiter notebook I can just
type out column headers if it's a last
variable I have listed it will
automatically print it just kind of a
shorthand and we can see right here we
have place I'm guessing that's bib name
gender age city state chip time chip
pace and so on so we have all our
headers right there I shouldn't have to
type them all in and we'll go ahead and
do it before we'll go ahead and do a
header list equals our empty array and
then we can do for a column in column
headers and we can take our header list
and just a pin and what do we want we
want the text from the column so we'll
just do column dot text and then if we
come down here and we print our header
list let's see what that looks like if
we did it right we should get a nice
list of all the different column
headings we want so we have placebib
name and so on and then pandas just
because pandas is so cool simply do DF
columns equals our header from our
header list we can simply set DF columns
set to DF headers and then if I print
df.head we'll take a look at that and
we'll see right here it has nicely
placed our values on here Place bib name
gender age and so on so very quickly
we've created this nice data frame we
have the data displayed in nice rows and
columns and easy to read and then as a
data scientist the first thing we want
to know is the info what is in these
columns and rows and headers and you see
right here they all come up with
non-null object there's a big flag so if
I want to do anything with this these
are all coming through as strings or an
object I usually mean strings in this
case that they're a string variable and
we have you can quickly read through
this 191 entries date columns total 14
columns there's a total of 14 columns in
the data and it shows you all the
different names and what type of column
they are and it's probably good also to
look at the shape of the data df.shape
we'll go ahead and just at you see it's
191 by 14 14 columns 191 entries this is
more like a we look at a numpy array 191
by 14 for the shape and remember this is
a variable so if I put it on if it's a
last variable or last value in the set
of cells Jupiter automatically prints it
out so if you're in a different IDE you
want to go ahead and use the print
statement on here and then one of the
things you'd want to also go through
we'll create a second one df2 equals DF
dot drop in a now the axis is
automatically equal to zero so a lot of
times you'll see something like X's
equals zero comma How equals any axis
equals 0 is default that means we're
looking at going down the rows you could
look at the column going across let's
remove the how any this is going to
confuse you the axis is is whether
you're going down the columns or if
you're looking at a row by row by row by
row or you could be looking at it by
column by column by column this would
drop any column in the adopt the N A in
any column and how equals and we want
any I always confuse all in any because
they both start with a all means that
all of them have to be non-value where
any means that any of them can be there
to drop it so this would drop any column
with a null value in it but we want zero
and it'll drop any value with a null
value and then because 0 is always the
default we'll just leave it out and then
as curious as to what the shape is now
did we lose anything was there any null
values in our df2 that we dropped from
the DF and we'll go ahead and run that
and we see 191 and 14. so we didn't
really drop anything but it's always
good to check there's other ways you can
also do are there let's see any Nas you
can detect Nas in here null values
infinite values that's another one you
got to watch out for we're working with
data that we're going to do something
with here in a minute so you got to be a
little careful also in the conversions
are you going to convert something where
people typed in weird characters to
describe the data as certain way so now
we've got to this point where we have
all our different columns we have our
different data and at this point maybe
you're asking or maybe the shareholder
the company is asking hey can we look at
the based on the chip time here's our
chip time can we plot that versus gender
how does gender versus chip time compare
and so we can do that we can take that
and the first thing we look at is we say
hey well chip time came in as a string
and that's going to be an issue now
there's a number of ways you can change
this one of them is we could go all the
way back up here where we created the
data and find a way to tag it and say
Hey whenever this cell text maybe
instead of appending this I notice that
anytime there's two colons in it that's
probably a time signature and let's uh
convert all the time signatures to date
time filled or whatever A lot of times
you don't get that you don't get that
option and that's always a question in
bringing in data whether you convert the
data coming in at the beginning or do
you wait till you have it open it up and
then convert it when you go to use it
we're going to go ahead and convert it
after we got it into our data frame so
we have our df2 here we've dropped all
of our Nas we dropped our we have a
shape in fact let's do this since
there's no difference between DF and df2
well we'll just go ahead and use df2 so
let's go ahead and take our df2 and we
want to take those that specific field
and convert it into some kind of
numerical value we can use and let's add
another column A lot of times this is
something you want to do is where you
want to go ahead and keep all the
original columns and just add a new
column in there and this new column is
going to be based on the if we remember
correctly we had chip time that's what
we're going to look at okay we want chip
time versus gender if we go into our
pandas we find out we have pandas 2
Delta and this is actually time Delta
and then we just want to take our df2
and we're going to use the chip time
column so this is going to say hey let's
look at let's convert everything in df2
chip time into a Time Delta format
that's the data type we're going to put
it as and we can go ahead and just run
this and if we go in here and we do info
df2 and we'll keep our we're going to
look at this particular column but we
want to keep it as a data
so this is a list of all the columns we
want to look at and we'll just do that
info on here and run that and we do an
info on that you can see it's now a Time
Delta 64 nanoseconds uh well we really
don't want nanoseconds we actually
probably want to do it in minutes uh so
let's take a look at that and let's take
this whole thing TF2 let's just set the
df2 we have our df2 this is a column
we're working with here and we can use
the as type property in pandas so we can
set this equal to df2 we'll take our
same column in here and we'll set it as
type time Delta second so it's still a
Delta time here so if I run this you'll
see that it still comes up as where is
it nope it turns it into a float so
we're now at a float 64 so it's the
number of seconds in that Delta time and
then finally we want to go ahead and
turn that from seconds to say minutes
and you know there's 60 seconds in
minutes and so now we divide by 60 we
still have a float we have our info it
shows us it's a flow then we can go
ahead and just do a print df2 and let's
just keep it small we don't want to look
at all our data we just want to do the
head of it and we run this and you can
see right here where we go to it'll be
the last one here's our chip time in
minutes and a lot of times just to make
life easy for viewing since we're only
looking at this particular element we
can do chip time in minutes and now we
just see that oops we take off we'll go
ahead and take off our info done with
that and we'll run this and you can see
we have our minutes 16.8 minutes 17.51
minutes and so on it's a float number
now keep in mind this is 0.8 that's not
a 16 minutes and 80 Seconds that can
always throw you if you're going through
so many numbers you forget so important
to remember that and we're also going to
look at the other one we're looking at
is what gender you want to look at
gender to chip time in minutes and so we
can see here under the head we get mail
mail mail and a number of different
setups and this switch this to tail real
quick and just look at the end of it and
here we have female female male female
female so we have two different
different genders and we have our chip
time in minutes and if you remember we
brought in our PLT if you haven't used
the plot Library the matplot library you
have a drawing place you're putting
stuff on so we have our PLT we're going
to do a bar graph and we just want to
Simply use our df2 gender and df2 Chip
time in minutes so that's going to plot
the two bars and to make it pretty we'll
go ahead and give it the X label gender
the Y label chip time minutes and that
simply is remember it always plots X and
it plots Y and we have our gender our
chip time give it a nice title a
comparison of average minutes run by
male and female and if we go ahead and
run this with the correct titles in here
and everything matches you'll get a nice
graph we can see here the comparison of
average minutes run by male and female
here's our chip time in minutes the men
seem to be Slackers in this particular
case and it's actually uh there's a
number of studies that show that women
tend to have as far as doing
cross-country there's a lot of women who
have a longer and returns and men so
it's not too surprising we can see here
the average chip time around 70 and for
women over a hundred minutes and then
another really cool thing we can do is
we can describe the data so
df2.describe this again is a pandas
function just like info is and we're
going to include uh NP number the numpy
number and if we run that you'll see
here it comes up it says chip time in
minutes count it gives you the average
or the means standard deviation the
minimum the maximum all the different
descriptive information you're going to
want from your data set on there and
just because there's all kinds of fun
ways let's do a box plot to display your
information we can do a box plot where
the column equals chip time in minutes
and let's go ahead and run that keep
mistyping my chip time in minutes you
can see it puts out a nice box plot
showing you the information we have our
different values and floaters this is
always interesting because this is a
nice way of seeing where we have these
floaters one up here and there's two up
above and of course you're they're nice
spread on the box plot and we can also
modify this a little bit and we can add
in buy equals gender and then we'll give
it a we'll just give it a blank title I
don't know why we're giving you a blank
title uh we'll just add a y plot y label
on there for runtime and if we run this
you can see here box plot Group by
gender chip time in minutes and now we
have our female and male two different
areas and you can see how they vary you
have your two different your outlier up
here and you can also see how there's
such an overlap between the two
different values so if I was looking at
this I'd be like wow you know I really
could not draw a conclusive thing on
this saying that Women's Run time was
more in general because they overlapped
too much that would be one of the
conclusions I'd have to come up with
done here and then we get to maybe the
partners come in from the company and
say hey we'd like to know the age versus
chip time in minutes that'd be something
worth knowing on the statistics on this
and the first thought is we can simply
plot it and we can do this we can
actually plot the scatter plot chip time
versus D of 2 of H those are X Y
coordinates but if you remember from df2
we did the info let's go way back up
here we're looking at a data object as
far as our chip time on this and our age
now we converted the chip time but we
also need to convert the age and if we
do it right here we just plot it and
it'll actually let us plot it it
shouldn't it should give us an error but
it does let us plot it you'll see the
Ages come up a mess over here because
they're converting it to weird float
numbers and all kinds of things so what
we want to do is we want to take our age
and we'll just call this age underscore
I so we're going to take our age and
we're going to create another column for
D of 2 Age underscore I and the I is
just going to stand for integer it's our
own choice of values there is a number
of ways to do this but we're going to do
pandas to Merrick is the best way in
pandas and the reason we're doing this
is that numeric creates a float value so
right off the bat we want all our stuff
converting converts it to the least
common the denominator so if they're all
integers already you'll get integers as
you can see from here it's doing some
kind of conversion that converts it to a
float value the other thing that numeric
does is if there is a null value or they
put in like a blank line or a dash to
represent no information it'll convert
it to a null so it goes from like a
string to a null versus just having some
kind of made up number that python
somehow created for the graph we have
below and then we want to add our df2h
because that's what we're converting to
numeric and then we want to coerce it
and there's a couple different options
on this like you can have it where it
just doesn't process it and pandas but
coerce means that if it gets a weird
value that is a null value now and since
we're dealing with errors this is what
happens when you get an error converting
it we want to coerce it there we go and
put the end bracket on there and then
finally we want to go and round this off
so we'll put brackets around all the way
around it and this rounds off everything
in this series so we've done here is
I've taken df2h which is a d-type object
which in this case is mostly stream
rings with a couple blank ones in there
and we're going to convert it to a
numeric which will automatically go to
float and then we're going to take
wherever there's an error where it says
hey this doesn't convert and usually
that's a blank screen like I said I've
worked with so many databases where they
someone puts down none someone types in
space sometimes in a dash domain none
and you get this really weird conversion
coming up this covers all of that in
pandas so it's really a nice way of just
coercing it and saying hey if we don't
have a number in there let's make it a
null value and then we're going to round
it off and then finally let's go ahead
and take our df2 here's our df2 and
let's drop those null values drop in a
and we want how how equals any so that
means if there's any null values in the
data set now you can be this might get
you in trouble because you might have no
values in a different column and so you
might lose data that way at this point
we could also do like certain parts of
like Drop just certain columns with null
values there's all kinds of other
options in here but we're just going to
do how we're going to just drop any and
we want to do it in line equals true so
that means it's going to reassign it to
df2 so df2 now has rounded out so it's
rounded to the integer we didn't do any
places the age and it's going to be age
I and then we've dropped all our null
values that way we're not going to get
any errors and we try to plot a null
value and it also makes sure that data
by deleting out the rows because that's
what this does it automatically does
axis0 which is your rows axis one is
your columns by doing this it
automatically removes all the rows with
null values so it just cleans out the
roles and then when we go ahead and plot
this we see we have a nice clean data
and we have age all the way up to 7 7D
so we have our chip time set and then
our age going across and it makes a nice
plot that you can easily show for
display and for the the and you can
easily show that to your shareholders or
whatever group you're working on it
makes it really nice and quick easy
display in this session we will discuss
the top tips and tricks in Python that
you can use to solve your problems first
let's understand what python really is
so python is a high level open source
programming language developed in 1989
by Guido van Rossum
it has simple easy to use syntax python
can run on different platforms such as
Windows Linux and Unix
it has a large collection of libraries
and can be integrated with other
programming languages such as C C plus
plus and Java
companies use Python for web development
software development statistical
analysis machine learning and deep
learning
python tips and tricks will help you
optimize the code and reduce your time
and effort while writing codes for
solving problems
these tips and tricks are usually short
Snippets of python code with simple
illustrations to tell you how you can
perform a complex task easily
it can also serve as examples that allow
you to dive deep into understanding and
exploring how each concept works and
where it can be used
so in this video we'll be covering the
tips and tricks based on python lists
tuples sets and dictionaries we'll also
see how to effectively use loops
iterators and collections in Python
so let me take you to my jupyter
notebook where I'll show you the
different tips and tricks
so here is my jupyter notebook
so let's begin with our first trick
if you want to initialize a list or a
tuple filled with repetitive strings or
numbers written in the form of a string
we can do that using the multiplication
operator
so let me show you
so first I'll declare a list suppose a
is equal to within square brackets I'll
declare a string suppose India
and now if I use the multiplication
operator and suppose I say 10
then I'll print a
so this will print India 10 times if I
hit shift enter it will run that cell
you can see we have printed India 10
times
similarly
let's add another element to our list
or another item to our list
say India and then we have
France
I'll use the multiplication operator and
apply 10. so let me print my list again
for hit shift enter you can see India
and France have been printed 10 times
also
you can use
an integer as a string
and print as many times as you want
suppose I am printing 25 times
I'll use the print statement
you can see we have printed 25 times
but if I pass an integer as my first
operand
it will result in the product of the two
numbers so for example if I use c equal
to
20 into 5
and if I print C
it will give me the product of 20 and 5
that is 100.
next let's see how you can reverse the
elements in a list for that we'll use
the list slicing method
let me first show you how you can
reverse a string
I'll declare my list as list 1 is equal
to
and inside this list I'll
pass in a few country names such as
India then we have
USA
let's say we have France
and then
Germany
and finally we have Spain now if you
want to reverse the order of this list
you can use the slicing method inside
the print statement so I'll write
print
and I'll pass in my list that is list
one
and I'll use double colon
followed by
-1 so this will read my list from the
end
so if I hit shift enter you can see we
have reversed
our original list so now this pane comes
first then Germany France USA and India
likewise you can also reverse
a list of numbers
so
let's reverse a list of numbers
suppose this time I'll use list 2 is
equal to
I'll pass in few integers say 100 200
300 and 400. now if I
print
my list
to
using colon colon -1 it will reverse
list two
you can see we have reboost our original
list two so now 400 comes first then 300
200 and 100.
now let me tell you how you can print
the elements in a list in any order that
you prefer suppose I have a list that
has values like 1 comma two three and
four
then I'll print this list
after that I'll use four variables
such as e comma B comma C comma d
and assign it to our list
after that let me go ahead and print any
order that I want for example I'll use B
comma e comma D comma C
and hit shift enter you can see we have
printed our list in the order that we
wanted
so basically what this cell does is
we have assigned the value 1 from list
to a 2 to B 3 to C and 4 to D and we are
printing in an order b a d c
so this is the result you can see
now suppose you want to print in some
other order like
say I want C first
then I want B
a and then d
so this is the output
up next
we will discuss list comprehensions in
Python so list comprehension is an
effective way to define and create new
lists based on existing lists
so suppose you want to extract and
separate all the letters from the word
simply learn and add letters as items of
a list ideally you would use a for Loop
to do this task
so let's see how you can perform this
task using a for Loop I'll assign an
empty list say letters
is equal to I'll use square brackets to
assign my empty list
then
and declare a for Loop so suppose for I
in
I'll pass in my string that is simply
learn
and
I'll append the letters
using the append function
now let me go ahead and
print the letters
if I hit shift enter you can see
this will print all individual letters
present in the word simply learn
but the same job
you can do it easily with the help of
list comprehensions
so let me show you how to do that
first I'll declare a variable say
letters
is equal to inside square brackets I'll
write I for
I in my string
simply learn
then I'll just
print the letters
you can see we have extracted all the
letters from the word simply learn
so this is how we use list comprehension
now similarly
if you were to find the square of
numbers you would like to create a user
defined function or use a for Loop to do
it so let me show you how you can
proceed
so
we were to define a function so first
I'll import
the math module present in Python
and then let's say I am defining a
function called Square
and I'll pass in a parameter as a
then I'll write e is equal to
I'll use the power function so I'll
first give in my module name that is
math and use the power function that is
pow
and I'll pass in my parameter that is a
and since we want to find the square
I'll give in 2
and I'll return my parameter that is a
if I hit shift enter now we have
successfully run our user defined
function
now let me call that function
if I write
square of a
does given me 1 by default
suppose I want to find the square
of integer 5
you can see it has given us the square
of 5 that is 25
now to find the square of a number you
can also create an empty list and use a
for Loop to iterate through a sequence
of numbers and append the square of
numbers to that empty list
so let me show you how you can do with
this process suppose I
declare an empty list called squares
I'll pass in my empty list
and then I'll use a for Loop say for
example for
I in
range
I'll give 10 as my range
and then
I'll append my Square value so I'll
pass in my empty list that is squares
Dot
append
so I'll use Quest dot append
and pass I into I
and then
I'll just
call my empty list squares if I hit
shift enter you can see
from 0 to 9 that is a range of 10 values
it has printed all the squares of those
integers
now these two methods that we just
discussed need at least three to four
lines of code but by using a list
comprehension you can find the square of
numbers in just a single line of code
so let's use a list comprehension to
find square of five whole numbers
between 0 and 20 having an interval of
4.
so I'll use
squares
is equal to
I'll say X
double multiplication operator
into 2 for
X in
say range
I'll pass in my range that is from 0 to
with an interval of 4.
now I'll
print squares
if I hit shift enter you can see it has
printed the square of values so first
the number is 0 so 0 square is 0 then
the number was 4 so 4 square is 16 8
square is 64. then 12 square is 144 and
then 16 square is 256.
moving ahead in the next trick
I'll show you how you can keep track of
the index positions and the items in a
list
so for that we will use the enumerate
function to print the item values along
with the index positions
so let's see I have a list
that has items
say
294 I'm taking random integers
450 and say 243
and now if I
use a print statement suppose
I'll write using the
enumerate function
then I'll use a for Loop say for example
for
index comma
element
in
enumerate
I'll pass in my
list that is list underscore items
after that
I'll use a print statement
I'll pass in index
and then I'll give
a list and that will have my
index
followed by
the value
I'll use another comma and pass in the
element
now if I hit shift enter you can see we
have printed the index position as well
as the item value so at index 0 we have
310 at index 1 we have 294 similarly for
index 2 and 3
now moving ahead
let us understand how we can convert two
less into a dictionary so a dictionary
as you must be aware comes with a key
value pair
you can use the dictionary method and
pass the zip function with our list as
parameters
so let me Define our two lists say item
number and names
so I'll use item number
and give him some random whole numbers
and let's say 321
and I'll use my second list
that is names and let's say this list
has
some string values like phone
next is laptop
and then we have say tablet
now
I'll
assign a variables say item
dictionary
is equal to I'll use the dict function
and then pass in zip
and I'll pass in my parameters item
number and names
finally I'll print
my newly created dictionary that is item
dictionary
now let me run it
so you can see we have a dictionary
created out of the list
so our keys are 102 410 and 321 and the
item values are phone laptop and tablet
now you can check that in the following
way so I'll
pass in my dictionary
and then I'll use the keys function to
get the keys from the dictionary so you
see we have all the keys printed
similarly if you want to print the
values from the dictionary
I'll use the values function
so that will print all the values you
can see we have phone laptop and tablet
now we look at how you can find the
common elements in two lists
so let me declare my first list as list
underscore e that will be equal to
Davis
then let's say we have Karen
then we have John
you have Frank next and then let's see
we have another person say Steve
and let me declare my list B so list
underscore B
is equal to I'll take care in
next we have Davis
then suppose we have Jack
up next we have
George
and then say we have Steve again
now to find the common elements I'll use
variable let's say common
and I'll again
use a list comprehension say a for
a in
list a
then use for
B in
list B
then I'll use an if Clause so if E
equals to equals to B
then
I'll
print the common variable
if I run this you can see we have the
common elements printed from both the
list A and B so Dave is caring and Steve
are present in both list A and B
next let's see how you can remove the
duplicate items in a list such problems
you would often come across while doing
data analytics so the idea is very
simple just need to convert the items in
a list into a set
so that will remove all the duplicate
items in a list
so suppose I have a list of numbers
let me take random whole numbers 20 22
4 so 26
then we have 28 repeated twice
and then again suppose we have 20
and we have 22
and let's see we have 30.
now
let me go ahead and print my list
so I'll say original list
equals to
and then I'll pass in my list that is
list numbers
after that
I'll convert my list that is list
numbers
into a set
so I'll first use the list function and
then inside of that I'll pass in my set
function and then declare
my list
that is list numbers
finally I'll
print my new list so I'll type list
after
removing duplicates
that will be equal to
I'll give a comma and then pass in my
variable
that is list numbers
if I run it
you can see our original list has all
the elements that has duplicate values
and the final list the output you can
see we have only the unique elements
printed
moving on
now let's have a look at how you can
merge two dictionaries
so there are two methods to do this
before that let's see how the code would
have looked like had you merged the
dictionaries using python 2 version or
Python 3.4 version and below
so let's see I have two dictionaries say
team a
I'll use curly braces to declare my
dictionary
I'll give my key as 1 and I'll take
Davis
I'll give my second key
and see I have Andrew in my team
and then let's say I have my
third key and let's see I have Karen
similarly let me declare my
Team B dictionary
I'll take
the next key as four
and the next person would be
say John
and then
I'll use my fifth key
we have Angela
and let's see I have my final member in
the team the sixth member
who is Suzanne
now
if you do it in Python 2 or Python 3.4
version and below I have to define a
function so let me say Define
merge underscore teams which will be my
function name
and I'll pass in two parameters say dict
one
and dict
then I have dict three
indict three
I'll use the
copy method so I'll
use dict
one
dot copy
then
let me go ahead and
use my dict three
Dot
update
I'll pass in my
dick to
and then
see I'll return
my dict three
finally
I'll print it so I'll use
merge underscore teams
then pass in my two parameters as team a
comma
TMP
if I run it oops there is a mistake I
have made so this should be dipped to
actually
so let me run it once again you can see
we have merged both our dictionaries
now you can see it has around six to
seven lines of code or even more
now if you want to do this task using
python 3.5 version and above you can use
the update method so let's see how we
can do
I have CE
is equal to
I'll pass in my dictionary
as
e has value of 1
say B has a value of
let's say B also has a value of 1
and my
second dictionary would have
key B again
and it has a value of 2
and Key C
will have a value of 1. now if I write e
Dot
update B
and if I print a let me run it you can
see we have merged
both the dictionaries here
now there's one more method which you
can use let me show you
so I'll copy paste my team a and Team B
again
and then
let's say I'll declare
another variable called final team
that will be equal to
I'll use curly braces and then say
I'll give two star and then team a
comma
two stars again
and then Team B
then I'll print my
final team if I run it you can see we
have merged both our team A and B and
this is our final team that has
six elements
now before moving to the next trick if
you have enjoyed watching this video so
far then please consider subscribing to
our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to never miss an update
also if you want to get the source file
I am using in this live session then
please mention your email IDs in the
chat section we'll share the source code
with you over email
now let's move on
similar to a list comprehension you can
also create a dictionary comprehension
let me show you the trick
suppose I want to find the square of
numbers so I'll pass in my variable that
is square
and I'll use my dictionary comprehension
say x comma X
star star 2 this will find the square of
a number
for X in range
C5 so I want the square of the first
five numbers
then let me just call it
you can see it has printed
a dictionary that has the square of
numbers from 0 to 4 that is five numbers
so 0 square is 0 1 square is 1 2 square
is four three square is 9 and 4 square
is 16.
now let's see the trick to check if all
the elements in a sequence are true or
false based on a condition
you can do this with the help of all
function all function in Python returns
true if all the items in an iterable are
true otherwise it returns false
so I'll directly use my all function so
I'll say all
now let's see I'll use a variable e
percentage 2 if it's equal to equal to 0
and I'll say for a
in
range
between 0 to 10 with an interval of 2
if I run it
it gives me true
because I have defined my range from 0
to 10 and an interval of 2 so the
numbers will range from 0
2 4 6 8 and so on
so all these numbers are divisible by 2
and the remainder is 0 so it gives us
true
now if I change the third parameter in
my range function see I'll make it 3.
and I run it it gives me false
up next we look at a common programming
question that you often get to see in
any interview or programming test that
is swapping two numbers
let's see the trick to swap two numbers
in a single line of code
so I'll
declare two numbers c x and y
let's say we have xs10 and by s20
I'll use a print statement
say it before
swap
give a comma and I'll declare my
variables X comma y
now to swap to variables I can simply
use x comma y equal to
y comma X
and then I'll again use a print
statement C after swap
and I'll write X
equal to
say
X
and
y
will have the variable
if I run it
you see before swap X had 10 and 20 and
after swap you can see we have X as 20
and Y as 10. so we have swapped the
values of the two variables successfully
now moving on
the next trick I am going to show is how
you can concatenate a list containing
strings so we'll use the join function
for this
let's say I have a list characters
and it has a list of strings
say p comma y
comma t
comma h
comma o
and we have the final string that is n
now if you were to concatenate all the
list elements
I'll declare a variable called word and
double quotation marks
and then I'll use the dot operator and
join function
I'll pass in my list that is
character
then I'll
print my variable word
below you can see the resultant output
so we have successfully combined or
concatenated each element or item in the
list director so we have python printed
now let me show you how you can find the
most frequently occurring values in a
list
so
I'll declare a list called test and
suppose it has some random whole number
C1 comma 2 comma 3
four
two comma 2 then we have 3 comma 1 comma
four comma 4 comma four
I'll use
print statement
and pass in my Max function
then I'll convert the list into
a set
give a comma and then I'll use key is
equal to test dot count
so what it basically does is it will
first count
the number of times each element is
occurring and then
find the maximum value out of it
if I hit shift enter you can see it has
given me 4 which means
the item 4 has occurred the most number
of times in my list you can see we have
four four times
moving forward the next step is how you
can use the if else statement using
ternary operators
ternary operators are commonly known as
conditional expressions in Python these
operators evaluate something based on a
condition being true or false
so I have my two variables a comma B
and it has values
10 and 20 respectively
now if I
use a print statement say both a
and B
are
equal
if
a equals to equals to B
else
a
is
greater than b
if
a greater than
B
else
is
greater
than e
so first I am evaluating this condition
if a
is equal to equal to B then we'll print
both A and B are equal
else if a is greater than b we'll print
a is greater than b
if both the conditions are false we'll
print B is greater than a
so let me run this
we have the output B is greater than a
because
our B value is 20 and a is 10 so B is
greater than a
now let me create a numpy array and find
the cumulative sum in a sequence of
numbers for this you can use the come
sum function
first I have to import my numpy library
so I'll write
import
numpy as NP
then
I'll declare a variable
say res which is for result
I'll use a list function
and then
passing my come sum function
and let's say I'll give a range of 10.
finally I'll print the result
if I run this
you can see we have calculated the
cumulative sum of the numbers ranging
from 0 to 9
so the first element is 0 then the next
element is 1 so 0 plus 1 is 1. the next
element is 2 so 1 plus 2 is 3 then 3
plus 3 is 6 6 plus 4 is 10 10 plus 5 is
15 and so on
let's Now understand how you can use
iter tools in Python either tool is a
module in Python that implements a
number of iterator building blocks it
provides several functions that work on
iterators to produce complex iterators
we will see an example to find the list
of matches to be played between the
teams in a league here we consider each
team will play against all the other
teams in the league
so to use the iter tools I'll first
import it so I'll write import
iter tools
and then let me go ahead and declare a
list see
football
underscore clubs
let me take
a few Club names see Manchester United
then we have
Real Madrid
I'm taking the top clubs from Europe
foreign
followed by
Chelsea
then we have say Liverpool
and finally we have
Barcelona
then
I'll use my list function and
use another function that is present
inside the item tools library that is
combination
so it will give me all the possible
combinations
I'll pass in my
list
name that is football underscore clubs
and I'll give another parameter that is
r equal to 2
if I run it
you have all the matches that would be
played in this league
as I mentioned each team will play
against all the other teams
now we will see the trick to print the
total permutations in a given set of
numbers using the iter tool and its
functions
now to do this I'll use a
for Loop so I'll use for p in
either tools
Dot I'll use permutations function
so
permutations
and then let's see I'll pass in my list
that has values 1 comma 2 comma 3 and 4
I'll print it
I'll use print
then I'll use the
join function
convert it into a string
four
X in p
if I run it you can see below we have
all the permutations listed
up next let me tell you how you can
print all the false values present in a
list now to do this we can use the
filter false function present in the
iter tools module
so I'll use list
and then
use my iter tools
Dot
filter false function
I'll pass in
Bool as my
data type
let's say we have a list containing none
then we have false
we have one comma 0 comma 10.
if I run it
it will print all the false values
present in the list so we have none
false and zero
so if you have liked watching this video
so far then please subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon to
stay updated with all the trending
Technologies also if you want to get the
source file that I am using in this live
session then please mention your email
IDs in the chat section our team will
share the source code with you over
email
again if you have any questions related
to the tips and tricks we have discussed
so far then please put your queries in
the chat section our team will answer it
in the chat
up next let me show you the trick to
perform certain mathematical operations
inside a list containing pairs of tuples
first we look at how to add elements in
a list of tuples
so for that I'll import my iter tools
you can skip this step because we have
already imported a writer tools module
and then I'll import operator
we have
a list of tuples say A2 comma 5
then we have 10 comma 4
we have another pairs as 60 comma 3.
now I'll use
list function and inside of it I'll use
my iter tools module
so I'll write iter tools plot
star map function
and
I'll use my operator
add
comma
I'll pass in my list that is a
now if I run it
we have the addition of the pills of
tuples present in the list so first pair
is 2 comma 5 so the addition
is 7 then 10 plus 4 is 14 and 60 plus 3
is 63.
similarly you can also multiply the
pairs of tuples in a list
I just copy paste this code and here
instead of ADD
I'll use
mul to multiply
if I run it
we have the output below
so 2 into 5 is 10 then the product of 10
and 4 is 40 and 60 and 3 is 180.
now let us explore a bit about the
collections module in Python so the
collections module implements
specialized container data types
containing alternatives to Python's
general purpose built-in containers such
as list Tuple dictionaries and set
I'll show you how to change the order of
the keys inserted in a dictionary using
the ordered dict function
so first I need to import the ordered
dict function from the collections
module
so I'll write from
collections
import
ordered
dict function
then
I'll say d is equal to
ordered
Dot
I'll use the from keys
and let's see
I have my key as e b c d e
then I'll
use another function called move
to
end
and let's say I want to move my key B to
the end
then
I'll use inverted commas
and pass in my join function
and inside that I'll say d dot
keys
if I run it
you can see we have shifted the key B to
the end
now if you want to move the key B to the
beginning
you can do something like this so let me
copy the last two lines of code from the
above cell
I'll paste it
now here I can give another
parameter that is lost
and I'll see
false
if I run this
you can see we have the key B in the
beginning now
now the final trick I am going to show
you is how to perform mathematical
operations using a Lambda function in
Python
so Lambda is an anonymous function that
does not have a name
it can have any number of arguments but
only one expression
the expression is evaluated and the
result is returned
so let's see how to add and subtract
numbers in one line of code using the
Lambda function
so first I'll declare a variable say
function
is equal to
and I'll assign a dictionary
I'll pass in my
sum and then
use the Lambda function
I'll pass in variables X comma y
and I'll add X Plus y
similarly
I'll now
subtract
I'll use the Lambda function again
pass in my variables X comma y
and I'll write x minus y
now
let me run it
so if you want to find the sum of two
numbers
so I have to call this first so I'll use
funk
and using square brackets I'll give my
sum
and then pass in my value say 10 comma 3
this will add 10 plus 3 and return the
result as 13. similarly
if you want to subtract two numbers
I'll just write subtract here instead of
sum
and it will return the result that is 10
minus 3 that which is 7.
I think with that we have covered all
the important tips and tricks that you
should know in Python welcome to python
interview questions certainly the
questions we're going to ask in here are
very general with a few specifics
towards data science and sets the main
direction that Python's going in and
you'd want to expand your questions for
your interview depending on the domain
that you're using the python in
specifically let's dive in and get
started with some python interview
questions number one what is the
difference between shallow copy and deep
copy and you can see with shallow copy
we have object one which has child one
child two child three and so on and
object two which has child one child two
child three a deep copy creates a
different object and populates it with
the child objects of the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is not reflected in the copy copy.deep
copy creates a deep copy shallow copy
creates a different object and populates
it with the references of the child
objects within the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is reflected in the copy copy.copy
creates a shallow copy and you can look
at this if we make a change to child one
it's only a pointer so if you make it in
object one and change the channel one
and object one it will also make that
change in object two number two how is
multi-threading achieved in Python oh
this is a good one with multi-processing
and multi-threading this question is
actually asking you do you know the
difference between multi-processing and
multi-threading and how multi-threading
Works multi-threading usually implies
that multiple threads are executed
concurrently the python Global
interpreter lock doesn't allow more than
one thread to hold the python
interpreter at that particular point of
time so multi-threading in Python is
achieved through context switching it's
very different than multi-processing
which actually opens up multiple
processes across multiple threads so
multi-threading discuss the Django
architecture so the Django architecture
and the first thing to know is that the
Django is a web service way to build
your web pages basically and so when you
look at the architecture you can see
here we have a nice model drawn out
where the user initiates the Django
which initiates the URL which initiates
the view what they're going to view and
you have your model and your template so
the model of data whatever data model
you're pulling goes into the template
and then goes back up the pipeline to
the user and the important thing to note
is there's a template the front end of
the web page this is what they're going
to see there's a model the back end
where the data is stored so you can keep
the template and the looks and
everything looks the same but you can
swap out the underlying formation that
goes into that template then you have
your view which interacts with the model
and template and Maps it to the URL and
then the Django serves the page to the
user so your Django grabs it and says
okay thank you for the URL and here you
go user what advantage does numpy array
have over a nested list so numpy is a
module you import almost always see
numpy import numpy as NP numpy is
written in C such that all its
complexities are backed into a simple to
use module lists on the other hand are
dynamically typed therefore python must
check the data type of each element
every time it uses it this makes number
arrays much faster than lists I would
also add in that numpy has a lot of
additional functionality that you don't
have in lists there's a lot of things
you can automate in the numpy quick flip
over to our Jupiter notebook any IDE
will work if you're going to do a set of
these of interview questions taking a
quick look at code is always important
we have our import and of b as NP we'll
go ahead and import time here's our list
list sub for Iron Range of 100 and what
we're doing is we're going to time it so
we're going to create a list then we're
going to create a numpy zeros array and
you can see here look how quick you can
create this numpy zeros array here we
are appending one zero at a time for a
regular python list and here we are with
numpy they're all zeros and they're all
of type integer I believe it's either
floater integer on this I'd have to
actually do a type and then so if we
take in and we create a tl1 time equals
time and then we do for I and range of
100 for J and range of 100 L of I J
equals L of i j plus five so we're just
doing a simple calculation on our array
and sub arrays this is an array of rays
and we'll do the same thing with tl2 tl2
time dot time tl1 so here we have our
final time on that and then we'll do
this with an array array op and this is
what I really love a equals a plus 10
and then you can just print it right out
so you can see right here with the numpy
array I'm doing the same thing if I run
this our time is significantly different
here we have 0.09 and 0.003 so you can
see that the time drops significantly
when you're running this on a numpy
array versus a list array also important
to note these times aren't going to be
they'll change each time I run it
depending on what I have running in the
background so there we go number five
what is pickling and unpickling Macy's
how many M's I pickle and unpickle
something converting a python object
hierarchy to a byte stream is called
pickling pickling is also referred to as
serialization unpickling converting a
byte stream to a python object hierarchy
is also called unpickling unpickling is
also referred to as deserialization so
if you just created a neural network
model you can now save that model to
your hard drive pickle it and then you
can unpickle it to bring it back into
another software program or to use at a
later time how is memory managed in
Python number six python has a private
Heap space where it stores all the
objects the python memory manager
manages various aspects of this Heap
like sharing caching segmentation and
allocation the user has no control over
the Heap only the python interpreter has
the access you have a nice little
diagram here here's your program there's
your interpreter we have our Heap memory
management on the garbage collector
going off of there number seven are
arguments in Python pass by value or by
reference arguments are passed in Python
by reference this means that any change
made within a function is reflected on
the original object so you can see here
def function of l l of zero equals three
L equals one two three four function L
print L and you're going to get three
two three four because we've passed l in
there so it's a pointer here we have def
function l l equals three two three four
L equals one two three four function of
L print L because in this function I
have assigned instead of operating on a
piece of L the list I've consigned a
whole new value to that list or L it
then at that points will create a new
object so if I make changes to the
object it's going to change it in the
outside the definition if I use a
variable and I ass cited a completely
new value like L equals three two three
four that will not show up when you're
outside the function number eight How
would would you Generate random numbers
in Python to generate not random numbers
in Python you must first import the
random module the random function
generates a random float value between 0
and 1. the random range function
generates a random number within a given
range and you can see here one is the
lower end times the upper end and step
two so it'd be one three five and so on
as far as the options in the random
generation number nine what does the
double forward slash operator do in
Python the forward slash operator
performs Division and Returns the
quotient in float for example five over
two returns 2.5 to do a double forward
slash operator on the other hand Returns
the quotient in integer for example 5
double slash returns two five divided by
two and you drop the point five number
ten what does the is operator do the is
operator compares the ID of the two
objects and you can see in here where
list one equals brackets around one two
three list one equals list two equals
true and you have the double equals in
Python of course and you can do list one
is list two where list two equals one
two three is false list two is not the
brackets one two three it equals it but
it's not the brackets and if we do list
three equals list one then list one is
list three equals true number eleven
what is the purpose of pass statement
the past statement is used when there's
a syntactic but not an operational
requirement for example the program
below prints a string ignoring the
spaces and so here we have variable
equals simply learned we've added two
spaces in it for I and variable so it
goes through each eye if I equals space
do nothing else print I and then we'll
have the end equals bracket bracket and
they'll print out Simply learn now of
course you would probably write this if
I does not equal blank space print but
this would be another way you could do
that if you need to play placeholder for
that first logical set or that first
area you can also do a function like
this you could do function whatever your
def function name brackets colon pass so
it goes into the function and does
nothing but it's a placeholder number 12
how will you check all the characters in
a string are alphanumeric python has an
inbuilt method is all number which
returns true if all characters in The
String are alpha numeric and so you can
see here A B C D one two three is all
number output equals true and the second
line a b c d the at symbol one two three
the pound symbol is all NuMe output
equals false so really just want to know
about is all new all numerical
alphanumerical number 12 how will you
check if all characters in a string are
alphanumeric so here we go if you know
is all number which returns that the
characters in The String are
alphanumeric one can also use rejects
instead and so we have Boolean Ari much
what's important about this is to note
your capital a dash to capital z a
lowercase to dash to Z 0 to 9 means that
that array includes all of those the way
they have it written out plus a dollar
sign and then we have what we're
comparing it to the string we're
comparing to the ABCD one two three and
so we can do an re dot match and if it
matches if all these things if all the
different entities in that array matches
the first one we'll get an output true
and if not an output false number 13 how
will you merge elements in a sequence
sequence there are three types of
sequences in Python there's lists tuples
and strings python equation makes this
easy if we have a list one and list two
and list one is square brackets one
comma two comma three list two is four
five and six we can simply do list one
plus list two and our output is one two
three four five six if we have tuples
your Tuple is the curve brackets
designates it and again just add them
together here same thing with strings we
have simply learn S1 plus S2 equals
simply learn number 14 how will you
remove all leading white space in a
string python provides the inbuilt
function L strip to remove all leading
access from a string and you can see
here space space python dot L strip
leading strip Python and you can also do
strip which leaves leading and ending of
course there's also the ending set
number 15 how will you replace all
occurrences of a substring with a new
string the replace function can be used
with strings for replacing a substring
with a given string syntax string dot
replace old comma new comma count
replace returns a new string without
modifying the original string hey John
how are you John question mark replace
John with capital j o h n one and then
you can see right here hey John how are
you and since we designated with the one
just says we're only going to replace
one of these 6 16 what is the difference
between Del and remove brackets on lists
Del for delete Dell removes all elements
of a list within a given range syntax
Dell list start to end remove remove
brackets removes the first occurrence of
a particular character syntax list
remove element and we see a nice example
over here if we delete the list one to
three it will delete the first in this
case b one two it doesn't do three
remember that one two so it will delete
B and C and you end up with a d where if
we do remove B from the list and we have
an a b b d it's only going to remove the
first B number 17 how to display the
contents of text file in reverse order
open the file using the open function
store the contents of the file into a
list reverse the contents of the list
run a for Loop to iterate through the
list number 18. differential between
append and extend append adds an element
to the end of the list you can see right
here we have a list one two three four
and we have pinned four and we end up
with an output one two three four and
extend adds an element from an interval
to the end of the list and we have here
list equals one two three list dot
extend four five six output is one two
three four five six so if you want to
append an array to the end of another
array you want to use the extend number
19. what's the output of the below code
justify your answer this is a great
interview question because these are the
kind of things that come up when you're
proofing code def add to list value and
list so we have value in and a list in
or List equals an empty in this case an
empty list list data pin value return
list list one equals add to list one
list two equals add to list one two
three empty bracket list three equals
add to list a and then we want to print
them list one equals and you can see the
formatting we have a placeholder list
one list two and list three so when it
prints list one we to get 1 comma a and
what you want to notice here is that
list one and list three are equal why
are they equal well when we passed the
information to the add to list we passed
value without passing the list equals
brackets without passing a second value
what this means is that list as we have
it if you don't have a list it'll start
off with empty list which we append the
one to the second one list two we
appended a value to an empty list so
we're only going to be one two three
doesn't matter what the list was before
we've already assigned an empty list and
then list three here's the tricky one
we're adding a to the list but because
we didn't designate the list list is a
shared value in other words it doesn't
reset it and we end up with list one
equals list three one comma a default
list is created only once during the
function and not during its call number
20 what is the difference between a list
and a tuple lists are mutable while
tuples are immutable and you can see an
example down here where I have list
equals one two three square brackets
denote it's a list list of two equals
four and I print it out I now have one
two four if I do the same thing with the
Tuple I get an error because you can't
change the Tuple one two three into one
two four you have to completely reassign
Tuple to a new value what is Doc string
in Python doc strings are used in
providing documentation to various
python modules classes functions and
methods and so you can see here we have
def for a function add a b and this is a
doc string we have the triple brackets
on there you can add carriage return in
that so that you can go multiple lines
and it says this function adds two
numbers and then sum a b returns some
and so we have down here two different
ways of accessing this function output
accessing docstring method one this
function adds two numbers accessing
dockstring method two help on function
add in model main this function adds two
numbers and so you can see the code down
here has two very different in values
the second one is basically a help menu
there's our help menu number 22 how to
use print without the new line the
solution to this depends on the python
version you are using in Python version
2 you can do print Hi and then you add a
comma afterwards print how are you and
you have Hi how are you in version 3
print hi comma end equals and it'll add
a space on the end there you can put
different characters in there but
generally you just want to put a space
put a space on the End Print how are you
and now we get Hi how are you number 23
how do you use the split function in
Python the split function splits a
string into a number of strings based on
a specific delimiter so we have string
split delimiter comma Max the maximum
number of splits the character based on
which the string is to split by default
is space so here we have an example we
have a variable red blue green orange
and we want to split it by commas and we
only want to do the first two so if we
print the list now you'll find it has
red blue and only spread it split it the
first two times and it gets to the third
one and just groups them all together
green and orange if you leave the two
off you'll split the whole thing number
24 is python object oriented or
functional programming python follows
object oriented Paradigm and you should
really know in depth what they mean by
object-oriented Paradigm if you're doing
any interview for scripting languages
python allows the creation of objects
and is manipulation through specific
methods it supports most of the features
of oops which as inheritance on a
polymorphism so you have an object and
you can inherit all the traits of that
object and then add new traits in or
alter some of those traits that's what
object oriented means python follows
functional programming Paradigm
functions may be used as first class
object python supports Lambda functions
which are characteristic of functional
Paradigm so you can set a variable to a
function as opposed to setting it to an
object number 25 write a function
prototype that takes variable number of
arguments here we have def function name
list so we could have in this case
whatever the list is Def function the
asterisk denotes so we're going to take
multiple arguments of a variable and we
can do for I and VAR print I so if you
send function of one you'll end up with
a one function one two five six it'll
actually print those out one at a time
the first one just prints out a one
because it only sent one variable the
second one will print one another line
25 another line 6. number 26 what is
asterisk args and asterisks quarks args
used in function prototype to accept
varying number of arguments it's an
iterable object death function arcs and
you can imagine it's just a basic list
so if I send add the numbers a comma b
or a comma B comma C it doesn't really
matter it will have that number of
objects in it whatever I send to it and
there's other uses for it but that's
very basic quarks I can actually tell it
what I want to send so used in a
function prototype and to accept varying
number of keyworded arguments it's in
both our iterable objects so you can go
through them one at a time and the def
function chords you can now set like
color equals red units equal two so
you'll see that especially in machine
learning there's a lot of like they'll
have inline equals true that kind of
thing number 27 in Python functions are
first class objects what do you
understand from this this means I could
return a function if you went from
another function I could create a
function and treat it just like an
object I can assign it to a variable I
can pass them as arguments to other
functions number 28 what is the output
of print nay underscore underscore name
and justify your answer the double
underscore name double underscore is a
special variable that holds the name of
the current module program execution
starts from main or a code with zero
indentation thus double underscore name
double underscore name has a value
double underscore main double underscore
in the above case if the file is
imported from another module then double
underscore name underscore double
underscore holds the name of this module
number 29 what is a numpy array and we
briefly touched numpy array compared to
a list early in processing speed now
let's go ahead and look at some of the
more specifics a numpy array is a grid
of values all of the same type so if
they're either all float all integer all
string and is indexed by a tuple of
non-negative integers the number of
Dimensions is the rank of the array and
the shape of an array is a tuple of
integers giving the size of the array
along each Dimension number 30 what is
the difference between matrices and
arrays a matrix comes from linear
algebra and is a two-dimensional
representation of data it comes with a
powerful set set of mathematical
operations that allow you to manipulate
the data in interesting ways now arrays
an array is a sequence of objects of
similar data type an array within
another array forms a matrix like we
said here two-dimensional so if you have
an array of three by four that would be
a matrix number 31 how to get indexes of
n maximum values in a numpy array of
course the first thing to do is to
import your numpy as NP you don't
necessarily have to use MP but that is
the most standard use of numpy we create
our array equals an NP dot array of one
two three four five and then if we want
to get our indexes of n at maximum
values in an empty array we can do one
way to do it is to take our array sort
it then do minus in colon that means
we're going to do once you've sorted it
you can do minus in in would equal then
the number of indices so it's not the
actual letter N colon and really this is
about understanding this notation that
we can sort it so it goes from lowest to
biggest and then we can get the top
values for n indexes and then we have
our final set of brackets with the minus
one on there number 32 how would you
obtain the resulting set from the train
set and the test set from below and
let's go ahead and look at the two
different variables we have train set
equals an array of one two three test
set equals a numpy of Ray of arrays we
have 0 1 2 1 2 3. what's important here
is that one it's a numpy so that leaves
a out and then we're stuck with three
other options and I'm going to say d is
out none of these and let's look at NP
dot concatenate versus NP dot v stack
concatenate would put one set after the
other so you would end up with probably
give you an error because one set is one
two three and then we're going to
concatenate array 0 1 2 and 1 array one
two three the array of arrays onto the
end of that what we really want to do is
stack and by the way you can actually
switch there's variables you can put
into concatenate obviously they can
change this so you could use the
concatenate with a lot of fudging around
but really we're looking for is v-stack
v stands for vertical versus the h-stack
which is horizontal and if we do a
v-stack we can simply do train set comma
test set and stack them together and so
we have C resulting set equals np.v
stack train stack test set both option A
and B would do horizontal stacking but
we would like to have the vertical
stacking option she does this again you
could add the axes in and use the
concatenate to stack it the correct way
number 33 how would you import a
decision Tree classifier in sklearn We
have
sklearn.decision tree import decision
tree classifier from sklearn Ensemble
import decision tree classifier and we
look at these and they're all import
decision tree classifier that actually
last part happens to be correct and it's
really just a vocabulary knowing where
is the decision tree class a fire stored
what module is that a part of and it is
of course part of the sklearn.tree
number c number 34 you have uploaded the
data set in CSV format on Google
spreadsheet and shared it publicly how
can you access this in Python what's
important here is to know that we can
read stuff with pandas so we don't show
it here but you can there's actually a
number of ways to do this what's
important here is to know a couple
things one we have our link generated
from the Google Docs and spreadsheets
and then we can do a string IO dot
string IO request get link dot content
so there's our source and then finally
we know that pandas can read a CSV
there's obviously many ways to read a
CSV but data equals pd.read underscore
CSV Source number 35 what is the
difference between the two data series
given below below we have DF name and DF
location colon comma brackets around
name comma where and then we have EF
equals PD data frame AABB x x u u comma
21 1650 33 columns equal name and age so
let's take a look and see what they're
looking at we have just glancing at the
questions they want to know is it the
original data frame or is it the copy of
the data frame and you can see here that
one is view the original data frame and
two is a copy of the original data frame
two is a view of the original data frame
and one is a copy the original data
frame both are copies both are views and
if you're working with pandas you know
that unless you specifically in certain
things tell it to do it inline and a lot
of functions don't allow you that you're
always taking a slice and it is always a
copy so C both are copies of the
original data frame number 36 you get
the following error while trying to read
a file temp.csv using pandas which of
the following could correct it so here's
our error Trace back most recent call
last file input line and one in module
Unicode encode error ASCII codex can't
encode character oh I hate it when that
one comes up and we have four different
entries we'll go ahead and just pretend
that D doesn't exist unless we really
can't fit it into one of the other
answers and the first one is PD read CSV
has our file compression equals gzip
well gzip is just an unzipping and you
actually get a zip error on there the
second one is dialect equals string
again not an encoding or coding setup
and then we have encoding equals utf-8
well that would be the encoding error
switching it from the character code
there's utf-8 there is Unicode that's
the most common two that goes between so
really this is about understanding the
difference between a utf-8 coding and a
unit code and the error that comes up
quite regularly with that number c
encoding should be utf-8 number 37 how
to set a line with in a plot given below
so looking at this we have import plot
Library Pi plot is PLT and you should
know your way around this how to do a
plot in there
plt.plot1234 plot equals show and so
this is a little bit of a vocabulary
test the vocabulary is at width equals
three line width equals three LW equals
three or something else and the
vocabulary word that we're looking for
is LW equals three which stands for line
width in pi plot Library Pi plot Number
38 how would you reset the index of a
data frame to a given list so this is a
vocabulary Challenge and understanding
what re-indexing is re-indexing as we
have the different values here we have
the first one which is reset the index
well we're not really resetting the
index re-index number b means we're
double checking our indexes to the
column and to the main index and so the
values match correctly where re-index
like now brings in a new index outside
of our data frame to a given list so
this is coming from external and thus
the vocabulary word like is our key word
that is external and we have a data
print into a given list number 39 how
can you copy objects in Python the
functions used to copy objects in Python
we have copy copy for shallow copying
and copy deep copying for deep copy
number 40 what is the difference between
range and X range functions in Python
well this is a good one we have matrixes
and arrays with a matrix the range
returns a python list object X range
returns an X range object and with
arrays an x-ray returns an x-range
object X range creates values as you
need them through yielding the key here
is that X range Returns the values as
you need them so it actually processes
it post like if you have for x or for a
variable in X range it is processing
them as you need them zero to nine it
doesn't create an array zero to nine it
just hands you zero then one two three
four one at a time number 41 how can you
check whether a pandas data frame is
empty or not the tribute df.empty is
used to check whether a panda's data
frame is empty or not and so you can
simply create a we have down here in
Porter pandas's PD we create our Panda's
data frame equal to an empty array and
is DF dot empty comes out as true one of
the catches you got to remember with
these vocabularies is with empty along
with some other pandas set up whether
you need the brackets or not at the end
number 42 write the code to sort an
array in numpy by the N minus oneth
column this can be achieved using ARG
sort function let's take an array X then
to sort the N minus 1 column the code
will be X to X to colon n minus two dot
args sort so let's see what that code
looks like we import numpy as NP we'll
create our array our numpy array which
is uh one two three zero five two two
three four so we have three different
entities with three different columns in
there and we go X of X and so we take X
of all the rows first entity well in
this case it's actually the second one
because it's zero one two dot ARG sort
so that would be the second entity or
minus two would also be the same you
could also do instead of one you could
also do minus two there instead of the
one our sort and then we get an output
of the array one two three zero five two
two three four number 43 how to create a
series from a list numpy array and
dictionary so we'll go ahead and input
import our numpy our pandas and have my
list and see here we have my list equals
list of a b c d e f g over all the way
through so my list now makes a list of
that for array we have NP dot a range to
26 my dictionary will create a
dictionary with a zip my list my
arguments so I'll just use the numpy
array we just created with my array to
go into the dictionary and the solution
is simple with the PD dot series my list
pd.series my array PD dot series my
dictionary so it's all about knowing the
dot Capital s-e-r-i-e-s don't forget
that capitalization number 44 how to get
the items not common to both series a
and series B and you can see here we
have instead of series A and B we have
series one and two and we have one two
three four five four five six seven
eight the solution is we take a panda
series we have a series U equals a panda
series NP Union one dimension series one
series two so we can now make a union of
them we now have series one Panda series
with an intersection and then we can
remove one from the other series U is
series U dot is in series one so if the
union is not in the intersection then
you know it's a unique value a little
bit of logic going on there I'm playing
with three different terms to get the
answer we want 45 how to keep only the
top two most frequent values as it is
and replace everything else as other in
a series so again we're working with
pandas because if you're talking series
and data frames that means we're working
with pandas so we're going to import
pandas as PD we'll go ahead and create
our Panda series we're going to do that
by creating a numpy random random State
100 so 100 in the numpy one and then we
have our Panda series you can see here
where random integer numpy random not
random integer one comma five by twelve
and so the solution for this is we go
ahead and we've created a PDF remember
the capital S Series solution we're
going to print the top two frequencies
and that is our series dot value counts
and then we take series values count dot
index of up to two so we're going to
take everything up to two and then we'll
do the series is in so if it's not in
the first two then it's going to equal
other and this would be something you'd
want to write down on paper if you're if
it looks confusing take a moment pause
the video write this down and see if you
can figure out how the logic came
together and try to throw yourself a
couple other little logic puzzles like
this number 46 how to find the positions
of numbers that are multiples of 3 from
a series and in here we're actually
going to use a numpy to solve it the
first part series lets you know it's
going to be a panda series and if we
come down here we have NP dot ARG where
this is a vocabulary question series
with remember the percentile 3 is the
remainder so if the remainder equals
zero then we're going to generate that
ring where the object divided by three
equals zero has no remainder so then we
know it's a multiple of three number 47
how would you compute the euclidean
distance between
theories and this one's really cool
because we have our Panda series uh p
and Q and what I like about this one is
they give us two solutions you can go
with and really you should kind of know
both the first one would be yes you know
what the euclidean distance is and that
is we can take the first series minus
the second series squared and then sum
them up and then we do the square root
which is the same as taking the power to
0.5 doing the power to 0.5 is easier
than doing the square root so a lot of
times you'll see that as a switch but
you could have also done the square root
and use the math in there so there's
solution one you should know your
euclidean distance and then solution two
is the numpy solution so we have NP dot
Lin alga.norm that's how we're going to
compute our euclidean distance
P minus Q very elegant and very
straightforward and easy to compute
number 48 how to reverse the rows of
data frame so here we have our data
frame we're going to create a numpy
array by 25 reshape it 5 minus one when
this creates a 25 by 25 data frame and
so our solution is to do the DFI
location and this is just understanding
how steps work the steps you have your
colon colon -1 so we're taking all the
rows all the columns minus one so our
stepping -1 going the reverse Direction
and then we're just going to use across
all the different columns on there let
me say that again the first colon is
going to be your row starting row
stopping row step minus one that's all
this is about is that step minus one
comma and then all the columns 49 if you
split your data into train test splits
is it possible to overfit your model and
the answer is yes is definitely possible
one common beginner mistake is retuning
a model or training new models with
different parameters after seeing his
performance on the test set my favorite
example of this is you have your script
put together and you keep hitting the
rerun button until you get the answer
you want not taking the answer it first
gave you or running it over an array and
recording all the answers to see how
they vary number 50 which python library
is built on top of matplot library and
pandas to ease data plotting the answer
this is Seaborn Seabourn is a data
visualization library in Python that
provides a high level interface for
drawing statistical information
informative graphs so thank you all for
watching this session on python
developer full course I hope this video
was useful and informative if you have
any questions then please feel free to
put them in the comment section A team
will help you solve your queries stay
safe and keep learning